EVERYONE WELL TO THE ASSEMBLY
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
HEARING DUE TO THE- CONTINUES
TO HEAD HOME ORDER WE'RE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
OUR SERVER ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE A
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. OUR ALSO
REQUIRE THE MAST BE WORN AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE YOU HAVE
AMASSED WHICH PROVIDE ONE FOR
YOU- AND WE DO HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS WILL WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. AFTER THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM THE. WE ARE
IN A ROOM FOR THIRTY SEVEN-
AGAIN BECAUSE COME A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC.
AND MEDIA TO MAINTAIN THAT-
SIXTY DISPLACING. OTHERS ALSO
STRICT FISCAL DISCIPLINE
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM-
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM LIKE TESTIFIED IN A
BILL. PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND-
THAT BILL AS- WELL AS- THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT. PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. BEGINS AND I'LL ASK
YOU TO PUSH THE MICROPHONE. AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I ASK THE
PUBLIC TO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE- YOU CAN. THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING WILL RETURN YOUR
SEATS. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVERS GO DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL. INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON I TALKED. FOR DIALING
WITNESSES WE WILL BE OF ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED. TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
IF YOU'RE CALLING IN TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE ASK YOU. UP
ONLY STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL. WE DO ANTICIPATE A
HIGH CALL CALL VOLUME TODAY'S
WILL BE VERY IMPORTANT. I TO
JUST- IF YOU'RE NOT ONE OF THE
KEY WITNESS IS YOU JUST CALLING
TO OFFER SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION.
AND JUST NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL. THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE. IS POUND ONE THREE
OR IS ONE THREE ONE BY FOUR
THREE SEVEN. I HAD ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE FIVE FOUR THREE.
AGAIN AND EIGHT SEVEN SO NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE. YOU CAN
ALSO BUY THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY CAN WEB. THAT BE FOUND
A B. E. R. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA
DOT GOV. A. L. B. R. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT G. O. V. AS
WELL AS ON THE TV SCREEN. FOR
CALLING IN. PLEASE PLAN TO DO
SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON HIS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. SO DON'T CALL IN
BEFORE THEN BUT CERTAINLY WAS
THE BILL PRESENTATION BEGINS
WHETHER. THAT POINT WOULD BE TO
PUT A POINT TO CALL IN. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU ARE SUPPORT. ORACLE
OPPOSITION TO A BILL. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING. YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST ENTERS MORE DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND. DISTORTION
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED IF
YOU'RE A MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST A
BILL. YOU WILL REMAIN ON THE
LIVE LINE AND WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF. UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED
ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY. THE MODERATOR SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THIS COMMITTEE. AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
TWO ZERO NINE ONE. AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP. I
ALSO WANNA NOTE THAT WE'RE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE
ALSO HAVE AN EMAIL ADDRESS SET
UP. THAT YOU CAN USE TO EMAIL
US YOUR TESTIMONY. THE EMAIL IS
A L. B. R. DOT COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV AGAIN
THE EMAIL IS. A L. B. R.
DOCUMENTING. THAT ASSEMBLY DOT
CA DOT. G. O. V. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL. OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL FACE-
THEN AT THIS TIME MADAM
SECRETARY BEFORE I ASK YOU TO
TAKE WILL IN THE STATUS QUO I
DO WANT TO THANK A SUMMER. MARK
STONE- FOR BEING WITH US TODAY.
I REALLY APPRECIATE. YOUR YOUR
ABILITY TO. JOIN AND HEAR THESE
BILLS I THINK THE LEAST- WANTED
TO WILL BE. HEADING YOUR
COMMITTEE SO MIGHT BE A GOOD-
PREVIEW AS WELL. SO WITH THAT
THE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE THE
ROLE TO. KERR KALRA I'M SURE
GONZALEZ I'M SORRY YOUR PHONE
SANTIAGO YES LORD YOUR A ON THE
STOP WITH THE. NINE OKAY YOU
KNOW AFFECT- IF IT YOU KNOW OF.
BE THE MODERATOR ON FOR THE
PHONE OF GETTING WE'RE GETTING
NOISE FROM THE PHONE IF WE CAN
MAKE SURE IT'S- NOT ON RIGHT
NOW EMAIL IT. HELLO YES EVER
WORKING ON A RIGHT NOW MY
APOLOGIES OKAY. THANK YOU.
OKAY- AND SO WE'VE ESTABLISHED
QUORUM NOW IF WE COULD HAVE A
MOTION TO ADOPT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THERE'S JUST TWO BILLS
I CONSENT AB SIX FORTY THREE
RAMOS AND AB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE BUT WE GUESS. EMOTIONS
SOME REWARDS ARE SECOND SECOND
SUMMER STONE- MADAM SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL ROLE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MOTION IS DUE PASS
CONSENT. TO APPROPRIATIONS.
KALRA HI KALRA HI FLORA
GONZALEZ JONES SAWYER- JONES
SAWYER HI STONE RIGHT STONE I
SEE ART OKAY HI SEATTLE FIVE
WARD WARD I CONSENT CALENDARS
ADOPTED THANK YOU SO MUCH- AND
THE SUMMER GET THE SENATE OVER
GONZALEZ ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THANK YOU HI. OKAY SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT THE SINK
COUNTERS PASS AND NOW ON TO THE
AND BEFORE WE GET TO THE
PRESENT AS WELL NOTHING WE DO
HAVE A ONE THIRTY TWO PM BREAK
TWO PM WE HAVE A BILL BEING
HEARD TIME CERTAIN LESSONS MUCH
AS WE CAN BEFORE ONE THIRTY AND
THEN WE'LL HEAR THAT PARTICULAR
BILL INTO AND THEN WE'LL KEEP
MOVING THROUGH- SO WITH THAT
FILE ITEM OF ONE IS AB TEN
THIRTY THREE. A SIMILAR ABOUT
CAMPING YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE-
AND YOU MAY BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB TEN THIRTY THREE.
THE BILL THAT WOULD REQUIRE
MEDIATION. THE FIRST STEP IN
EMPLOYEE SMALL EMPLOYER
DISAGREEMENTS ON PAID FOR BY
MICHAEL. I'M PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
SHOULD BE OKAY WELL YOU MIGHT
WANT ONE I TRIED WILL BE A
LITTLE BIT MOVING THAT LITTLE
BIT CLOSER TO. I THINK I THINK
THAT. THANK YOU UNPAID UNPAID
FAMILY LEAVE SAVING TIME FOR
QUICKER RESOLUTION AND MONEY ON
COSTLY LITIGATION LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR HANNAH
BETH JACKSON SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE EXPANDED THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY RIGHTS ACT IT NOW
APPLIES TO CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH JUST FIVE OR
MRE EMPLOYEES. DUE TO CONCERNS
ABOUT COSTLY LITIGATION IN
SMALL BUSINESSES ABILITY TO
COMPLY WITH THE MANDATE IN THAT
EFFORT THE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHED THE SMALL EMPLOYER
FAMILY LEAVE MEDIATION PILOT
PROGRAM IN BUDGET BILL AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN. AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN WE'RE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING CHARGES BEEN FILED FOR
A VIOLATION OF CFRA AGAINST
EMPLOYER WITH FIVE TO NINETEEN
EMPLOYEES THE EMPLOYEE OR
EMPLOYER WOULD NEED TO REQUEST
MEDIATION WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF
RECEIVING A COPY OF THE RIGHT
TO SUE NOTICE. THE CURRENT
PROBLEM IS THAT EMPLOYERS DO
NOT RECEIVE A COPY OF THE RIGHT
TO SUE NOTICES UNTIL AFTER
LAWSUIT HAS BEEN FILED.
UNDERMINING THE PURPOSE OF THE
PROGRAM THIS FAILURE OF THE
EMPLOYER TO RECEIVE THE LETTERS
FOR GOOD REASON. THE EMPLOYEE
MAY DECIDE NOT TO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON FILING A LAWSUIT AND
DOESN'T WANT THE EMPLOYER TO
KNOW THAT THEY ALMOST FILED A
LAWSUIT. AB TEN THIRTY THREE
CORRECT THIS ISSUE. BY HAVING
THE EMPLOYEE CONTACT THE F. PH
IS MEDIATION PROGRAM IF THEY
DECIDE THEY DO WANT TO PROCEED
WITH A LAWSUIT. AND THEN D. F.
E. H. WILL CONTACT THE EMPLOYER
TO RANGE THE MEDIATION WITHIN
THE NEXT SIXTY DAYS. IF BOTH
PARTIES AGREE MEDIATION WOULD
BE FRUITLESS THEY NEED NOT
PARTICIPATE. SECONDLY THE BILL
ALSO CLARIFIES THAT EDUCATION
SHOULD HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO
MEDIATION UNDER THE PROGRAM BUT
WAS NOT. THE EMPLOYER CAN ASK
TO STAY THE PENDING ACTION GO
THROUGH MEDIATION. TODAY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT I HAVE ASHLEY
HOFFMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE COMMERCE
AND KEVIN FOR DRAHI WITH NFIB.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND EACH
WITNESS OF WILL HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES. AND SO WE CAN GO AHEAD
THEN AND BEGIN WITH- ASHLEY
HOFFMAN IF YOU'RE READY TO GO
ON THE PHONE TO MAYBE CAN. GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
ACTUALLY HOPPIN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE A PROUD SPONSOR AS AT
TEN THIRTY THREE- AB TEN THIRTY
THREE IS REALLY INTENDED TO
CLEAN UP AN ALREADY EXISTING
MEDIATION PROGRAM THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED LAST YEAR IS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED.
WHEN SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
WAS BEING DISCUSSED TO EXPAND
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHTS
ACT THE SMALL BUSINESSES THERE
WERE SOME CONCERNED ABOUT THE
EFFECT THE POTENTIAL LITIGATION
ON THE SMALL BUSINESSES. AND
THEY LEARN TO IMPLEMENT C. FOR
A WHICH COMES WITH QUITE
LENGTHY AND COMPLEX
REGULATIONS. AND AGREEMENT
THEREFORE WAS MADE TO ESTABLISH
A NOVEL SMALL EMPLOYER FAMILY
NEEDS MEDIATION PILOT PROGRAM
THROUGH THE D. S. B. H. UNDER
THAT PROGRAM AT THE C. FOR
RELATED COMPLAINT WAS FILED
AGAINST THE SMALL BUSINESS WITH
FEWER THAN TWENTY EMPLOYEES
EITHER PARTY COULD REQUESTED
THE PARTIES FIRST MEDIATE THAT.
WE GET THE CLAIM HERE THAT THE
FAA. BEFORE A LAWSUIT CAN BE
FILED. AT THAT PROGRAM DOES
SEVEN TEN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
AT THE ISSUE AS STATED WITH THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE IS THAT YOU
REQUEST MEDIATION. AND A THIRTY
DAYS OF RECEIVING A COPY OF THE
RIGHT. YOU KNOW THAT HOWEVER.
IN EMPLOYER. ACTUALLY RIGHT.
THEREFORE I'M SORRY BACK
POLICIES- AND IF SO IF SOMEONE
BECAUSE IN A WHERE DOES NOT
ACTUALLY A COPY OF THE RIGHT TO
DO NOT A THEY ARE A TO UTILIZE
THE PRO YOUR THEY DON'T
ACTUALLY SEE A COP OF THE RIGHT
TO DO NOT AND TELL THE- USUALLY
IT'S NOT EVEN A TO THE CA AND
AN EMPLOYER DOES NEXT GET IT
TELL. THAT OF WHAT YOU CAN
THREE IS THAT PROVIDES THAT
WHEN EMPLOYEE WOULD LIKE TO
COURSE ACTIVE STATUS CONTACT
WITH THE IF EACH SHE MEDIATION-
IN TO FIX THE MEDIA PRO THE
BILL ALSO AND PARENTS OF A LOT
TO THE LIST THAT THE THAT NEED
CAN TAKE CARE FOR AND RISKY
FOR- THIS IS INTENDED TO BEING
BASS YEAR IN THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE BUT DUE TO AN ERROR IN
THE LANGUAGE- EXTRACTED IT
WOULD NOT AND WE WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHORS OFFICE AS WELL AS
THE LAST- WORKING GOOD FAITH
THE BEST TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU KNOW I HAD
ABOUT HOW MEDIATION OPERATES IN
THE TIGHTENING. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FINAL DETAILS
YESTERDAY AND ALSO THIS
MORNING- ANTICIPATING TO HAVE
THOSE WORKED OUT VERY VERY
SOON- I'M HAPPY TO ASK ANY
QUESTION ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THOSE AMENDMENTS- BUT WE
DO INTEND TO CONTINUE TO WORK
AND GET PAID ON THAT- AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THE BILL MAY MOVE FORWAD
AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
OF NEXT KEVIN PODR ATTY IF
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE. YOU MAY
BEGIN UP TO TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU- GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS- KEVIN TO DRAW THE ON
BEHALF. OF AND- WE WRAP. UPPER
FIFTEEN TO. SO BUSINESS. IN THE-
OF CALIFORNIA. MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES. ARE STILL SUFFERING
FROM THE RESULT OF TOTAL BED.
BATH SMALL BUSINESSES DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO HUMAN RESOURCE
PERSONNEL. OR LEGAL COUNSEL IN
THE SAME WAY IF MANY LARGE
BUSINESSES. WHEN THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY RIGHTS ACT WAS EXPANDED
LAST YEAR. NO SMALL BUSINESSES
HAD TO LEARN. A NEW COMPLEX SET
OF REGULATIONS AND HOW TO
PROPERLY ADMINISTER TRACK AND
DOCUMENT THAT LEAVES. DUE TO
THE HIGH RISK OF INADVERTENT
ERRORS THAT CAN BE MADE A SMALL
EMPLOYERS LEARN THIS NEW LEAVE
PROGRAM. AND THE FINANCIAL
IMPACT EVEN ONE LAWSUIT CAN
HAVE ON A BUSINESS. THE SMALL
EMPLOYER FAMILY LEAVE.
MEDIATION PROGRAM. IS IMPORTANT
TO SMALL BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. AB TEN THIRTY THREE
AM SHARE SOME PLAYERS ARE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE PROGRAM BY FIXING THE
WAY THE MEDIATION. IS INITIATED
UNDER THE PROGRAM. WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO SUPPORT AB TEN THIRTY
THREE. AM THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU- THAT'S GOING THEN
AND MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT
AND AGAIN JUST ASK THAT YOU SEE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IF ANY
AND POSITION ON THE BILL. AND
WE CAN START IN THE ROOM.
ANYONE IN SUPPORT. WELL YEAH
WITH MICROPHONE SET UP THEIR.
YEAH DON'T PLEASE UNDERSTANDING.
THANKS MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CRISTINA KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF
THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT. IF NOT
A LONG WE GO OVER TO. THE FONTS
IS ANYONE ON THE PHONES IN
SUPPORT AND THIS IS A B. TEN
THIRTY THREE BARRICADE HAN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
AB TEN THIRTY THREE MY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU AREN'T
SUPPORT OF AB TEN THIRTY THREE.
AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
LITTLE- DYLAN GIVENS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE
LINE OF SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MARK THE DATE WITH A
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY SO SHE'S MORE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AN EXCEL GO TO LINE OF EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EIGHTY
NINE TEN WITH A CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WE ARE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. WOULD JUST
HAVE TO GET THEIR LINE NUMBER.
AND AGAIN WE'RE ON AB TEN
THIRTY THREE IN SUPPORT. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORNING MICHAEL OVER THE
CALIFORNIA'S PROTECTION OF
WHITE PAPERS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
IT'S A FAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY SO
MOVING ON TO OPPOSITION WE
DON'T HAVE ANY LISTED WERE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HOWEVER
WE WILL TAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR THOSE OPPOSE- AGAIN- THE
CITY NAME AFFILIATION POSITION
ON THE BILL SO ANYONE IN THE
ROOM IN OPPOSITION TO AB TEN
THIRTY THREE. KAMALA MODERATOR
IF WE CAN GO OVER TO THE- PHONE
LINES TO SEE THERE'S ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE
NOT THE VISION OF AB TEN THIRTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO NOW. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FAIR IN OPPOSITION OF TEN.
R. A. B. TEN THIRTY THREE.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THE
SUMMER GONZALEZ I'M GONNA VOTE
FOR THIS TODAY I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT THE VERBIAGE THAT IS
BEING USED TO MAYBE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE WORKED ON
INTRODUCED MAYBE I'M NOT
READING IT CORRECTLY BUT IT
APPEARS THAT IT IT. FORCES
MEDIATION AND EVERY STANDPOINT
WHEN MY UNDERSTANDING THE DEAL
THAT WE MADE IT WAS THAT THE-
EMPLOYER COULD REQUEST
MEDIATION BUT THE LANGUAGE OF
THIS BILL REALLY DOES PUT
PEOPLE IN A BIND WHERE THE-
EMPLOYER DOES NOT WANT TO-
ENGAGE IN MEDIATION FOR
WHATEVER REASON MAYBE THEY WENT
THEY'RE NOT RESPONDING TO
THEIR- TO THEIR MALE MAYBE.
THEY'RE THEY'RE JERKS AND ARE
JUST LIKE I DON'T CARE SEE IN
COURT RIGHT BUT I THINK IT'S IT
MIGHT BE A DISTINCTION WITHOUT
A DIFFERENCE FOR MOST CASES
RIGHT WOULD GO TO MEDIATION BUT
IT IT SHOULD NOT BE REQUIRED
MEDIATION IT IS UPON US THE
REQUEST OF THE EMPLOYER. DOES
THAT MAKE SENSE. I THINK
THERE'S- WERE EMPLOYER I THINK
WHAT WE THAT THE MEDIATION. HAS
TO BE ALLOWED UPON REQUEST OF
THE EMPLOYER BUT IT IS NOT
REQUIRED PER OUR DISCUSSIONS AT
LEAST MEDIATION ITSELF WAS NOT
REQUIRED BEFORE FILING A
LAWSUIT THE EMPLOYER JUST HAD
TO HAVE THE RIGHT TO SEEK
MEDIATION BEFORE A LAWSUIT WAS
FILED. SO I WOULD LOVE TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW THAT I'M
FULLY GRASPING WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING BUT I. THINK IT'S- I
MEAN I THINK AND I THINK MAYBE.
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN A YEAR AN
HOUR ANYTHING THIS LAST SPRING
THAT WE HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS MAYBE THAT'S PART
OF WHAT THE PROBLEM IS- I THINK
MY- RECOLLECTION WAS WE WANT TO
BE EMPLOYEE TO BE ABLE TO SEEK
MEDIATION AS WELL WHICH IS PART
OF IT I WAS ASKING YOU AYE. SO
AND WE WANT TO MEDIATION BE
OPEN TO ANYONE WHO DIDN'T WANT
TO GO THROUGH COSTLY LITIGATION
I WANTED TO GET THEIR RIGHT TO
EXERCISE I WOULD HOPE THAT THE
EMPLOYEE WOULD HAVE THAT RIGHT
AS WELL WHICH WE'RE TRYING TO
EXPRESS I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S-
PART OF WHAT YOU'RE GETTING
THAT'S WHY AND I TO GET IN
TROUBLE WITH GIVING. HE RIGHT
TO THEM PLATE AND OR THE
EMPLOYER YOUR ALWAYS THE RIGHT
EXIST WITH EITHER PARTY HOWEVER
I THINK IN A PLANE WE NEED THE
TEXAS SUGGEST THAT MEDIATION IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY BEFORE- A
LAWSUIT WHEN IT DOESN'T IT
DOESN'T ADDRESS A POINT WHERE
YOU MIGHT HAVE AN EMPLOYER AND
EMPLOYEE NEITHER OF WHOM WANT
MEDIATION. OKAY NOW I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE SAYING THANK
YOU MEXICO EVERYBODY SO- WE
TRIED TO ADDRESS THAT I DO
REALLY WANT TO THINK I DON'T
KNOW SEALERS LISTENING BUT I DO
REALLY WANT TO THANK THEM FOR
PARTNERING ON THIS AND WORKING
REALLY HARD TO GET USTO
LANGUAGE THAT GOT US TO WHERE I
THINK WE WERE LAST YEAR AGAIN
THEY WERE. HUGE PROPONENTS OF
THE BILL LAST YEAR. AND THAT'S
PART OF WHY WE PUT THE TIMELINE
GOING TO I MAY MY REMARKS ONE
OF THE WITH GIVING EMPLOYERS
RIGHT IS THEY DON'T GET THE
RIGHT TO SUE LETTER WHICH OF
COURSE FOR GOOD. WE DON'T TO
FLIRT WHAT HAPPENED. RETALIATED
FOR THAT RIGHT TO SUE LETTER
AND SO WE GOOD REASON NAME-
DOESN'T KNOW THAT THIS IS
COMING THE CEREMONY REGULATED
THAT LETTER WANT TO KEEP IT WAY
SOME THE FAA AS BEEN REALLY
ABOUT NINE BROUGH AT. AND SO
HOW DO WE WORK OUT A SYSTEM
WHERE THE EMPLOYER GET THAT ARE.
IN A MEETING FOR WAY- WITHOUT
GETTING A LETTER THAT WAS SORT
OF THE CA. WE WERE STOPPED AND
SO WE DID HERE PERSONALLY IS
AND THE PARTIES CAN AGREE
IMMEDIATELY THAT IT'S GOING TO
BE FOR LESS THAN OF A GRAVE AND
NOBODY GOES TO MEDIATION THE
OTHER THING IS. FOR SOMEONE
WHO'S NOT RESPONDING- THERE'S A
SIXTY DAY WINDOW IF IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN IN SIXTY DAYS YOU GET
THE RIGHT TO SUE SO THOSE WERE
WHAT WE CAME UP WITH C. LEAD TO
REALLY MAKE SURE WE'RE
ADDRESSING WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
SO WE'RE NOT DELAYING THE
LITIGATION WHERE MEDIATION IS
FRUITLESS. OR WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE SO WE DID TRY TO WORK
THAT OUT I DID NOT TWICE. LIES
NOW. NEUTRAL ON THE- IS BECAUSE
THEY- FELT LIKE WE- HAD FOUND.
WAY TO. POP GET A PATH TO THEIR-
WHERE IT'S- BUT ALSO PROVIDE.
MEETING FROM. I'VE BOTH PARTY.
BUT I WOULD LOVE. TO TALK FOR.
IF YOU THINK. WE HAVEN'T. THAT
CORRECTLY. YOU COULD JUST FEEL
IT WHEN I READ IT. IT IT SEEMS.
A BIT CONFUSING ON. THE
REQUIREMENT. OF MEDIATION. I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY I. AM VERY
TRUSTING OF. THE GOOD STAFF.
THAT IT'S- GOING TO GO TO. IN I
THINK THEY WILL HEAR MY
CONCERNS NOW AND IF I'M WRONG
THEY WILL LET YOU KNOW. SO YOU
REALLY GOT- YEAH IT'S- NO I
DON'T HAVE A- HONOR AWARD WAS-
SUCH. OKAY THIS A SECOND FROM
SOME MEMBERS STONE ANY OTHER
QUESTION COMMENT. YES PLEASE
OVER THE SUMMER CENTER. WELL I
THOUGHT THE STONER RT SECOND.
ARE YOU SECOND GOT IT OKAY SO
IT WASN'T SANTIAGO GOT IT SO-
WE HAVE A FOR A WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. AND I'LL
JUST SAY THE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AS WELL AS A SPONSOR OF
THE CHAMBER. OF COMMERCE WERE
WORKING- THERE'S OFTEN A LOT OF
CHANGES THAT HAVE OCCURRED OVER
THE RECENT WEEKS. ON THE BILL
ARE THERE MAY BE FURTHER
CLARIFICATION TO THE SUMMER IS
ALSO A POINT OF THINK WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY. AS A
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASSENGERS
JERRY I DO WANT TO THANK CAELAN
LEGAL AID AT WORK AS WELL.
AFTER WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE. TO GET IT WHERE IT IS
NOW WHICH I THINK IS A MUCH
BETTER PLACE AND SO WITH THAT
IT ISN'T. AN I RECOMMENDATION-
AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECT FAST RIVA THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR STAFF
INCREDIBLE HARD WORK ON THIS AS
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND SO YES I'M A MAN OF
SECRETARY FOR GOING TO A WILL
CALL ON. AB TEN THIRTY THREE.
MOTION AS THE PATH TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE KALRA I KALRA HI
FLORA. FLORA HI GONZALEZ. RIGHT
GONZALEZ SIDE YOU SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER I. FIVE STONE I ARTICLE
I. ZERO HI BOARD. WORD I. RIGHT
THE BILL HAS HAD OVER TO A
JUDICIARY. THE TOUGH CHAIR OVER
THERE. BUT YEAH ALL RIGHT SO ON
TO THEM A COUPLE ITEMS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO. AND SO WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY GO AHEAD AND- MAKE
YOUR WAY UP TO THE TO THE TABLE
HERE WE HAVE AB. SEVEN NINETY
FOUR- WHICH IS A DO PASS TO
TRANSPORTATION RECOMMENDATION
AND WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT TO YOU AB SEVEN NINE
FOUR THE CLIMATE JOBS IN EQUITY
ACT A MEASURE THAT WILL
TRANSFORM CLEAN VEHICLE
INCENTIVES. INTO A TRUE ENGINE
FOR ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
GROWTH OF HIGH QUALITY JOBS FOR
DISADVANTAGED WORKERS BY
ENSURING THE PUT THAT PUBLIC
FUNDING TO MANUFACTURE AND
PURCHASE CLEANER VEHICLES IS
TIED TO LABOR STANDARDS I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE. AND OUR
PARTNERS ON THIS ISSUE I WILL
BE MAKING AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS CLAIMING
INVESTMENTS ARE ESSENTIAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC. LIMA
CHANGE IN ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE STRATEGIES AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE COVER NINETEEN
DOWNTURN IN THE GOVERNOR'S
CLIMB AN EXECUTIVE ORDER. HAVE
MADE THESE INVESTMENTS EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT- THROUGH
ECONOMIC EQUITY AND CLIMATE
TOOLS. THIS BILL INCORPORATES
HIGH ROAD WORK FOR STANDARDS
AND TO CALIFORNIA'S NEW CLEAN
VEHICLE INCENTIVE DOLLARS.
THESE STANDARDS WILL LEVERAGE
HIGH ROAD JOBS FOR
DISADVANTAGED AND DISLOCATED
WORKERS. AND VEHICLE
MANUFACTURING BATTERY
PRODUCTION AND TRUCK DRIVING.
WORKFORCE STANDARDS GUARANTEE
THAT OUR PUBLIC DOLLARS DELIVER
EQUITY TO STRUGGLING CALIFORNIA
WORKERS. AND US CALIFORNIA
JOBS. IN THE CVV TRANSITION
THIS IS BECAUSE STANDARD SOME
PUBLIC DOLLARS INCENTIVIZE
COMPANIES TO PERFORM AT THEIR
BEST DELIVER HIGH QUALITY JOBS
AND TAKE RESPONSIBILITY. FOR
EMISSIONS THE AUTO INDUSTRY IS
A CORNERSTONE. OF AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING JOBS EMPLOYEE
NEARLY TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA AND ONE MILLION
PEOPLE NATIONWIDE. BUT JOB
QUALITY IN THE AUTO INDUSTRY
HAS BEEN COMPROMISED BY OFF
SHORING RELIANCE ON TEMPORARY
WORKERS. ATTACKS ON WORKERS
FREEDOM OF ASSOCIATION AND
WEEKEND HEALTH AND SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT. AND WHEN ADJUSTING
FOR INFLATION WAGES FOR
PRODUCTION WORKERS AN AUTO
ASSEMBLY AND AUTO PARTS OF
DECLINED. BY OVER 20% IN THE
PAST FIFTEEN YEARS. THIS IS WHY
GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIES TO AUTO
COMPANIES NEED TO INCENTIVIZE
HIGH QUALITY JOBS THAT ARE
BASED IN THE UNITED STATES. IN
LOS ANGELES PORT TRUCK DRIVERS
PARK DRIVE PORT DRIVERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE. FOR MOVING ALMOST
HALF OF THE NATION'S CONTAINER
IMPORTS. OUT OF THE ALLEY PORTS
IN CALIFORNIA HAS OTHER ACTIVE
PORTS. WITH MAJOR TRUCKING
OPERATIONS AS WELL- TRUCKING
AND SHORT HAUL TRUCKING
GENERALLY ARE HOME TO A GREGIS
MATH CLASSIFICATION OF
CONTRACTORS BY MAJOR
INTERNATIONAL CORPORATIONS
BETWEEN SEVENTY TO NINETY
PERCENT. OF DRAYAGE TRUCK
DRIVERS ARE MISCLASSIFIED
MAKING THIS THE DOMINANT
BUSINESS MODEL IN THE INDUSTRY.
POLICIES AND INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
TO UPGRADE FLEETS WITHOUT LABOR
STANDARDS PUNISH ARE HARD
WORKING DRIVERS AND ENTRENCH
MISS CLASSIFICATION. USA TODAY
CALLED CONDITIONS OF THE LOS
ANGELES AND LONG BEACH PORTS
MODERN DAY INDENTURED
SERVITUDE. AFTER THE FIRST
CLEAN TRUCK PROGRAM AND OFTEN
TRUCK DRIVERS ARE NEGATIVE
PAYCHECKS BECAUSE THE COMPANIES
CHARGE MORE FOR THE TRUCK
RENTAL THAN DRIVERS EARN. IN
THEIR INCOME. WORK FOR
STANDARDS CAN BEGIN TO SHIFT
THE BUSINESS MODEL AND TRUCKING
FROM EXTREME WORKER
EXPLOITATION AND ENVIRONMENTAL
NON COMPLIANCE TO HIERO JOBS IN
CLEAN VEHICLES THAT DON'T
POLLUTE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. LIKE MINE AS SUCH AB
SEVEN NINE FOUR CREATE THE
PATHWAY TO ENSURE THAT PUBLIC
INVESTMENT IN VEHICLE
MANUFACTURERS AND FLEETS. PER
SERVING GROW HIGH QUALITY US IN
CALIFORNIA JOBS INTO AUTO
MANUFACTURING BY. TYING BY
TYING WORK FOR STANDARDS TWO
INCENTIVE. DOLLARS THERE IS A
LOT OF REALLY GREAT POSITIVE
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE WITH THIS
BILL UNAVAILABLE TO TESTIFY ARE
SHINGLES MAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL AND- SOME APPEL
REPRESENTING THE BLUEGREEN
ALLIANCE FONG. EXCELLENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH- SO A TEST PLANS
PORT EACH WITNESSES WITNESSES
UP TO MINUTES- SO WE HAVE- BUT
SHANE. SHANE GUSMAN SAM APPEL-
SO WHOEVER'S READY SENATOR
READY YOU MAY BEGIN- RIGHT AWAY.
YOU MISTER. MISTER SHE MEMBERS
DUST ON BEHALF OF THE CAN TEAM
PUB AFFAIRS. IN SUPPORT AND
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS
MEASURE. FOR DECADES THE GROUP
SUPPORTING THIS BILL HAVE BEEN
WORKING SEPARATELY ON SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL AND WORKER
PROTECTION POLICIES. IN THE
MORE RECENT PAST MANY OF US.
HAVE COME TOGETHER TO THINK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN ACHIEVE SOME
OF OUR GOALS THROUGH
COLLABORATION. SB SEVEN NINETY
FOUR IS A PRODUCT OF THAT
COLLABORATION. THE IDEA HERE IS
VERY IS A VERY SIMPLE ONE. HOW
CAN WE ACHIEVE MULTIPLE
BENEFITS FROM EVERY DOLLAR THE
STATE SPENDS. IN OTHER WORDS
LET'S MAXIMIZE THE USE OF THE
PUBLIC'S MONEY TO MOVE THE BALL
FORWARD ON POLICIES CALIFORNIA
HAS ALREADY PRIORITIZED IN THIS
INSTANCE TACKLING CLIMATE
CHANGE AND ENSURING THAT THE
JOBS CREATED. IN ADDRESSING
THAT WORLDWIDE CONCERN ARE GOOD
ONES. FOR THE TEAMSTERS BECAUSE
MANY OF THESE JOBS WORKING WITH
CLEANER VEHICLES ARE IN
TRACKING. WE NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THE BIGGEST LABOR PROBLEM THE
INDUSTRY FACES THAT'S NICE
CLASSIFICATION AS YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD. THIS COMMITTEE
HAS HEARD COUNTLESS HORROR
STORIES ALREADY ABOUT MISS
CLASSIFICATION WITH NO WORKER
PROTECTIONS PROVIDED TO THESE
DRIVERS. NO HEALTHCARE NO
BENEFITS NO TIME OFF NO SICK
LEAVE AND THE LIST GOES ON AND
ON. THE OTHER THING THAT MANY
DON'T REALIZE IS THAT.
CLASSIFIED DRIVERS ARE FORCED
TO DECLARE. THAT THEY ARE IN
BUSINESS FOR THEMSELVES
REQUIRING THE PURCHASE OR LEASE
OF A VERY EXPENSIVE TRUCK.
BEARING ALL OF THE COST GAS
LEASE PAYMENTS INSURANCE
ETCETERA- MANY MANY MONTHS THE
COST OF THE TRUCK IS MORE THAN
THE DRIVER MADE IN THE RATES
THEY RECEIVED RATES BY THE WAY
THAT THEY HAVE NO POWER TO
NEGOTIATE. HOW CAN A
MISCLASSIFIED DRIVER IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES STANCES
ADEQUATELY COMPLY WITH COSTLY
ENVIRONMENTAL UPGRADES FOR THE
PERSON. YEAH. AND I WHEN PORT
WE HAD TERRIBLE COME NUMBERS
WITH THE ORIGINAL SUBSIDIES
THAT CARBON OTHER AGENCY SPENT.
WE CAN DO BETTER WE KNOW THAT
COMPANIES WHO ARE BETTER
CAPITALIZE AND WILLING TO MAKE
THE EFFORT TO PROVIDE HIGH WILL
JOBS WILL ALSO MAKE THE EFFORT
TO SPEND CLIMATE MONEY
APPROPRIATELY AND GET US TO OUR
CLEAN AIR AND CLIMATE GOALS
FASTER. SB NINETY FOUR
ACCOMPLISHES THIS BY ENSURING
THAT THOSE WHO TAKE THE
PUBLIC'S MONEY ARE NOT
SCOFFLAWS AND ARE WILLING TO
MAKE THE WORKER STANDARD
COMMITMENTS GOING FORWARD. WE
THANK YOU FOR THIS TIME AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP NEXT SAM
A PELLET YOU ARE ON THE LINE
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN. AND YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HAVE A TIME YOU'D.
S. SAM SAM ABOVE THE IF YOU YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE I'M NOT SURE. WE
CAN COME BACK TO YOU. MATAMATA
ONLY GO HEAD TO CARE. OKAY.
SANTA OKAY WELL WE GOT A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE- IS ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER SUPPORT. SB SEVEN NINETY
FOUR IF NOT A MAN MODERATOR WE
HAVE ANYONE IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. AMY YES. THERE SAM OKAY
GOD WANTS TO GO AHEAD AND GIVE
YOUR OF UP TO TWO MINUTES A
TESTIMONY AGAINST THEM. BUT
ABOUT THINGS GOOD MORNING CHECK
POWER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MORNING HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YEAH WE CAN HEAR
YOU BUT. OKAY IT DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE CHAIR KARA CAN. I GET OVER
IT I CAN HEAR YOU CAN HEAR ME.
SAM YEAH WE HEAR YOU WE HEAR
YOU LOUD AND CLEAR TO GO AHEAD.
OKAY THAT THAT. THE MORNING
CARE COVER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SAM A PAL
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
MANAGER FOR THE BLUEGREEN
ALLIANCE. OR COALITION OF TEN
NATIONAL UNION THE FIVE
NATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
ADVANCING ECONOMICALLY JUST
CLIMATE CHANGE AND AIR
POLLUTION STRATEGY. EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETY FOUR IS. SUPPORTED
BY A DEEP AND DIVERSE ARRAY OF
LABOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
EQUITY ORGANIZATION AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL IT SEEKS TO
ACHIEVE YOUR GOAL. ONE IN
TRANSFORM PARK CLEAN VEHICLE
INSPECTED. INTO TRUE ENGINES AT
THE MOMENT ASSEMBLY. AND LOW
INCOME WORKERS COLLECT
SPECIFICALLY IN THE TRACKING
AUTO MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY.
AND SECONDLY AB SEVEN NINETY
FOUR AIMS TO REMOVE HEAT HIT
OPTION BARRIER TO THE ROLL OUT
OF THEIR MUCH VEHICLE
SPECIFICALLY. TRUCK DRIVER
METHOD CLASSIC. ON THE AUTO
MENU SIDE OF THE BILL. AB
SEVENTY FOUR THIS TO PRESERVING
HIKE OF JOB. AND CALIFORNIA IN
MANUFACTURING BATTERY
MANUFACTURER AND THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED BE AMERICA AUTO TECH
EMPLOYS THIRTY. CALIFORNIA
WORKERS AND ONE MILLION WORKERS
NATIONALLY AND JOB QUALITY AS
SHE SAID THIS WOULDN'T OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS IN THE FUTURE
HE HE'S COULD GREATLY
ACCELERATE AROCHA JOB. IN THE
U. S. IN U. S. AND HEALTH MANY
FACT. IF WE'D TAKE CORRECTIVE
BOTH AMERICANS APPLIED BACK
PRODUCTION AND AUTUMN TAX CHINA
AND THE R. OR YEARS OF A ET AND
BATTERY BACK. BETTMAN THAT'S
GALA. IF WE DON'T TAKE
PROACTIVE NOW WE MAY NOT CATCH
UP AND HAVE A GREAT UP. WITH
BEING THE THIRD LARGE MARKET
MAN HE- IN A WAR OF. THE POLICY
BEFORE THE CAR BETWEEN THEM BY.
AND ARE. WHO WANT TO ROLL
ELECTED VEHICLE THE QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND ARE DEEPLY ATTUNED
THE NEEDS OF URGENT NEEDS.
INDUSTRY AND MANUFACTURING WITH
KNOWLEDGE OF THE FACT BY. ON
THE CHAIN AND INTENT TO BILL A-
ET. WORK AND ECONOMY THE
MANUFACTURING OF THE BILL
INCLUDES FIVE DAYS FIND WORK
STAND LEGAL. THE CARD DOMESTIC
SUPPLY INDUSTRY COME WAGES AND-
BANDER TRAIN A LOT WITH HIRING
THAT THE- WORK. COMMUNITIES
FAMILIES- WE ABSOLUTELY CANNOT
AFFORD TO GO DOWN THAT ROAD AND
LEAVE OUR COMMUNITIES BEHIND.
AND THAT'S WHAT ALL THE GROUPS
THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
ESSENTIAL ON THE SIDE OF THE
BILL. I AM INTERESTED TIME. TO
WRAP UP IF YOU COULD. USHER
OKAY- ON THE TRUCK DRIVING SAID
IN THE BILL THE EVERYONE I
THINK ON MINUTES MILLION WITH
MISS CLASSIFICATION HOWEVER I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE SIGNIFICANT THE BILL IN
NOT- SINCE IT'S CLASSIFIED
DRIVERS EARN SUCH LOW INCOME
STRUCTURE GREATLY TO COMPLY
WITH CLEAN VEHICLE RULES AND
ARE GONNA HAVE A VERY HARD TIME
BUYING TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR PLUS YOUR MISSION TRUCKS
IN THE FUTURE- THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU. WE GOT A WE GOT TO
MOVE ON BUT THE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FOR YOUR FEEDBACK AND I
KNOW YOU'RE- THE YOU'RE- QUITE
DRIVER THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH
NOW REALLY. IT IF WE CAN MOVE
ON TO. PUBLIC COMMENT I ALREADY
ASKED FOR IN THE ROOM THERE WAS
NO ONE THERE IS- HANDS WILL GO
ON. ONCE AGAIN TO THE PHONE- IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE. FOR SB SEVEN NINETY
FOUR. THANK YOU IF YOU AREN'T A
PART OF AB SEVEN NINETY FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO. WE
WILL CUT THE LINE EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NORTH AMERICA
WITH THE CALIFORNIA WITH THE
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE OF NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS KEEP
IN BAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
TEAMSTERS PORT DIVISION AND THE
TRANSPORT WORKERS UNION OF
AMERICA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BERS MITCH SNIDER WITH
THE YOU CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT
THE LINE OF ONE HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER MEMBERS
BRENNAN DAWSON WAS HERE TO
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE
OF ONE OH TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NUMBERS
PRIVILEGE ON BEHALF OF THAT
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER TURNER. I'M SORRY PLEASE
GO AHEAD WERE UNABLE TO HEAR
YOU. SORRY ABOUT THAT YOU'RE
GONNA. BOTH SPORT. THANK YOU
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
FOUR EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
EXTROVERT THE LINE OF FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
BUDGET QUEUE NO WITH UNITED
AUTO WORKERS REGION EIGHT
PROBABLY IN SUPPORT. YOU THANK
YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THERE THIS IS AMBER WITH THE
PEOPLE COLLECTED FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT RECORD SO LINE OF
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIND MORE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRED THAT BLOCK WITH
TEAMSTERS JOINT COUNCIL SEVEN
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KATHY
WALLACE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP
WORKING FRAME FAMILIES
INCLUDING OUR AFFILIATE CENTRAL
COAST ALLIANCE UNITED FOR A
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY PENTAGON
POLICY POLICY INITIATIVES AND
SANTIAGO ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITIES ORGANIZED FOR
RESPONSIBLE DEVELOPMENT. IF
THEY ALLIANCE FOR SUSTAINABLE
ECONOMY WORKING PARTNERSHIPS
UNTIL COME BALLY LAWCENTER
PHILANTHROPY CONNIE AND
GRAPHICALLY TOOK CENTRE OF THE
INNER EMPIRE. IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT A
BOTTLE OF ONE A ONE YOUR LINE
IS- OPEN. MORE WILL READ OUR
HARM WORKING. USA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING JESSICA DURHAM WITH THE
LOS ANGELES ALLIANCE FOR NEW
ECONOMY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN Q. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE A WE DO HAVE- SOME OF THE
TESTIFIED OPPOSITION A
CHRISTIAN MODA I IS ON THE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. BUT YOUR
CAR I'M ON THE PHONE I DON'T
CHANGES SCHEDULE NO PROBLEM GO
AHEAD BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. IF YOUR CALL KALRA
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CHRISTIAN
ADULTS CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY
FOUR SPLIT PURCHASING
REQUIREMENTS. BUT LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHORED
SPONSORED MOVING FORWARD. UNDER
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY FOUR
DRAFTED TODAY YOU KNOW SURE
RECORD KEEPING VIOLATION OR AN
INCORRECT ADDRESS ON A PAY STUB
OVER A TEN YEAR SPAN. OF THE
REPAYMENT OF TEN YEARS WORTH OF
ENVIRONMENTAL INCENTIVES.
RATHER THAN INCREASING
COMPLIANCE WITH LABOR AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY LAWS IN
PRACTICAL TERMS WE ARE
CONCERNED. THAT EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY FOUR WILL SIMPLY CUT OFF
STATE AND SENATE FUNDING AND
THE SHORTFALL IN PORT DRAYAGE
MARKETS. TO AREAS IDENTIFIED BY
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND THE
GOVERNOR EARLY DEPLOYMENT OF
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS. AN
INCLUDES EVEN POLICE- WITH
COMPANY DRIVERS. BECAUSE THEIR
MISSION TRUCKS ARE ANYWHERE
FROM TWO TO THREE TIMES MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN THEIR
CONVENTIONAL GAS OR DIESEL
QUOTE ONCE. LOTS OF STATE
INCENTIVES WILL GREATLY IMPACT
THE ABILITY TO MEET THE STATE'S
CLIMATE GOALS. HARM CALIFORNIA
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED TRUCKERS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS ON MORE
FOCUS WE PURCHASING PROVISIONS.
THAT WILL SPELL OUT THE MUCH
NEEDED ENVIRONMENTAL INCENTIVES
IN THESE KEY THEIR. MISSION
TRUCK MARKETS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OKAY SO- BONO GOOD UP
COMMENT FOR THOSE OF IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM COLLECTORS
TO IDENTIFY THEMSELVES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN NINETY
FOUR. IF NOT- WILL GO OVER TO
THE PHONES AGAIN NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
BILL THIS IS OPPOSITION AB
SEVEN NINETY FOUR. TO THE
PHONES. THANK YOU AND IF YOU
ARE ON OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN
NINETY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
SIGNIFICANT OPPOSITION. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING ERIN RODRIGUEZ A MEDIAN
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS I'M
CALLING IN OF THE TWEENER WE
DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON
THE BILL THAT CALLING I'M NOT
SUPPORTING CONTENT AND THINGS
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. THANKS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE
OF ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SENATE CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. WITH DUE RESPECT
TO THE TO THE AUTHOR UP KESSLER
IS AN OPPOSITION. THAT HOPES TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHORED ON
POSSIBLE. CHANGES THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK GOD WE HAVE NO
FOR THE OPPOSITION QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE DO ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION. FROM A SUMMER GONZALEZ
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LORD. THERE'S NO OTHER FOR THE
QUESTIONS WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR I THINK THIS IS THE
EXAMPLE OF ME TALK ABOUT- LABOR
COMING TOGETHER WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL- COMMUNITIES TO
HELP ADVANCE- BOTH OBJECTIVES
OF HIGH QUALITY JOBS AND
CLEANING UP OUR ENVIRONMENT I
THINK THAT- YOU HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD- BUT WITH THIS ONE AND
I'M VERY GRATEFUL THAT YOU BUY
FOR THE RECOMMENDATIONS DO
PASSED. THE TRANSPORTATION AND-
BEFORE WE GO OFF TO THE VOTE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU AYE AYE MISTER CHAIR I HAVE
A LOT TO SAY ON THIS BILL BUT I
WILL KEEP MY COMMENTS SHORT-
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WE NEED
LONG TERM EQUITABLE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIES TO BUILD
BACK BETTER. MAYBE SEVEN NINETY
FOR THE CLEAN JOBS AND EQUITY
ACTUAL HOW TO DO THIS WITH TWO
ICONIC AMERICAN INDUSTRIES
TRUCK DRIVING AND AUTO
MANUFACTURING. I HAVE ASKED
THAT MEMBERS HAVE ASKED ME AS
WE TRY TO FIGURE OUT OUR
PRIORITIES WILL IS THAT THE
LABOR BILL IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE BILL. IT'S BOTH MMHM WE
CAN DO BOTH AND THAT IS THE
MANDATE THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
AND THOSE ARE THE PILLARS OF
THE GREEN NEW DEAL IN WHICH
CALIFORNIA IS ALREADY LEADING
ON. SO IF WE TRULY BELIEVE IN A
JUST TRANSITION WE NEED TO
ENSURE. THAT WE ARE CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THAT TO
ACTUALLY BE A REALITY AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
IDOL. THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY FROM CALL THE ROLL.
SB SEVEN NINETY FOUR PLEASE.
MOTION IS DUE PATH TO
TRANSPORTATION KALRA I KALRA HI
FLORA. FLORA NO GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER. JONES.
SAWYER HI STONE. JOHN I SEE I
DON'T KNOW. ZERO NO BOARD. WARD
HI. ALL RIGHT SO THE BILLS ON
THE TO TRANSFER- SO ITEM BY
ITEM. DECEMBER YOU HAVE OF
SEVENTEEN YOU MAY BE BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU I'M PROUD 2% MISTER CHAN
MEMBERS ELEVEN AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY NINE WHICH CREATES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WORKING
PARENTS AND MOTHERS TO RETURN
TO WORK BY CREATING BACK OF
CHILD CARE AT THE DIRECT
BENEFIT. FOR EMPLOYEES WHO WORK
AT COMPANIES WITH MORE THAN ONE
THOUSAND STATEWIDE EMPLOYEES
THE AVERAGE PARENT MISSES ABOUT
EIGHT DAYS OF WORK PER YEAR DUE
TO CHILDCARE BREAKDOWNS AND FOR
SINGLE MOTHERS WITH CLOSE TO
SIXTEEN DAYS. THIS IS
DEVASTATING FOR LOWER INCOME
EARNERS AND MISCHIEF'S AND
WAGES OFTEN LEAD TO MISS RENT
AND JOB LOSS THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS FURTHER EXPOSED
MANY CALIFORNIANS TO
UNPRECEDENTED ECONOMIC
INSTABILITY BUT MANY WOMEN
PARTICULARLY AMERICAN INDIAN
BLACK LATINO AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER WOMEN WERE ALREADY
STRUGGLING TO JUGGLE THEIR
THEIR CHILD CARE. AND WORK
RESPONSIBILITIES PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC EVEN SO THE COVER
NINETEEN RECESSION WAS THE
FIRST RECESSION IN WHICH MORE
WOMEN THAN MEN LOST THEIR JOBS
AND BLACK AND LATINO WOMEN AND
IMMIGRANT WOMEN. LOST THEM AT
ESPECIALLY HIGH RATES THIS YEAR
ALONE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
WOMEN LEFT THE WORK FORCE DUE
TO CHILDCARE ISSUES NOW NEARLY
ONE YEAR INTO THE COAL BUT
NINETEEN RECESSION MANY WOMEN
IN CALIFORNIA FACE HARSH
REALITIES AS THEY SCRAMBLE TO
PAY FOR EVERYDAY EXPENSES.
AFTER LOSING THEIR JOBS AND
THEIR HOUSEHOLD INCOMES MOTHERS
HAVE TO SERVE BOTH AS CARE
GIVERS AND PROVIDERS IN ORDER
TO MAINTAIN THE ECONOMIC
STABILITY OF THEIR FAMILIES LOW
INCOME FAMILIES SPEND ABOUT A
THIRD OF THEIR INCOME ON CHILD
CARE WHILE ALSO TRYING TO
BALANCE OTHER FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITIES. MOTHERS HAVE
MOTHERS NOW HAVE EVEN FEWER
AFFORDABLE OPTIONS FOR CHILD
CARE POTENTIALLY DELAYING THEIR
RE ENTRY INTO THE WORKFORCE AS
CALIFORNIA STRUGGLES TO RECOVER
FROM THE CROWN OF I RESPECT
PANDEMIC. WORKING MOTHER SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO FACE IMPOSSIBLE
CHOICES EACH MONTH ABOUT
WHETHER TO PAY FOR THEIR FOOD
THEIR RENT OR CHILDCARE AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE INSURERS
WORKING PARENTS CAN CONTINUE
EARNING THEIR WAGES. WHY THEIR
CHILDREN SAFELY BEING CARED
FOR. STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
ONE SINGLE MOMS ARE EMPLOYED BY
A COMPANY THAT OFFERS BACK UP
LIKELY. TO BE EMPLOYED TWO
YEARS LATER. IT IS WHY
INCREASING ACCESS TO CHILD CARE
IS ESSENTIAL TO KEEPING WOMEN
IN THE WORKFORCE INCLUDING SUCH
BENEFITS WILL MAKE CALIFORNIA
COMPANY STRONGER. AND MORE
COMPETITIVE WHILE ENSURING
WORKING MOTHERS ARE NOT LEFT
BEHIND IN OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY
TO BUILD BACK BETTER WE MUST
PROVIDE CHILD CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT WORKING
FAMILIES NEED AND FINALLY PAY
WOMEN FOR THE UNCOMPENSATED
LABOR THEY PROVIDE FOR OUR
ECONOMY. I AM COGNISANT OF THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS AND
INTEND TO WORK. WITH THEM TO
ADDRESS THEM I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WTH MY OFFICE ON THIS
URGENT ISSUE AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK. WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AVAILABLE TO
TESTIFY OVER THE PHONE R.
BROOKE SHAPIRO- BRANICKI TO
MANAGER WITH CLOROX- BERNIE'S.
A LISA MARIE MCGINNIS WHO IS A
CONSTITUENT AND WILL BE
TESTIFYING. AND ADDITIONALLY
JENNIFER WHEN HALL REPRESENTING
OUR BILL- AND THE SPONSOR FILE
WITH HELPER WHO IS OUR SPONSOR
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
START WITH BROOKE SHAPIRO IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE. UP TO TWO
MINUTES PLEASE THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOLERA
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS GREG SHAPIRO AND I
LIVE IN OPEN AND I'M THE
FOUNDER OF A PARENT EMPLOYEE
RESOURCE GROUP ACT BLACK. I
ALSO STARTED PANDEMIC WORKING
PARENT NOW MAMBA WITH THE
MISSION OF HELPING MOM PROPER
AND THEIR CAREER. AS A MODERATE
INTENT AND A TWO YEAR OLD. I
PERSONALLY NOT ON BEHALF OF
BLACK SUPPORT AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
NINE. CAN MANDATE. EMPLOYER
PROVIDED BACK UP CHILDCARE. AT
WORK I WOULD. WITH MY RESPONSE.
OF NEW PARENTHOOD. AND DAY TO
DAY WORK. I QUICKLY REALIZED
THAT I WASN'T ALONE. FOR
DISTRACTED DURING MEETINGS THEY
ARE TAKING ON PLANNED DAYS OFF
ARE ALWAYS LEAVING EARLY DUE TO
CHILD CARE NEEDS. THANK YOU
THAT THE NINETEEN ACKERMAN
APPARENT REBIRTH FOR.
UNDERSTAND PARENTS NEED PROVIDE
RESOURCES. AND ADVOCATE FOR
SUPPORT. AND THIRTY THIRD WE
THAT CARE WITH ONE OF OUR MOST
PRESSING A KISS. EVEN CREE COVE
A PARENTS WERE STRUGGLING WITH
BALANCING CHILD CARE. KID
SCHOOL CLOSURE CANCELLATIONS
ARE SUBJECT SHIFTING WORK
SCHEDULE ALEX RIVETED TO THAT.
ACCORDING YOU WANT ONE CORRECT
EIGHT WALDRON THEY CAN'T RECALL
AND CHILD CARE ASSISTANCE
BECAME IMPAIRED AT OUR FACTORY
WORKERS ALL THE WAY UP TO OUR
FEMALE CEO. WE TO RELIEVE THE
PRESSURE OF THE SLOW TARGETED.
BERMAN FOR DATED. SO THEY FOCUS
ON THE FIND A DOCTOR THE LAST.
AS A RESULT OF THAT I WORK WITH
HR DETERMINE HOW DID THAT
PROVIDE BACKUP CHILD CARE
BENEFITS ARE EMPLOYERS ACROSS
THE U. S. HAPPY TO HEAR THAT
CORRECTIVE. THAT THEY'RE- WHAT
YOU NEED US TO UP OUR
PRODUCTION PLANNING THE- I'M
FOR THE LEFT. I BELIEVE BACK UP
CHILDCARE A LIFE SAVER BOTH
MORE PARENTS AND COMPANIES.
IMPLICATED ARE NOT ONLY FINDING
IMPACT THE MAINTAIN WOMEN IN
THE WORK FOR THAT YEAR. I URGE
YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF AB
ELEVEN NINE. SO THAT MILLION OF
CAL WORKING CAN THRIVE NETWORK.
THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF A THEN ALSO THAT UP NOW
UNDERNEATH MY KIANA- IF YOU'RE
ON THE LINE YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT
OUR LAND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LISA
MCMANUS AND I LIVE IN OXNARD
CALIFORNIA. AND CURRENTLY
PARENT OF TWO GIRLS TEN AND
FIFTEEN I SUPPORT AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY NINE EMPLOYEES PROVIDED
BENEFIT BACK UP CHILDCARE. I'M
A MOM OF TWO ADULT SONS AND IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN MY
HUSBAND I BECAME GUARDIANS OF
MY TWO NIECES. SHARON THIRTEEN
AND FRANKLY EIGHT AFTER MY
BROTHER'S PASSING I WOULD JUST.
LEFT MY MANAGEMENT POSITION AT
GOODWILL FOR HURRICANE STOP IN
THE MEDICAL OFFICE. EARLY ON TO
MY JOURNEY OF PARENTING I
EXPERIENCE THE SAME STRUGGLES I
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM MY EMPLOYEES
AT GOODWILL RAISING KIDS MAKING
A NINE TO FIVE SCHEDULE MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT. OUR PUBLIC
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
FILLED SINCE THE YEAR. BEFORE
APRIL WITH THE TRUCK DRIVING
JOBS AT A HIGHER SALARY I WAS
FORCED TO CALL OFF WORK TO PICK
UP THE GIRLS AFTER SCHOOL.
PEOPLE NIGHT AFTER FAMILY
SUPPORT BUT THEY QUICKLY
EXHAUSTED BECAUSE THEY HAD JOBS
WITHOUT. I ASKED MY BOSS TO
CHANGE MY HOURS TO ACCOMMODATE
PICKING UP THE GIRLS BUT THE
OPTION WASN'T AVAILABLE. I WAS
FORCED TO QUIT MY JOB. A YEAR
AND A HALF LATER I'M STILL ON.
AND NOT SURE. IF I'M ABLE TO A
WAY. POST CALLED IT. IF YOU TO
BE HAVE TO BE THIS. YOU WORK
AND HOW CAN AND CAL. I AM TRULY.
IN THE HBO SEVENTY NINE HAS
BEEN. THE PARTY ME BACKING
THEM. WITHOUT MAKING. I WOULD
STILL BE EMPLOYED. MY FAMILY
WOULD BE MUCH BETTER OFF. I
DIDN'T NEED A LOT OF HELP JUST
THAT THREE TO FIVE BABY SITTER.
FOR A COUPLE MONTHS INTO THE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM OPENED
THAT. I MET OTHER PARENTS TO
BUILD SUPPORT AND NETWORKING.
BUT HARDSHIP WITH MIGHT STILL
BE BILLS I KNOW. I'M NOT ALONE
FRANCIS. WAS NOT THE ONLY ONE
ON THE AFTER SCHOOL WAITING
LISTS. I URGE YOU TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF THE EIGHTY ELEVEN
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU AGAIN
TOO MANY MEMBERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- TESTIMONY.
WILL MOVE ON TO. TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE
AGAIN FOR PUBLIC COMMENT JUST
TAKE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE. YES
PLEASE- COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE ONE AT A TIME. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JAY
STEINBERG I'M A SOCIAL WORKER
AND I'M IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. HELLO MY NAME IS CASEY
EDWARDS AS A DOMESTIC WORKER
FOR FIFTEEN YEARS I WAS A
VOLUNTEER FOSTER PARENTS A
MEMBER OF CLOSING THE WOMEN'S
WEALTH GAP THE THEO HELPER AND
I SUPPORT ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE.
THANK YOU. OF AND SO THAT'S ALL
THE PUBLIC HAS MONEY IN PERSON
WILL GO OVER TO THE PHONE LINES
AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF AB. ELEVEN
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY NINE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. THEN ZERO ONE ZERO FOR A.
B. ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE UP FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MULLIN HI
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THERE A
BLOCK ON BEHALF DSCA IN
SUPPORT. GROUP THANK YOU AND
NEXT DON'T GO TO LINE OF ONE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BURKE
TRIPLICATE OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT ACROSS THE LINE
OF ONE THIRTY FIVE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS ASKING THE COURT CLERK
AT THE STUDENT SPECIALIST AND I
AM IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO- GO TO LINE OF ONE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS CHRIS WALKED
IN ON A SEVENTH GRADE
HUMANITIES TEACHER AT CHILDREN
STATE COOL AND I SUPPORT IT
BILL AB ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE OF ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS JEFF
AND WALK AN ACCOUNT MANAGER AT
ENTRANCE AND I SUPPORT BILL AB
AT ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU UNACCEPTABLE
IT'S A LINE OF ONE OF FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
RACHEL CAME IN I'M A COMMUNITY
MANAGER AT HEAD CAMP AND I
SUPPORT A. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
NINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS WENDY SMITH I'M
DIRECTOR OF SALES AND I SUPPORT
AB ONE ONE SEVEN NINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO CAROLINA
ONE OF FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS ERICA RIGHT
I'M A NONPROFIT ARTS
ADMINISTRATOR AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
NINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS THAT I AM A CREATIVE
DIRECTOR AT WITHIN AND I
SUPPORT AB ONE ONE SEVEN NINE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
TO GO TO LINE OF ONE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS EMIR FRYE AND I'M A BUSINESS
OWNER AND I SUPPORT A. B.
ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE OF WHAT ONE OF FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS- BOBBY LOPEZ
CALLING FROM OAKLAND I WAS
MERELY HERE WITH MY FOUR KIDS
LISTENING IN AND REALIZE THAT
THIS BILL IS VERY IMPORTANT AND
I HOPE YOU SUPPORT IT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. GET OUT OF- EIGHTY
FIFTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO TIMELINE OF
ONE FORTY SIXTY LINE IS OPEN. I
MADE MICHAEL SCHULTZ I'M A
PARTNER YOU CAN MANAGER AYE
DOCUSIGN AYE SUPPORT AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO TO LINE OF ONE
FIFTIES OR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BERMAN AND MAKE THE CALL AT
WORK H. P. AS A- PROGRAM
MANAGER AT NIGHT. THE PORT
EIGHTY ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NXR GOT
SOMEONE OF A ONE OF FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS JUDY AND HE I AM A
PARENT RESOURCE DIRECTOR AND A
MOTHER AND I SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE ONE MORE
IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE GATHER THEIR LINE NUMBER AND
AGAIN WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE ONE SEVEN NINE. IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
OF A. B. ONE ONE SEVEN NINE.
AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF ONE
OF FIFTY NINE. HI MY NAME IS
SHELBY ROSA I'M A DILLON AND I
SUPPORT B. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
NINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE HAVE QUITE A
FEW THAT- CUED UP ONE MOMENT I
WOULD GATHER THEIR LINE NUMBERS
AND IT IS THE- WE'LL GO T LINE
OF ONE FIFTY EIGHT. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS STEVEN
STEINBERG AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL I MAKE YOU KNOW LA UNIFIED
SCHOOL TEACHER IN LOS ANGELES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
OVER TO ONE OF ONE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS EILEEN CULVER I'M A CHILD
CARE TAKER I'M A TOLL FREE
BECAUSE- FOR ELEVEN AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO TIMELINE OF ONE
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
ONE SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU HAVE A DUMMY AT. ONE SIXTY.
MEXICO CAROLINA ONE SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS DANNY ROOSEVELT I WORK AT
DROPBOX AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
EIGHTY ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
ACROSS THE LINE OF ONE OF FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE ONE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS ANKIT MENDEZ AND
MANY OF THE TEACHER AND THE
SUPPORT BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY
NINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF ONE SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS DANIEL AT NINE I'M A
MUSIC TEACHER IN LOS ANGELES
AND I SUPPORT ONE ONE SEVEN
NINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WILL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION WE
HAVE. AT ASHLEY HOFFMAN WHO
WILL BE TESTIFYING BY PHONE IN
OPPOSITION IS ACTUALLY PURE
READY YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS ACTUALLY OFTEN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY ELEVEN
SEVENTY NINE AS A JOB KILLER.
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
ABSOLUTELY SHARE THE CONCERN
THAT THE COULD BE NINETEEN AND
DEMOCRATS HAD A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
WOMEN IN LARGE PART DUE TO
CLOSURES OF SCHOOLS AND
CHILDCARE CENTRES WE SHARE THE
CONCERN ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE AFFORDABILITY OF CHILD CARE
FOR WORKING FAMILIES. THE ISSUE
HERE IS WHO SHOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING FOR
BACKUP CHILD CARE WERE REGULAR
CARE PROVIDER CANNOT BE
UTILIZED EMPLOYERS MUST ALREADY
PROVIDE LEAVE FOR SITUATIONS OR
SCHOOL OR CHILDCARE CENTERS
CLOSED UNDER EXISTING LABOR
CODE PROVISIONS. SOCIALLY
DURING THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC EMPLOYERS HAVE REALLY
BECOME THE STATE UNIT OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE MANDATE TO
CONTINUE TO GET PILED ON HAVE
BECOME UNTENABLE WELL MANY
BRUSH AWAY ANY NEW BURDENS THAT
ARE PLACED ON LARGE BUSINESSES
MANY ARE STARTING TO HIT THEIR
BREAKING POINT WHERE THEY MUST
CONSIDER WHETHER THEY CANNOT TO
AFFORD TO EXPAND IN CALIFORNIA.
WHETHER THEY NEED TO CLOSE
FACILITIES TO BE ABLE TO
FINANCIALLY SURVIVE HERE THE
BILL ALSO APPLIES TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS LIKE CITIES WHO ARE
ALSO FINANCIALLY STRUGGLING AT
THIS TIME. OUR POSITION IS THAT
IF THERE'S GOING TO BE A
SUBSIDY FOR BACKUP CHILDCARE
REALLY SHOULD COME FROM THE
STATE PROVIDING THOSE BENEFITS
ARE USING FINANCIAL INCENTIVES
TO HELP EMPLOYERS COVER THE
COST OF SUCH A PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIANS RECEIVED FUNDS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAT COULD BE USED FOR THIS
PURPOSE AND IS PRESENTLY
ENJOYING A CONSIDERABLE SURPLUS
THAT ALSO COULD BE USED FOR
THIS PURPOSE. SPEAKING TO
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY. WE HAD OUR
MEMBERS HAVE CONCERNS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL
PASSED SECTION TWO NINE FIVE
THREE D. PROVIDES AN EMPLOYER
MAY NOT REQUIRE AN EMPLOYEE TO
PROVIDE DOCUMENTATION VERIFYING
THE USE OF THEIR FIRST SIXTY
HOURS IT APPEARS THE SECTION
MAY PROHIBIT AN EMPLOYER FROM
REQUESTING DOCUMENTATION TO
CONFIRM AN EMPLOYEE IS INDEED
USING THAT FOR BACK UP
CHILDCARE- AND NOT FOR PRIMARY
CHILD CARE. WE HAVE REQUESTED
CLARIFICATION ON THIS POINT BUT
HAVE NOT RECEIVED IT TO DATE-
THERE'S ALSO NO CAP ON HOW MUCH
MONEY AN EMPLOYEE CAN MAKE- TO
BE ENTITLED TO THE BENEFIT OF
ATTORNEY MAKING THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR TO OUR.
COOPER WOULD BE ENTITLED TO
THIS BENEFIT IT. OTHER AND HOW
THE BAY. AGES I'M IN THE LINE.
WELL ONCE. SAYS THE BENEFIT
WOULD BE PAID AT MINIMUM WAGE.
THERE'S ANOTHER SECTION THAT
HAS A- SIMILAR PAYCHECK LEAVE.
THEREFORE IN THAT STRUCK. AND
TO MAKE MORE MONEY WITH ACTUAL
GET MORE. FOR CHILD CARE. MONEY
RATHER THAN THE MAKING WILL
WAGES TO HAVE A- MY- OUR DATA
TOURNEY AND- SAMPLE WOULD BE
ENTITLED TO MORE. ONEY FOR
BACK UP CHILDCARE ATTENDED
MINISTRY WHO PLAYED THE SAME
FOR MAKING CLASS. FOR THOSE
REASONS AND MORE WE DO OPPOSE
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE
AFTERSHOCK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANYONE HERE- IT
THE ROOM AND THEY. ELEVEN
SEVENTY NINE. IF NOT THEN GO
OVER THE PHONES AND IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES. IN
OPPOSITION AB ELEVEN SEVEN NINE.
GIVE IT SHARE IF YOU'RE NOT THE
VISION OF AB. ELEVEN SEVENTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN.
ONE AND THEN ZERO IN OPPOSITION
OF A LOT SEVENTY. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE FORTY YEAR LOW IS
OPEN. SHARE MEMBERS YELLING GET
THEM WITH THE L. SPACE THIS
THIS ISSUE AND- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN OCTOBER TO LYING
OF SEVENTY YEAR AS THOUGH.
HELLO AGAIN THE CAL MAY AFFECT
A TECH ASSOCIATION WHERE
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF. TWENTY NINE
CHINA'S OPEN. GOOD MORNING-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS BRIAN
LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AT THIS TIME THERE
IS NO FOR THE OPPOSITION IN Q.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR MOTIONS. ON A. B.
ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE. THE
SERVER'S DATA WELL THANK YOU
MISS CARILLO FOR- YOUR CONCERNS
ABOUT A CHILD CARE BECAUSE THE
BIG THE BIG ISSUE ESPECIALLY IN
A COMMUNITIES AS YOU SPOKE
ABOUT THAT ARE- NOT STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY AND- AND IT. UP IT
OVERLY IMPACTS SOME ARE
MINORITY COMMUNITIES AND- THE
FOLKS THERE. MY QUESTION IS WHY.
YOU KNOW L. IS WE KIND OF
BERMAN MORE AND MORE ON TO
THESE CORPORATIONS COMPANIES
THAT SET FOR THE EMPLOYERS OF
THESE. WHY ISN'T THERE A
CEILING ON ON WHO GETS THIS
BENEFIT BECAUSE- THAT COST-
ISN'T NECESSARILY SOMETHING
THAT HIGHER WAGE EMPLOYEES-
NEED TO HELP OFFSET AND IT
SEEMS LIKE. A LIKE A LOT OF THE
PROGRAMS WE DEVELOP- IT'S- A
LOT OF MONEY IS GOING TO PEOPLE
WHO DON'T NEED IT WELL THE
PEOPLE THAT DO NEED IT DON'T
GET ENOUGH. AND THAT'S MY
CONCERN IS THAT WE KEEP MAKING
THESE PROGRAMMES. THAT THAT.
DIDN'T BENEFIT. OF THE DONATED
OR HAVE THEIR ALLOW THEM TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A PROGRAM
THAT THEY JUST DON'T NEED. AND
YET YOU KNOW IF IT'S THERE THEY
TAKE IT. AND THAT REDUCES THE
ABILITY OF US TO ASSIST PEOPLE
THAT ARE TRULY IN NEED. SO WHY
WHY WAS THAT NOT CONSIDERED IN
THIS BILL. THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION- YOU MENTIONED WHAT IS
THE CEILING THE CEILING OF THE
GLASS CEILING IT'S A FEELING
THAT NEEDS TO BE BROKEN BECAUSE
MOTHERS AND PARTICULARLY
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY WORK.
REGARDLESS OF MUCH MONEY THEY
MAKE AND I'M GLAD THAT THE
CHAMBER POINTED THIS OUT AS
WELL IN TERMS OF. LOW WAGE
WORKERS AND HIGH INCOME WAGE
WORKERS MOTHERS DON'T GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO STAY I'M GOING
TO GO TO WORK TODAY OR I'M
GOING TO BE A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER TODAY OR I'M GONNA YOU
KNOW BE THE SOLE EARNER. IN MY
FAMILY THERE IS NO CHOICE
MOTHERS DO ALL OF THAT I WOULD
SAY THAT PARENTS DO ALL OF THAT
SO THERE ARE CORPORATIONS
ALREADY OFFERING THIS BENEFIT
LIKE GOOGLE AND FACEBOOK. WHO
WORKS THERE. RIGHT IT'S MOSTLY
ENGINEERS. OF HIGH WAGE EARNERS
THAT ALREADY HAVE THIS BENEFIT
AND IT'S NOT A BENEFIT. THAT IS
THE FIRST PRIORITY TO YOU THE
BACKUP CHILD CARE. HOW THE
BENEFIT IN CASE YOU NEED IT.
NOT THE ONE THING THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO SOLELY USE. I WORKED
ON LEGISLATION IN THE PAST
WE'VE ADDED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITION TO AFTER
SCHOOL FUNDING. HUGE DEAL IN
TERMS OF ENSURING THAT.
CHILDREN IN LOW INCOME AREAS
PARTICULARLY LIKE AND
COMMUNITIES THAT I SERVE HAVE A
SAFE SPACE WHERE THEY COULD BE.
I WANT PARENTS ARE WORKING SO
THAT THERE. ARE BEING EDUCATED
THAT THEY HAVE RESOURCES AND
PROGRAMS BUT EVERY YEAR WE
CONTINUOUSLY. CUT FUNDING OR
DON'T HAVE AS MUCH RESOURCES TO
OTHER PARTICULAR AREAS OF CHILD
KERR THERE IS A HUGE INTENT AND
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF THINGS
PASSED IN TERMS OF. EARLY CHILD
CARE. AFTER SCHOOL CARE. BUT A
BACKUP CHILD CARE PROVIDED BY
YOUR EMPLOYER IS QUITE
DIFFERENT. AND IN FACT WE HAVE
DATA THAT SHOWS THAT. AN
EMPLOYER WHO OFFERS SUPPORT FOR
CHILDCARE. ABSENCES AT THAT
COMPANY DECREASED BY 2230% AND
TURNOVER DROPPED BY THIRTY
SEVEN OF 60% THAT IS ACTUALLY A
BENEFIT. FOR CORPORATIONS SO
THAT THERE'S LESS TURNOVER LESS
MONEY SPENT ON TRAINING. AND
LESS MONEY TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHO'S GOING TO TAKE ANOTHER
POSITION. SO IF WHAT I'M
HEARING YOU SAY IS THAT YOU
BELIEVE THAT A PROGRAM LIKE
THIS IS BENEFICIAL TO LOW
INCOME OR LOW WAGE WORKERS I'M
WITH YOU. BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
IT FLEXIBLE FOR EVERY SINGLE
PARENT EVERY SINGLE MOTHER
ACROSS THE BOARD. THAT'S THE
INTENT RIGHT SIR IS A- PERSON
WHO ACTUALLY GREW UP WITH THE
DAD- WITH THE ONES WITH THE DAD.
AND OUR MOM MOM MOM MOM PASSED
AWAY SO- DADS HAD THAT SAME
ISSUE AND YOU KNOW HE DID
MANAGE. BUT ALSO- WHAT I WANTED
TO THAT POINT OUT WAS THE
GOOGLES. AND THE FACEBOOKS AND
BIG COMPANIES YOU MENTIONED
THEY CAN AFFORD TO DO THAT AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO TO HELP.
BUILD THE WORKFORCE THAT THEY
WANT- SOME CORPORATE SOME
COMPANIES CAN'T AFFORD TO DO
THIS. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
FORCING THEM TO. GO INTO THAT
WORLD AND COMPETE AND FROM A-
ATTRACTIONS STANDPOINT. FOR
AREAS LIKE THE AREA I LIVE IN
WE NEED MORE MANUFACTURING WE
NEED MORE BUSINESSES TO COME IN
SO THAT WE CAN GET PEOPLE OFF
OF THE COMMUTE. AND STOP IN
WHICH HELPS THE ENVIRONMENT.
YOU CAN'T IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
BUSINESS RETENTION IT'S ABOUT
BUSINESS ATTRACTION AND THE
MORE OF THESE TYPE OF- IN
POSITIONS ON THESE COMPANIES
THAT WE PUT IN. THE THAT MORE
DIFFICULT THE ENVIRONMENT IS
FOR THEM TO OPERATE. THE LESS
WE'RE GONNA HAVE COMPANIES AND
THAT MEANS LESS JOBS AND THAT
MEANS THOSE GLASS CEILINGS
DON'T GET BROKEN BECAUSE THOSE
PEOPLE AREN'T WORKING. SO SO
THAT'S MY CONCERN YOU KNOW I
GET I SEE THE CUMULATIVE
EFFECTS THAT THIS IS HAVING ON.
ON ON THESE COMPANIES THAT WE
WANT TO HAVE HERE. AND THEY'RE
NOT COMING HERE. AND BECAUSE
IT'S NOT A CHOICE NOW OF MOVING
OUT. BECAUSE THAT'S A HUGE
CHOICE FOR SOMEBODY WHO'S BEEN
HERE FOR SO LONG AND NOW THEY
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT WHILE WE DO
BUSINESS HERE ANYMORE. THAT'S A
HUGE UNDERTAKING THE FOR
SOMEBODY WHO'S CONSIDERING
DOING MANUFACTURING HERE- NUYS
WILL DO IN ARIZONA AND THAT'S
WHAT WE ARE COMPETING AGAINST.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S HURTING AREAS
LIKE OURS AND THAT'S WHAT'S
HELPING. CREATE MORE POLLUTION
INSTEAD OF LEFT SO. THERE'S MY
CONCERN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I WANT TO JUST THANK YOU
FOR RAISING WE TALK ABOUT MONTH
QUITE A BIT. OF MOTHERS HAVE
BEEN HIGHLY IMPACTED BY COAL
THE NINETEEN. BUT I DO WANNA
THANK YOU FOR SHARING. YOUR
STORY ABOUT YOUR YOUR FATHER
AND BEING A SINGLE DAD. THIS
ALSO IS BENEFICIAL TO PARENTS
TO OPT INTO MOMS TO DADS- IN AN
EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT THE JOBS
AND OPPORTUNITIES AND RESOURCES
ARE HERE THEY WERE ABLE TO
RETURN TO THE WORKFORCE AS WE
THINK ABOUT. AND QUITE HONESTLY
REIMAGINE A DIFFERENT TPE OF
WORKPLACE A AND WORKPLACES AND-
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARENTS
TO THRIVE COVERT NINETEEN
REALLY TAUGHT US LIKE WE CAN
WORK DIFFERENTLY. CORPORATIONS
CANNOT WORK DIFFERENTLY WE
NEED. YOU KNOW WORK
DIFFERENTLY. AMID THE PANDEMIC
AND SO IF NOT NOW WHEN- AND SO
IT'S AN INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY
I THINK TO REIMAGINE TO RETHINK
WHAT. THE WORKFORCE LOOKS LIKE
FOR WORKING PARENTS AND FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO DO THE RIGHT
THING MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU
SO MUCH- SUMMER DOES ALSO. SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD IT'S CREATIVE IT'S
DIFFERENT IT'S A NEW APPROACH-
I THINK YOU KNOW I WAS A SINGLE
MOM FOR A VERY LONG TIME AND I
WAS RAISED BY A SINGLE MOTHER.
AND I. THE EMERGENCY CHILDCARE
SITUATIONS WERE OFTEN CAUSED BY
WORK. YOU KNOW AND I WAS LUCKY
ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO DRAG MY
KIDS. BACK TO WORK WITH ME WHEN
I HAD TO GO. IN AND GO IN FOR
WHATEVER REASON BUT NOT ALL
WORKERS HAVE GOTTEN SO I'D
REALLY ARGUE THOUGH TOO. RIGHT
NOW WHILE WE'RE SEEING ALL
THESE STORIES ABOUT HOW HARD IT
IS TO GET WORKERS TO COME BACK.
THAT'S PART OF THE EQUATION
HERE YES YOU CAN MOVE SOMETHING
THE ARIZONA DOESN'T MATTER IF
YOU DON'T PAY ENOUGH AND
PROVIDE ENOUGH FOR PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY WANT THAT JOB WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE THAT FOR. WAY
TOO LONG- THE UNITED STATES HAS
HAS RELIED ON- LARGELY
UNPROTECTED IMMIGRANT WORKERS
TO PICK UP THE SLACK AT THE
BOTTOM. AND WITH THE CHANGES
THAT HAVE HAPPENED AND WHAT
WE'RE SEEING NOW IT'S ONLY YOU
KNOW IT IT IT'S BECOMING CLEAR
THAT OUR WORK FORCE RULES
NATIONALLY DO NOT WORK. FOR
WORKING PARENTS. SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU I DON'T KNOW IF.
THEY'RE THERE ARE THINGS I
THINK WE CAN WORK ON IN THIS
TICKET TO STRENGTHEN AND TO
MAKE IT MORE WORKABLE THAT- AND
I DO THINK. WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE IT IS BACK UP CHILD CARE
IT'S NOT JUST THE FOR SIXTY
HOURS I UNDERSTAND I THINK WE
CAN WORK ON THAT AND THIS IS A
NEW APPROACH TO IT THOUGH AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT CHILD CARE ENOUGH- AS A
BARRIER TO EMPLOYMENT AT ONE OF
THE REASONS WOMEN DROPPED OUT
OF THE WORKFORCE WAS BECAUSE OF
OUR CHILD CARE ISSUES SO. I
JUST I COMMEND YOU FOR DOING
THIS HARD WORK IN FOR STARTING
A CONVERSATION THAT. IF IT'S
NOT JUST CALIFORNIA OUR ENTIRE
COUNTRY NEEDS TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION AND WE KNOW IT
DOESN'T START FROM WASHINGTON
IT NEVER DOES ALL OF THESE
IDEAS START CALIFORNIAN SO I'M
GLAD YOU'RE STARTING. LOOKING
MOTION. THAT MOTION. IS THEIR-
SEGMENT. UP BY SHIP. YEAH YOU
JERRY THANK YOU- CALLING FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD BECAUSE I DO
SHARE MY- COLLEAGUE A SUPPORT
OF OBVIOUSLY CHILD CARE- BUT
NOT ALL INDUSTRIES ARE CREATED
EQUAL. AND WITH I'VE SAID THIS
MANY TIMESIN THIS COMMITTEE
WHEN WE PAINT IN THESE BROAD
BRUSHES AND THERE ARE NO. WE
COME FROM BUT THAT WAS IN
MANUFACTURING OKAY- IF THERE IS
A ISSUE WITH A PRESS BRAKE
OPERATOR. IT'S NOT LIKE I CAN
JUST PULL SOMEBODY OFF THE
STREET. TO REPLACE THAT RIGHT I
UNDERSTAND THE CHILD CARE IS A
HUGE HUGE PROBLEM AND WE NEED
TO DEAL WITH THIS. BUT TO PUT
THESE KIND OF- ONEROUS.
MANDATES QUITE FRANKLY ON THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND I DO I
HAVE A WHOLE LIST OF THINGS
LIKE. AT SOME POINT I'LL GO
THROUGH THEM- OF WHAT JUST LIKE
THIS COMMITTEE JUST TODAY WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO TO THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. AND THIS IS
JUST ONE MORE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT I THINK THE INTENTIONS ARE
GOOD BECAUSE I KNOW YOU I
RESPECT YOU. BUT WE HAVE THIS
WEIRD IDEA THAT THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY IS OUT THERE JUST.
RANDOMLY HURTING PEOPLE THEY
DON'T CARE. AND IT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY FLAWED IN A IN A
AND I'M STARTING TO REALLY SEE
A PATTERN HERE WHERE EVERYTHING
THAT WE DO IT'S ALL ABOUT THE
EMPLOYEE AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
TO BE SHORT. BUT THERE IS ALSO
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
BUSINESSES AND MO THERE'S AN
ARGUMENT BECAUSE OF THE STATE
BUDGET THAT PEOPLE AREN'T
LEAVING. BASED ON CERTAIN
SECTORS OUR BUDGET IS KIND OF
REBOUNDED. THE MY CENTRAL
VALLEY IS GETTING DECIMATED
OVER THESE ISSUES THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT THE FARM WHERE
EVERYONE AT THE FARM LABORERS.
IT'S MORE THE MANUFACTURING
SIDE THAT I HAVE A REALLY MAJOR
CONCERN BECAUSE THAT IS A
SKILLED POSITION. AND IF WE
JUST GIVE THEM. CHILD CARE IN
THE IN THIS IN THIS BILL LIKE
THEY ONLY HAVE TO PROVE THAT
THE CHILD CARE WASN'T AVAILABLE.
IT'S JUST ASSUMED. THAT THE
BEING TRUTHFUL. WHERE CAN
ACTUALLY ASK THAT. I THINK
THAT'S KIND OF A PROBLEM SO I
THINK IS AS MUCH AS WE CARE
ABOUT OUR KIDS. WE HAVE TO TAKE
A HARD LOOK AT OUR EMPLOYERS AS
WELL BECAUSE THEY TOO DESERVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE AND I AM AM.
VERY VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DIRECTION OF SOME OF THE THINGS
WE'RE GOING. IN SHAKEN NOT
STIRRED I THINK YOU'VE GOT MORE
THAN. MMHM I'LL BE BEING WANTED
BY THE OF THE COMMITTEE TO
SOLIDIFY. ANY OTHER QUESTION OR
COMMENT FROM MEMBERS- THANK YOU
I THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION I THINK THE QUOTED
CRISIS HAS EXPOSED A LOT OF
GAPS. IN OUR SOCIETY FRANKLY I
THINK CHILD CARE CERTAINLY IS
ONE OF AMON SILICON VALLEY WHAT
A HIGH AGE WORKERS EARNERS HIGH
WAGE EARNERS THAT ALSO ARE
HAVING ISSUES WHEN IT COMES TO
CHILD CARE AND- IN OCTOBER AND
I RESPECT THEM THE THOUGHTS
YOUR VICE CHAIR. TALKING ABOUT
HOW TO PULL ACROSS THE LINE BUT
THERE'S NOT A CHANCE THAT THEY
WILL HAVE TO PULL THEM ACROSS
THE LINE BECAUSE IT'LL JUST ON
THE JOB. BUT I UNDERSTAND THE
COSTS AND ALL THAT THE THAT THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION IN THAT
REGARD. HOW IT IS NOT JUST.
ABOUT THE QUANTITY OF JOBS ALSO
THE QUALITY OF LIFE PROVIDED BY
THE JOBS THAT PEOPLE HAVE AND
SO THA IS A CONSTANT
CONVERSATION HERE IN THIS
BUILDING I KNOW THERE'S
CONSTANTLY BILLS GOING FORWARD
WORKS THERE'S ARGUMENTS ON BOTH
SIDES AND THAT'S OUR JOB IS TO
FIGURE OUT. HOW TO WALK
OUTLINED HOW TO BALANCE BUT
MAKE SURE AT THE END F THE
DAY. BUT IF PEOPLE IF IT'S A
RACE TO THE BOTTOM IS THE
WORKERS GOT CRUSHED IN THAT
REACHED THE BOTTOM AND SELF HOW
DO WE ENSURE THAT WE'RE
CREATING QUALITY JOBS WHILE OUR
ECONOMY HOPEFULLY CONTINUES
NUMBER TO EXCEL AND GROW. SO
WITH THAT- WE ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION FOR THE SUMMER GONZALEZ
SECOND BY SUMMER STONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IT GOT HERE WHICH I
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS AND APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION I DO BELIEVE THAT
WE ARE IN A NEW ERA. IN WHICH
WE MUST REIMAGINE AND RETHINK
WHAT WORK AND CHILD CARE LOOKS
LIKE NOT ONLY IN THE STATE BUT
ACROSS THE NATION. THIS IS AN
ACTUAL EXAMPLE AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE OF WHAT REALLY
SHATTERING THE GLASS CEILING
LOOKS LIKE AND WE MUST BE ABLE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT PARENTS AND
SPECIFICALLY MOTHERS ARE CARE
GIVERS FRONTLINE AN ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. AND THEY DO NOT HAVE
THE LUXURY OF PICKING WHICH
ROLE THEY WANNA PLAY THAT DAY
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE IS ABOUT
EQUITY. AS MENTIONED IN LOW
WAGE AND HIGH WAGE WORKER
FIRST. OF THE 7% OF. PROVIDING
BACK UP CHILD CARE RIGHT NOW
IT'S A BEEN A- IT IS THE
EMPLOYEE AT THE- OF THE
ECONOMIC LADDER. THAT RECEIVED
ASSISTANCE. OUT WE NEED TO
CHANGE THAT HOW MANY TIMES HAVE
YOU READ IN THE NEWSPAPER THAT
A MOTHER HAS BEEN ARRESTED
BECAUSE THEY LEFT THEIR KIDS IN
THE CAR ALONE AT HOME BECAUSE
THEY HAD TO GO. TAKE AN
INTERVIEW OR GO TO A JOB THAT'S
A REALITY. AND NO MOTHER NO
PARENT SHOULD HAVE TO BE OCKED
UP AND BOOKED. BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO CHILD
CHARACTER TRYING TO PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILY. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR LARGER
COMPANIES TO THINK ABOUT THE
REALITIES. WHICH HAVE ALREADY
BEEN PROVENABOUT HOW DIFFICULT
IT IS FOR WOMEN TO RETURN TO
THE WORKFORCE GIVEN THE CURRENT
SITUATION. WHEN COMPANIES AS I
MENTIONED PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
CHILD CARE. EMPLOYEE ABSENCES
DECREASE BY 2230% TURNOVER
DROPPED BY THIRTY SEVEN TO
SIXTY PERCENT- AND THAT IS WHY.
THIS CONVERSATION IT'S
IMPORTANT AND SO NEEDED RIGHT
NOW WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF AGAIN WE DO HAVE A
MOTION MADAM SECRETARY FROM
CALL THE ROLL AND AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY NINE. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA
AYE KALRA AYE FLORA. FLOOR
UNKNOWN GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE
STONE. STONE I SEE I DON'T KNOW
SEE I DON'T KNOW WHAT. THE
BOARD. LORD I. THE BILL IS OUT
THE LATEST PREPARATIONS YOU
SOME ARMOR. UP NEXT WE HAVE
BARBARA ITEM FOR. A. B. NINE
EIGHTY THREE EDUARDO GARCIA
THIS ALSO ENJOYS A- DO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMENDATION
AND WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO
MAKE AN- EMOTION A SECOND MAY
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
PERFECT A. B. NINETY THREE
WOULD REQUIRE AGENCIES AND
ENTITIES AND RESTRAINING PUBLIC
FUNDS TO EXPAND THE USE OF
COMMITTEE WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS
ON LARGE SCALE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS RELATED TO BATTERY
MANUFACTURING. BASED TECHNOLOGY
THAT THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION IS CURRENTLY UNDER-
A LOT OF RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT TAKING PLACE AND-
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT COULD
BE A MAJOR GAME CHANGER TO
BRINGING MANUFACTURING- AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE GOOD
PAYING JOBS IN CALIFORNIA.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR APPLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN. TESLA'S
APART WE HAVE. JOHN WHITE AND
SYLVIA BONDS. WITH EACH OTHER
UP TO TWO MINUTES AND SO JOHN
IF YOU'RE PREPARED OR YOU'RE ON
THE LINE YOU MAY BEGIN. I DO
NOT SEE JOHN AT THE TIME BUT IF
YOU ARE ON YOU MAY PRESS STAR
ZERO AND I WILL OPEN YOUR LINE.
IF JOHN'S OTHERS IF SYLVIA'S
THERE SHE MAY BEGIN. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THANK YOU- THANK YOU
CHAIR THE FILE FROM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH AN
QUESTIONS ABOUT ME AND I ALSO
THINK THAT THE VICE PRESIDENT
FOR THE KITCHEN OF A LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE BOND ELECTION.
ARE THIRTY MINUTE IS THAT
UNANSWERED WORKS WITH THEM YET
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
REPRESENTS HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE CARPET AND THEN WHAT IT IS
IMPORTANT. THAT WE TAKE STEPS
NOW. I TO CREATE. PATHWAYS
ECONOMIC WITH FOR ABOUT THE IT.
COMMUNITY WORK AGREE FOR OUR
READ TO BATTERY ONE. AND WE BE
A KNOWLEDGE OF. IT PARTICULARLY
IN COURT TO ONE WE CAN DO.
ABOUT ADMINISTRATION IT CAN
CREATE A. TENSION AND
RECOVERING. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE VALUE OF COMMUNITY WORK
FOR SIX WITH THE INTEGRITY
TARGETED HIRING FOR INTO FROM
REPRESENTED COULD. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THE GOAL THE
CRIBBAGE OF WHR THROUGH A
PRACTICE PROCESS THAT ALLOWS OF
THE CAN TO THE AND I THINK THAT
SOME MEMBER CARD. KOREAN
COOKING THE SENATE BILL AND
THAT THE IS THE PERFECT AT THE
BILL FORWARD IT WILL I WOULD
RESPECT WITH- THAT THE FOR
CROSSES THE AND BEYOND THE
CREATION OF THE FIFA REYES
HURRICANE COMMITTEE IN MONITOR
CROSS. AS WELL AS IT RCW A
SHOULD CREATE FOR VIGIL SO LOW
INCOME COMMUNITY TO ACCESS
CONTENTS OF JOPLIN ACCORDING UP
WITH. EIGHTY NINE THREE OF AN
IMPORTANT SACRIFICE DRINKING
ENGAGEMENT CENTER TEMP QUITE
AND I URGE FROM O'CLOCK THANK
THANK YOU SO MUCH. JOHN WHITE.
JOHN'S RIGHT. YEP I'M READY-
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHN- I'M
WORKING TODAY HATHAWAY CO BUT
IS IN IN DEVELOPING NEW TECH TO
EXTRACT LITHIUM FROM FROM PRIDE-
WE THIS BILL BECAUSE BELIEVE
THE THOSE ARE NOT THE- A THE
VERY BEGINNING OF A NEW WINDOW.
IN A JUST A COMMUNITY- TO ABLE
TO INVOLVE THE COMMUNITY IN THE
PLANNING FOR THE- DEVELOPMENT
OF THE INDUSTRY INCLUDING THE
WORK FORCE BUT TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT SO WE SUPPORT THE
BILL AB APPRECIATE MR PURSUIT
OF LEADERSHIP ON DEVELOPING A
CALIFORNIA LITHIUM INDUSTRY CAN
HELP OF GLOBALLY. AS WELL AS
LOCALLY. THANK YOU FOR MUCH.
THANK YOU I WOULD YOU KNOW. ONE
PUBLIC COMMENT IS THERE ANYONE
THE ROOM THAT ALLOW TO- SUPPORT
LET'S POSITION FOR A BI NINETY
THREE. IF NOT WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE- IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE EIGHTY THREE. GIVE IT. IF
YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
EIGHTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO NOW. ONE AND THEN
THEY'RE OFF YOUR IN SUPPORT.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU-
MODERATOR AND MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS BEGIN THE JOURNEY CARE
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL. I WE ARE NEUTRAL TODAY
ON THE BILL ALTHOUGH I COULD
NOT AGREE MORE WITH MR GARCIA
COMMENT ON P. W. A. AND THE
SPEAKERS WE JUST WANT TO STAY
IN TOUCH WITH THAT OFFICE LIKE
WE ALREADY HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT CURRENT. STATE LAW
REGARDING PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS- JIBES WITH THIS
BILL AS WELL- REPORT FOR THE
CONVERSATION CONTINUING I JUST
WANT TO WEIGH IN TODAY JUST
MAKE SURE THE CANADIAN
EVERYBODY KNEW THAT WE WERE
INVOLVED AND WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE STAY INVOLVED. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH GERMANY. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE- ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT.
THAT'S THE OF. YEAR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
NOT SHOPPER ONE ON BEHALF OF AB
CALIFORNIA HEARING THAT SUPPORT
IT'S AMENDED POSITION AND WE'RE
HOPING TO DISCUSS INCLUSIVE
WOULD ALLOW ALL OF PROJECTED
GRADUATES FROM ALL STATE GROUP
BRIDGE PROGRAMS. WE'LL GET INTO
THAT THANK YOU MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO OF ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE ONE EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THE ROCK CHILD
FROM THE COALITION FOR
INCLUSIVE CAPITALISM JUST TO
SAY THAT WE ARE IN SUPPORT AND
WOULD LIKE TO STAY IN THE FORM
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE BY NO FURTHER-
SUPPORT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY WITNESSES LISTED
IN OPPOSITION HOWEVER I WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR ANYONE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ANYONE IN THE ROOM.
IF NOT WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ANYONE AGAIN THIS IS A.
B. NINE EIGHTY THREE- ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONES.
EUROPEAN OPPOSITION OF AB
NINETY THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
IN OPPOSITION. OF A. B. NINE
EIGHT THREE. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
IN Q. ONE MOMENT. AND AGAIN AND
THE OPPOSITION OF A. B. NINE
EIGHT THREE. THAT WILL ABOUT
THE LINE OF ONE OH SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS RICHARD
MARCUSSEN FOR THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION. WE'RE NOT AWARE OF
ANY PROHIBITION ANYWHERE IN
STATE LAW- THE PROPENSITY OF
THE CADENCE TO FROM ENTERING
INTO A COMMUNITY WORKFORCE
AGREEMENT SO WE THINK THAT THE
BILL IS UNNECESSARY.
FURTHERMORE THE STATEMENTS BY
MR SMITH IN THE INCLUSION OF
SECTION TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED OF
THE PUBLIC CONTRACTS CODE WHICH
REFERS TO PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS. SUGGEST THAT THIS
IS REALLY AN ULTERIOR MOTIVE
THIS IS ABOUT PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS IT'S NOT ABOUT AN
INCLUSIVE ENVIRONMENT WE ARE
OPPOSED FOR THOSE REASONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A MOTION
ALREADY FROM AS A MEMBER
GONZALEZ SECONDED BY SOME
MEMBER AWARD. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR. IF
NOT- JUST WANNA THANK THE
AUTHOR I DO KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OF CONVERSATIONS WITH THOSE
THAT HAVE SOME CONCERNS I KNOW
YOUR OFFICE HAS BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY. WITH THEM AND I
IMAGINE WE'LL START OUT OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS WILL
CONTINUE SO I APPRECIATE THAT-
AND WITH THAT. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE LARA I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT THEM I THINK THE- COMMENTS
THAT WE'VE HEARD. AREN'T SO
MUCH LEANING TOWARDS CONCERNS
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE LAST
ONE- ABOUT AN ALTERNATE MODE OF
AN ADDRESS THAT I THINK THE
QUESTION HERE IS. A THE LITHIUM
INDUSTRY AND OPPORTUNITIES ARE
NEW. TO CALIFORNIA SO THERE'S A
LOT OF UNANSWERED QUESTIONS
TERRITORIES THAT WE'VE NEVER
REALLY BOUGHT INTO. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO WITH THE ALTAR
MOTIVE IS SET A STRUCTURE. FOR
ANY RIGHT IN THIS CASE THE
LITHIUM OPPORTUNITIES. TO
ESTABLISH THEMSELVES IN
CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS THE
GLOBAL NEEDS AS WELL AS THE-
STATE GOLDEN OBJECTIVES. TO
HAVE A FRAMEWORK IN PLACE
ALREADY THAT WILL ENSURE AND
ADDRESS. COMMUNITY BASED NEEDS
WHEN IT COMES TO WORKFORCE.
PATHWAYS TO THESE JOBS AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE GOOD
LIVING. WAGE JOBS. AT SO THERE
IS NO ALTERNATIVE MOTIVE BUT
THAT ONE- AND IF THAT SUB THE
BAD THING THEN YOU KNOW I'M NOT
APOLOGETIC ABOUT THAT. I JUST
WANNA SAY THAT THAT WERE
WORKING AGAIN WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THOSE
WHO ARE OPPOSED. TO CLARIFY.
WHAT THE INTENT OF THIS BILL
IS. AND I BELIEVE THAT WHEN
IT'S ALL SAID AND DONE WHAT WE
WILL HAVE DONE IS SET UP A
STRONG FOUNDATION. FOR GOOD.
LIVING WAGE JOBS FOR A REGION
THAT HISTORICALLY. HAS HAD. THE
HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- UP FOR
DECADES AND SO HERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TURN AROUND THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND YOU KNOW WE
CAN GET INTO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ASPECTS OF THIS BUT WE KNOW
THAT OUR CLIMATE POLICIES. HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN CREATING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS
AND HERE'S ONE EXAMPLE OF HOW
WE MAY BE ABLE TO ADD TO THAT
SUCCESS. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR APPLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WITH. THAT- MADAM SECRETARY OF
CAN HAVE OF. THE ROLE. KALRA HI
FLORA FLORIDA NOT VOTING AND
SALAS RIGHT GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE STONE
SEATTLE NO SEATTLE NO WARD WARD
HI RIGHT FOR THOSE OUT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. UP NEXT UP ON FIVE
A. B. SEVEN EIGHTY THREE IS A
MEMBER GRAY. AND SO WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB
SEVENTY THREE IS A MEASURE TO
IMPROVE WORKPLACE SAFETY-
CONDITIONS OF SURFACE MINING
OPERATIONS THE BILL CONTAINS
TWO PRIMARY PROVISIONS FIRST IT
REQUIRES THE INSPECTORS REPORT
OBSERVED HAZARDS WITHIN SEVENTY
TWO HOURS TO THE MINE OPERATORS
THAT THEY CAN BE ADDRESSED AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. CURRENTLY
OPERATORS MAY NOT BE MADE AWARE
OF HAZARDS FOR WEEKS OR MONTHS
WE'VE THE CURRENT REQUIREMENTS
WITHIN SIX MONTHS- THIS WOULD
MAKE THAT SEVENTY TWO HOURS
OBVIOUSLY- ALLOWING. THE FOLKS
MANAGING THOSE- SITES TO ACT
QUICKER. THE SECOND PROVISION
THE BILL PERMITS BUT DOES NOT
REQUIRE CALLOW SHOULD TO ACCEPT
SURFACE MINING WORKSITES INTO
THE VOLUNTARY. PROTECTION
PROGRAM. THE PURPOSE OF THE VPP
IS TO ENCOURAGE WORK PLACES TO
ADOPTED HERE TO MORE RIGOROUS
AND ENHANCED WORKPLACE SAFETY
PROGRAMS THAN THE MINIMUM
STANDARDS REQUIRED BY LAW.
ACCEPTANCE INTO THE PROGRAM IS
A HIGH BAR- INVOLVES A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS WHICH
INCLUDES- IN GAUGING WITH LABOR
TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE NO
OBJECTIONS- FROM THE UNION OUR
WORKERS ON THE GROUND. THE BILL
SUPPORTED BY CALCIUM A GRANITE
CONSTRUCTION OTHERS I HAVE WITH
ME TODAY MEMBERS IN SUPPORT OF
HE BILL- CHARLIE RAY FROM
CALCIUM AND GARY JOHNSON WITH
GRANITE- THEY'RE PREPARED TO
MAKE SOME REMARKS AS CHAIRMAN-
IF IT PLEASES THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR REMEMBER-
YES SO WE DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES
OF UP TO TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE. CHARLIE RAY IF YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY BEGIN. HELLO I'M
CHARLIE RAY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION AND INDUSTRIAL
MATERIALS DISSERTATION. BIRDS
OF CALCIUM TO PRODUCE AGGREGATE
AND INDUSTRIAL MINERALS THAT
ARE USED TO BUILD ROADS HOMES
BRIDGES HOSPITALS SCHOOLS AND
MORE THE BILL AB SEVENTY THREE
PROPOSES TO UPDATE SAFETY FOR
SURFACE MINING OPERATIONS IN
TWO WAYS. FIRST I NOTICED
HAZARDOUS TO BE ISSUED THE
MINING OPERATOR WITHIN SEVENTY
TWO HOURS IF DURING THE
INSPECTION HAZARDS ARE
IDENTIFIED. THIS IS TO ENSURE
THAT ACTIONS CAN BE TAKEN
QUICKLY TO PROTECT WORKERS
WHILE NOT IMPACTING THE REGULAR
CITATION ENFORCEMENT PROCESS
STONE. SECOND. IT WOULD
ELIMINATE THE CONFLICT IN THE.
YES GOOD MORNING- MY NAME IS
GARY JOHNSON I'M WITH GRANITE
CONSTRUCTION COMPANY- A MEMBER
OF UNIONIZED CONSTRUCTION
AGGREGATE AND MINING COMPANIES
LIKE GRANITE CONSTRUCTION
DEVELOP THIS PROPOSAL. WE'VE
BEEN VERY FRUSTRATED AT ALL THE
MANY MONTHS PASSED BETWEEN
SAFETY INSPECTION AND WHEN WE
LEARNED ABOUT A HAS YOUR- WE DO
NOT WANT TO INTERFERE WITH THE
CITATION PROCESS WHICH CAN
REQUIRE MONTHS TO COMPLETE. NOR
DO WE WANT TO LIMIT THE
PENALTIES THAT MIGHT BE AT THAT.
SO WE DEVISED A SOLUTION THAT
LEAVES THE CITATION PRODUCT
THAT I'M TAG. BUT ALLOWED. TO
BE NOTIFIED ABOUT HAS. THAT WE
CAN IMMEDIATELY ADDRESS
BILLBOARD IN INJURY TO AN
EMPLOYEE. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT NAME AFFILIATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM. IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTY THREE. IF NOT
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND GO TO THE
PHONES ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN EIGHTY THREE. GIVE YOUR
SUPPORT OF A. B. SEVEN EIGHT
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND ZERO IF YOU
WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB. SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE. AND ONE MOMENT
WHERE WE GATHER THEIR NUMBERS.
AND AGAIN ADDED SUPPORT OF AB
IS. SEVEN EIGHTY THREE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OVER TO- TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TRADEMARK
WHERE WITH THE IMPROVISERS ON
BEHALF OF VULCAN MATERIALS
COMPANY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
TO VOTE TO LINE OF SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
MEGAN MEAL WITH THE PEER
INDUSTRIAL STANDS IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE WILL GO
TO. LINE AT SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE LAST MINUTE FOR
CONSTRUCTION WE SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT. WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS JOHN SHERIDAN WITH.
CHILLER BRAND AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN EXTRA GO TO LINE
OF TWO OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE TWO ZERO FIVE DO YOU
HAVE A SON YOU. HI. ONE CAN'T
HI MY NAME IS JACQUELINE
CAPITAL ONE I'M WITH RIVERSIDE
MILLING COMPANY AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE DO NOT HAVE A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION- LISTED
BUT I WOULD LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITY IF ANYONE DOES WANT
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. NO ONE HERE IN OPPOSITION
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO ON THE
PHONE AB SEVENTY THREE IS THERE
ANYONE. IN OPPOSITION. MADAME
MODERATOR YOU CHECK FOR THAT.
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVEN EIGHTY THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO FEAR IN
OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION TO QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
I KNOW WE HAVE A MOTION WE
DON'T HAVE A SECOND HAS WILL
MOST PROVIDERS ARE SECOND. AS A
SECOND FROM DECEMBER SAY ART
OPENING CONVOCATION THE SUMMER
GONZALEZ. I JUST IT'S SO SIMPLE
I IT'S SO SIMPLE I WANT TO MAKE
SURE I UNDERSTAND THE LIKE READ
IT OVER AND OVER. NORMALLY THE
CITATION HAS TO BE GIVEN WITHIN
SIX MONTHS BUT THIS SAYS YOU
HAVE TO ACTUALLY TELL THE
OPERATOR WHAT THEY'RE DOING
WRONG WITHIN SEVEN TWO HOURS
FOR IT JUST FOR THE GENERAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF. OF MAKING
IT A BETTER WORKPLACE FOR THE
WORKERS IF YOU WELL I MEAN IT
THAT'S NOT WHAT IT SAYS BUT
IT'S A QUICKER NOTICE THOUGH
THAT. THE CORRECTION CAN BE
MADE ALTHOUGH OF THE CITATIONS
THE CITATION WILL STILL COME
OUT. IS THAT RIGHT THAT'S
IMPORTANT FOR EIGHTEEN TO LONG
AND THE- THERE'S NO ADVANTAGE
TO- THE EMPLOYER OF THE SITE A
IN THE SENSE OF RELIEVING SOME
LIABILITY FROM A CITATION
RECITATIONS CITATION IF THERE'S
SOMETHING- OUT OF SORTS IT
NEEDS TO BE RECTIFIED. WHAT
THIS DOES THOSE AND OBVIOUSLY
CREATES A SAFER WORKPLACE IN
THE- IN THE NEAR TERM- WITHIN
SEVENTY TWO HOURS GIVING THOSE
FOLKS AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THAT RIGHT AWAY- WHICH IS IN
EVERYBODY'S INTEREST- IT ALSO
INTERNED WITH THE SECOND
PROVISION THE BILL ALLOWS. THE
MINING SITE TO A IN ESSENCE BE
A GOOD CORPORATE CITIZEN RIGHT
IF I'M GONNA GO OUT OF MY WAY
TO IT HERE TO HIGHER STANDARDS
TO CORRECT THE- A VIOLATION
WITHIN SEVENTY TWO HOURS- GOOD
CORPORATE CITIZEN. STREAMLINED
THE PROCESS. ABBAS WANTED BUT
YEAH THERE'S NOTHING YOUR
RESIDENTS VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD
VERY SIMPLE BILL WITH THE TWO
PROVISIONS THAT I MENTIONED IN
MY OPENING WHAT HAPPENS IF- I
GUESS IT'S THE GOVERNMENT WHO
IS ISSUING THE NOTICE WITHIN
SEVENTY TWO HOURS RIGHT IT'S
WHOEVER'S DOING THE INSPECTION-
WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY DON'T.
ISSUE IT IN SEVENTY TWO HOURS
AND ARE THEY- PROHIBITED FROM
DOING THE VIOLATE THAT
SALVATION OKAY NO THERE'S THAT
THAT THERE'S NO. I WISH THAT
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL TO THE SITE
AND WE WOULD HOPE THAT. THE
VARIOUS AGENCIES WOULD IN FACT
MEET WITH A CENTERS BUT IF THEY
DON'T THERE'S NO. FALLOUT FROM
THAT AND THEN IT'S ANOTHER DAY
GONE BY WITHOUT. A VIOLATION
BEING ADDRESSED RIGHT. RIGHT
I'M ANY OTHER OF COURSE COM
YEAH YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THE
MORE QUICKLY THINGS GET
RESOLVED IT'S GOOD FOR EVERYONE
INVOLVED THEY WERE TRYING TO
GET AND HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT IT
DOESN'T. PRECLUDE CITATIONS AND
OTHER MECHANISMS THAT ARE IN
PLACE- BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY I THINK IT'S BETTER THAT-
TO THE EMPLOYERS- SOONER RATHER
LATER THAN THAT NOT ONLY IS IT
A LOWER LIABILITY TO THEM IT
CREATES A SAFER WORK
ENVIRONMENT MORE QUICKLY WHICH
IS WHAT WE ALL WANT. SO WITH
THAT WE DO- HAVE A MOTION WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE CEMETERY I
JUST THANK YOU FOR THE DIALOGUE
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
RIVAL THANK YOU SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION OF MOISTURE FOR A SECOND
BY SUMMER SAY ART THOUGH AMOUNT
OF SECRETARY PAUL THE ROLE IN
AB SEVEN EIGHTY THREE. MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA I KALRA HI FLORA FLORA HI
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER FIVE JONES SAWYER AYE
STONE. ZERO FIVE ZERO I WORK.
WARD I. HI THOSE UP THANK YOU
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME. ALL RIGHT
WE. UP UP NEXT MELISSA THIS
SUMMER MURATSUCHI- SO I'LL GO
IN ORDER UNLESS THERE'S ANOTHER
ARRANGEMENT MADE WITH THE
AUTHORS. SO WE HAVE EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY- AND SO WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY A SERVER IS BEGIN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS- THIS BILL AS A JOINT
AUTHOR OF AB SIX FIVE ZERO.
FIRST OF ALL I JUST CAME FROM
GETTING MY SHOT SO. I WANT TO
SAY A- THANK GOD FOR THE FRONT
LINE HEALTH CARE WORKERS. AND
SO I AM HERE TO PRESENT THE
HEALTHCARE WORKER RECOGNITION
AND RETENTION ACT. YOU KNOW I
WAS JUST FORWARDED TO. ANY
MAIL- TODAY A THE WASHINGTON
POST KAISER FAMILY FOUNDATION
POLL THAT JUST CAME OUT- WHERE
THEY FOUND AT THREE AND TEN
HEALTH CARE WORKERS- ARE
WEIGHING LEAVING THEIR
PROFESSION I'M- MORE THAN HALF.
ARE BURNT OUT. FROM THE
PANDEMIC. AND ABOUT SIX IN TEN
SAY THAT THE STRESS FROM THE
PANDEMIC HAS HARMED THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH. AND SO THAT'S
WHY I AM PRESENTING. AB SIX
FIFTY- WITH ARE YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- MR RODRIGUEZ IN
THE AUDIENCE. N. THE OUR
FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
YOU KNOW IT'S SO. ALMOST A YEAR
AGO FROM TODAY THE GOVERNOR
NEWSOM DECLARED THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND- WHILE WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE THE PRIVILEGE. OF
WORKING- FROM THE SAFETY OF OUR
HOMES. OUR FRONTLINE HEALTH
CARE WORKERS. DAY IN DAY OUT
THEY HAD TO GO ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THIS PANDEMIC. THE
GOING TO COMBAT AGAINST THIS
HORRIFIC VIRUS. THEY WENT TO
WORK PUTTING THEMSELVES AT RISK
ON A DAILY BASIS TO TAKE CARE
OF OUR FAMILIES OUR LOVED ONES.
THOSE AMONG US. WHO SUFFERED
AND DIED. FROM THIS TERRIBLE
VIRUS. THEY WENT INTO A
DANGEROUS WORKPLACE ON A DAILY
BASISOFTEN WITH INADEQUATE
PROTECTIVE. EQUIPMENT LACK OF
TO. LAW WORK YOU FEW BROUGH. IN
ORDER TO TAKE CARE OF OTHERS IN
THE SAME LIVES. MANY AS I JUST
INDICATED HAVE PAID A
SIGNIFICANT PRICE OF FRONT LINE
WORK WITH THE MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL SCARS TO SHOW FOR IT.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT THE OVER
SIXTEEN HUNDRED HEALTHCARE
WORKERS HAVE DIED IN THE LINE
OF DUTY. A SURVEY OUR FRONTLINE
HEALTH CARE WORKERS THEY ARE
HEROES. AND THAT'S WHY THEY
DESERVE THIS RIGHT RECOGNITION
AND RETENTION BONUS THE HAZARD
PAY THE COMBAT PAY THAT IS
BEING PROPOSED IN AB SIX FIFTY.
I WOULD LIKE TO. TURN IT OVER
TO OUR TO SUPPORTING WITNESSES
FOR THIS BILL. MATT LEADS FROM
SEIU AND GISELA THOMAS A
RESPIRATORY SPECIALIST WITH THE
DESERT. REGIONAL MEDICAL CENTER
TO TALK ABOUT HER FRONT LINE
EXPERIENCE I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF WE ARE WITNESSES FOR UP
TO TWO MINUTES EACH AND SO WE
HAVE A MANAGING AND GISELA
THOMAS- MATT IF YOU'RE READY
YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON
JERRY MEMBERS MATHIS A ABOUT
THE AS YET YOU CALIFORNIA THE
PROUD SPONSOR OF EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY. FIRST ELECTED I THANK
THE CHAIR AND HIS STAFF FOR
THIS THEIR WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE- THROUGHOUT THE
CALL THE NINETEENTH PANDEMIC
HEALTHCARE WORKERS HAVE BEEN ON
THE FRONT LINES PROTECTING
RESIDENTS ARE NURSING HOMES.
CARING FOR PATIENTS IN
HOSPITALS AND VACCINATING OUR
LOVED ONES. FOR THE PAST YEAR
HEALTHCARE WORKERS HAVE GONE TO
WORK EVERY DAY KNOWING THAT
THEY WERE RISKING THEIR OWN
LIVES. AND HEALTH OF THEIR
FAMILIES. IN NURSING HOMES AND
HOSPITALS HEALTHCARE WORKERS
COMP THREE ASIAN SIMPLY FOR
FAMILY MEMBERS WERE NOT
PERMITTED TO BE WITH THEIR
LOVED ONES. AND WORKERS
THROUGHOUT HEALTHCARE I'VE
WITNESSED SUFFERING THAT HAS
BEEN DESCRIBED AS LIKE A WAR
ZONE OR IN THE WAKE. OF A
DISASTER LIKE HURRICANE KATRINA.
AND IT. IN A TO- TO THE
DIRECTORATE SEVEN FACTION
STAFFING SHORTAGES INCREASED
PATIENT RATIO AND GRUELING
SHIFTS HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO
EXTREMELY HIGH LEVELS OF
BURNOUT EMOTIONAL TRAUMA AND
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS.
ESPECIALLY EARLY IN THE
PANDEMIC HEALTHCARE WORKERS
FECES CONDITIONS WITH
INSUFFICIENT PROTECTIVE
pHEALTHCARE WORKERS TO MAKE OR
BUY THEIR OWN P. P. ONCE IT WAS
CLEAR THAT THEY CANNOT GET
ADEQUATE PROTECTION FROM THEIR
EMPLOYERS. HEALTHCARE WORKERS
HAVE ALSO WENT TO EXTREME
LENGTHS TO KEEP THEIR FAMILY
SAFE INCLUDING SOME CORN CAME
AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILIES FOR
WEEKS FOR MONTHS AT A TIME.
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY THE NECESSARY
TO HELP RETAIN SKILLED AND
EXPERIENCED HEALTHCARE WORKERS
IN CALIFORNIA. EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
EXPAND ITS HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
AT THE AGING POPULATION
INCREASED DEMAND FOR HEALTHCARE
SERVICES. SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THE MAJORITY OF
THE LATINO AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
NATIVE AMERICAN RT LIVE AND
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE
AREAS. NOW MANY HEALTHCARE
WORKERS ARE REACHING A BREAKING
POINT AND CONSIDERING LEAVING
THE PROFESSION. ASEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED JEFF TODAY KAISER
FAMILY FOUNDATION RELEASED A
REPORT SAYING THREE INTENT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS ARE CONSIDER
CONSIDERING LEAVING THE
PROFESSION WHICH WILL
EXASPERATED ACCESS ISSUES THE
CARE- IN OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. HEALTHCARE WORKER
TURNOVER COMES WITH HIGH COSTS
OF TRAINING REPLACE WORKERS AND
ALSO JEOPARDIZES PATIENT CARE.
THIS IS A CRITICAL TIME TO
INCENTIVIZE HEALTHCARE WORKERS
TO REMAIN AND TO DEMONSTRATE TO
FUTURE HEALTH CARE WORKERS THAT
THEY WILL BE SUPPORTED DURING
DIFFICULT PUBLIC HEALTH CRISES.
EVEN PROVIDERS HAVE RECOGNIZED
THE NEED FOR BONUSES TO RECRUIT
AND RETAIN HEALTHCARE WORKERS
THE AMERICAN HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION HAS EVEN USED-
WORKERS TO ADVOCATE FOR MORE
MONEY CITING THE NEED TO
PROVIDE HAZARD PAY. AS PART OF
WHY HOSPITALS NEED FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. HOWEVER HOW TO PAY
LARGELY FAILED TO MATERIALIZE
AND MANY COMPANIES THAT DID
PROVIDE SOME FORM ADDITIONAL
COMPENSATION EARLY IN THE
PANDEMIC ENDED THOSE BENEFITS
AFTER A FEW WEEKS OR MONTHS.
HEALTH CARE COMPANIES HAVE BEEN
IT BENEFITED FROM BILLIONS IN
FEDERAL SUPPORT DURING THE
PANDEMIC INCLUDING DIRECT
GRANTS AND TAX RELIEF THAT
WOULD COME FROM THE CARADOC AND
OTHER FEDERAL STIMULUS BILL.
RECORD BREAKING INVESTING COMES
IN HIGHER THAN EXPECTED
OPERATIONAL REVENUE. MANY
HEALTHCARE. INTO TWENTY TWENTY
EVEN MORE PROFITABLE THAN THEY
HAD IN TWENTY NINETEEN BUT
THOSE GAMES HAVE NOT BEEN
SHARED WITH THE HEALTHCARE
WORKERS ARE PUTTING THEIR LIVES
AT RISK. THIS BILL SIMPLY ASK
WHEN EMPLOYERS CALL THEIR
HEALTHCARE WORKERS HEROES. IS
THAT JUST HOLLOW WORDS. EVOKE
FOR EIGHTY SIX FIFTY PROVIDES
SUBSTANTIVE CAN'T WILL PROVE TO
HELP THE WORKERS THAT THEIR
PSYCHIC SACRIFICES DURING THE
PANDEMIC ARE RECOGNIZED AND
INVESTED IN OUR FUTURE TO
ENSURE THAT OUR CARE GIVERS ARE
THERE WHEN WE NEED THEM THE
MOST. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ON
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HI ANGELA THOMAS IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE FOR HADN'T
AGAIN. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME
IS ELIZABETH HAMILTON I'M A
RESPIRATORY THERAPIST NOW IT
DOESN'T BEACH NOT MEDICAL
CENTER IN PALM SPRINGS. I HAVE
BEEN A RESPIRATORY THERAPIST
WILL LOOK FORTY YEARS. AND I'VE
ALSO WORKED IN HOSPITALS IN SAN
DIEGO. I LOVE WHAT I'M DOING
I'M NOT TAKING CARE OF PATIENTS
THAT HAVE DIFFICULTY BREATHING.
THANK YOU CANNOT GET A BETTER
RESPIRATORY THERAPIST AND
MYSELF. JUST ASK THE DOCTOR
I'VE WORKED WITH IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM AND DAY IN
TRAUMA MY PRIMARY AREA OF
RESPONSIBILITY. SO I SPEAK FOR
MYSELF AND ALL MY COWORKERS THE
NURSES CNA'S ADMITTING FACT
CLARK'S LAP TAX. MEAT SAUCE SO
MUCH PAIN THAT WE WERE AFRAID
TO SIT DOWN TO TAKE OUR BREAKS
BECAUSE THE PATIENT MAY NEED US
AND THEY DIE BY WE EAT. WE GOT
TO REST IN OUR GARAGES AFTER
GOING HOME. FROM EXHAUSTING
SHIPS. I PUT MY IN BAD AND THEN
THE IN TRASH. NUMBER FIVE EVEN
LIVED IN OUR GARAGES WHY DIDN'T
CALL HOME FOR WEEKS BECAUSE
THEY WERE AFRAID TO PASS CODE
WHICH TO OUR FAMILY MEMBERS. I
CAN TELL YOU ABOUT THE NURSE
THAT BURKE EXTRACTION. TO PAY
OFF BILLS BECAUSE HE WAS GOING
TO RETIRE HERE APRIL THE
FIFTEENTH BUT THEN HE CAUGHT TO
COPE WITH IT HE DIED IN
JANUARY. I CAN TELL YOU ABOUT
THE TRANSPORT A GLAND WHO
TRANSPORTED TWENTY THAT BODIES
TO THE MORGUE YES OF WHAT WAS
FULL SO HE HAD TO TAKE THEM TO
A REFRIGERATOR TRUCK THAT WAS
PARKED OUTSIDE IN THE ICU
PARKING LOT. AT THAT SAME
TRANSPORT OF WHAT'S REFUSED IN
NINETY FIVE MAPPED AT THE.
BEGINNING OF THE CALL THE
PANDEMIC. YOU DON'T KNOW A BATH
HE WAS. STILL I'M SO FOR HIM.
WHAT ALSO FOR THE LAB TECH THIS
DO IT THAT THE TO THE PLOT FROM
CORPORATE PATIENT IN THERE
WASN'T A PAPPA AVAILABLE. AND
SHE ENDED UP CATCHING CORPORATE-
I'M SPEAKING FOR HER ALSO.
PENTATHLETE CAPTAIN HELENA'S WE
ARE STARTING TO SEE A LIGHT AT
THE END OF THE TUNNE BUT THE
COLLECTIVE PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT WILL
FOR EVER ABBOTT ABBOTT STAYED
WITH ME AND FOR WITH US HEALTH
CARE WORKERS DESERVE
RECOGNITION FOR WHAT THEY ARE
GOING THROUGH AND WENT THROUGH.
WHICH IS WHY I'M ASKING THAT WE
ONE OF YOU THE ASSEMBLY TO
PLEASE PLEASE PATH SB SIX FIFTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE WILL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE ROOM. THERE'S NO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE ROOM A
META MODERATORS WE CAN CHECK ON
THE PHONE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
SUPPORT. OF AB SIX FIFTY. THANK
YOU FOR ITS SUPPORT OF AB SIX
FIFTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO
FAIR IN SUPPORT OF A. B. SIX
FIFTY. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
OF EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MATT
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND THE ENGINEERS AND
SCIENTISTS THE CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FIFTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YOU HAVE A SON YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEXICO
CAROLINA ONE EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS IMAGE FACTOR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN SPORTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT ACROSS THE LINE
OF TWO NINETEEN. NOW NOT OVER
LINE OF TWO TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU JUDGE SHERMAN
AND- BOARD MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
JOE SUMMER'S GONNA BE UP THE
COUNTRY ABOUT THE LABOR COUNCIL
AND WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EXPECTED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OF A LINE OF AT TWO TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS WORKING REMOTELY
NINE WHAT THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FEDERATION OF LABOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT UP A
LOT OF TWO HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOE LEAN AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THIS PROJECT STATE
COLLEGE DEMOCRATS IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIX FIFTY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO TIMELINE UP TO
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS JENNIFER
MCKENZIE AND I AM A MEMBER OF
P. E. I. U. LOCAL TWENTY NINE
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
THAT. AB SIX FIFTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT AGO
LINE OF TWO TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
DARLENE PATRICK I REPRESENT
INDIVISIBLE STANISLAUS AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SIX FIFTY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A
LINE OF TWO OH EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ESPECIALLY LOS
ANGELES COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TRUCKS- HEARD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF LOS ANGELES
DEMOCRATIC PARTY CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE PARTY IN OUR
THREE MILLION DEMOCRATS LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIX FIFTY. THE
REQUESTED BY BOAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OF OUR LINE OF
TWO OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS WILLIAM KELLY I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE NORTH
VALLEY LABOR FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIX SIXTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWO
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON BOBBIE LOCALES
HERE LEGISLATION CULTURE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL COMMITTEE.
WHICH IS THE MOST AFFORDABLE
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A
LINE OF TWO TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS BECKY
ROSE I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE ALAMEDA LABOR COUNCIL
AFL-CIO. FOR CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX THAT THE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO A
LINE OF TWO TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BY TWO TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I THINK
ON TUESDAY TO I THINK I AM FIVE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS CONNIE
TAYLOR STUDENTS AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF PHILLIPS
TEMPLE CME CHURCH IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIX FIFTY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AN EXTROVERT THE
LINE OF TWO THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE HI THIS IS EDDIE
SANCHEZ OUT IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE OF PRESIDENT OF THE
COMPANY NO COUNTY YOUNG DEMS
HAULING IN SUPPORT OF AB. SIX
FIFTY I WE KNOW THE PELCO
WORKERS HAVE BEEN ON THE FRONT
LINES IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
RENDON CELLS IN THE FAMILY THAT
WRITTEN IN ORDER TO CARE FOR
MILLIONS OF PATIENTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOT TO GO TO LINE OF
TWO THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWO THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. DO YOU HAVE A TIME YOU.
TO THIRTY FIVE. WE WILL GO LINE
OF A TWO THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS GLEN
SHOWER I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE MODERATE THE CENTRAL LABOR
COUNCIL. AFL-CIO IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY SIX FIFTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ACROSS THE LINE OF TWO
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JOHN
REILLY I REPRESENT THE SIBLINGS
OF THE NAPA SOLANO CENTRAL
LABOR COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SIX FIFTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT A
LINE OF FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND YOU'RE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
AFTER A FULL SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SIX FIFTY THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A
LINE OF TO ALL ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS DANIEL MOORE
FROM THE CENTRAL COAST LABOR
COUNCIL AND- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB FIFTY. THANK YOU.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FROM BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF ONE
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HAPPENING ON JUNE SEVENTH ST
JOHN'S WELL CHILD AND FAMILY
CENTER WE DON'T HAVE TO JUST ON
THIS BILL YET BUT WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS THAT THE BILL IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN AND ARE
WORKING WITH THAT THE AUTHOR
AND STAFF OFFICERS AND
ADDRESSING THEIR CONCERNS AND
APPRECIATE THEIR OPENNESS TO
DEFECT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF TWO
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWO TWO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME OF THE PARTY
GOVERNMENT CALLING ON CALPERS
ACCOUNT YOUNG DEMOCRATS AND THE
FRESNO COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
CENTRAL COMMITTEE TO EXPRESS
OUR ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO MORE
FURTHER SUPPORT IN Q.
MESSENGER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
WE DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. OF FIRST ALEX
HAWTHORN. FOLLOWED BY VALERIE
LAKEY SO ALEX BE ON THE LINE
PLEASE PROCEED. INSURE THOUGHT
PROPER ACTUALLY FELT LIKE YOU
CAN GO FIRST IN AN AUTO. THE
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
VALERIE LAKEY THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY RELATIONS
AT MAYERS MEMORIAL HOSPITAL
DISTRICT WHERE VERY SMALL RURAL
CRITICAL ACCESS AND PUBLIC
DISTRICT HOSPITAL LOCATED IN
NORTHEASTERN SHASTA COUNTY WE
HAVE TWENTY TWO ACUTE CARE BEDS
AND NINETY NINE SKILLED NURSING
BEDS WE SERVE A GEOGRAPHIC AREA
OF OVER EIGHT THOUSAND SQUARE
MILES WITH THE NEXT NEAREST
HOSPITAL TO ACCESS OVER SEVENTY
FIVE MILES AWAY. THE SERVICES
IN JOB TO PROVIDE ARE VITAL TO
OUR VERY VERY SMALL COMMUNITY.
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB SIX
FIFTY- ARE NOT THAT WE DON'T
EXTREMELY CARE FOR OUR OUR
STAFFALL TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PLUS MEMBERS OF OUR- FACILITY
CLINICAL AND NON CLINICAL. ARE
VERY ESSENTIAL AND HAVE BEEN
SELFLESS HEROES DURING A REALLY
DIFFICULT YEAR. THAT'S WHY
MAYORS AND MANY OTHER HOSPITALS
AND PROVIDERS. HAVE GONE TO
GREAT LENGTHS AND EXPENSE TO
REWARD AND SUPPORT OUR WORKERS.
ON OUR OWN ACCORD WE HAVE
PROVIDED TWO ROUNDS OF HAZARD
PAY BONUSES TO ALL OF OUR
EMPLOYEES BASED ON THE HOURS
THAT THEY WORK. WE EXTENDED THE
CODE SICK PAY POLICY AFTER IT
LAPSED AT THE END OF. I'M
TWENTY TWENTY. WE TRIED TO DO
MORE THAN JUST MONETARY
ASSISTANCE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO US TO SHOW OUR
EMPLOYEES THAT THEY ARE VALUED
AND THEIR TOTAL WELL BEING IS A
PRIORITY. AND WITH THAT IN MIND
WE HIRED A DEDICATED EMPLOYEE
SERVING AS A WELLNESS
COORDINATOR. DURING THIS LAST
YEAR JUST FOR STAFF WITH THEIR
OVERALL WELLNESS IN MIND AND
SIMPLY TO JUST BE THERE FOR OUR
STAFF WITH EDUCATION
ENCOURAGEMENT AND SUPPORT
DURING THIS TOUGH TIME. WE
PROVIDED DAYCARE ASSISTANCE
MEALS AT NO COST FRESTON MAMA'S
PROGRAM. OUR SMALL HOSPITAL
DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF EXTRA
RESOURCES TO SPARE OTHER
CRITICAL ACCESS HOSPITAL WE ARE
COST BASED WE SERVE A LARGE
MEDICARE ALL MEDICARE
POPULATION OF OVER 80%
ADDITIONAL EXPENDITURES FOR US
WOULD ONLY MEAN REDUCE
SERVICES. THE ADDITIONAL COST
OF AB SIX FIFTY WOULD PUT A
HEAVY FINANCIAL STRAIN ON OUR
FACILITIES AND MANY OTHER SMALL
FACILITIES LIKE CARDS. IT WOULD
ALSO ELIMINATE OUR ABILITY TO
CONTINUE THE EFFORTS THAT WE
HAVE MADE TO MEET THE LONG TERM
NEEDS OF ALL OF OUR STAFF. NOT
JUST TO THOSE CARVED OUT FOR
THE EXTRA PAY IN THIS BILL. THE
ENORMOUS UNFUNDED UNFUNDED
COSTS IMPOSED BY SB SIX FIFTY
WOULD LIKELY LEAVE US WITH NO
OTHER OPTION THAN TO ELIMINATE
OR CUT SERVICES. IN OUR
pDISTRICT THAT MEANS CUTTING
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE TO
OPERATE AT A LOSS INCLUDING
HOSPICE CARE CARDIAC REHAB AND
OTHER OUTPATIENT ANCILLARY
SERVICES. THESE CUTS WOULD BE
DEVASTATING MANY OF OUR
PATIENTS CAN SIMPLY NOT TRAVEL
TO SEVENTY FIVE MILES OR MORE
TO RECEIVE THOSE SERVICES
ELSEWHERE. AT TEN IN THE
SERVICES WOULD ALSO HER STAFF
THE VERY WORKERS THAT THIS BILL
IS INTENDED TO PROTECT. AB SIX
FIFTY WOULD BE DEVASTATING FOR
OUR SMALL PUBLIC HOSPITAL AND
AT AND STUFF LIKE THAT. THERE'S
SO MUCH MORE TO OUR STORY AND I
WOULD LOVE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ANY TIME THAT YOU
HAVE THEM WE RESPECTFULLY URGE.
YOU TO VOTE NO ON AB SIX FIFTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- AND WE
ALSO HAVE WITH US ALEX HAWTHORN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
BEGIN. HE CHAIR MEMBERS OUT
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE ARE
CLOSED EIGHTY SIX FIFTY.
CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITALS ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES OF THE PANDEMIC
HELPING OUR STATE SURVIVED THE
LARGEST PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS IN
A CENTURY. TO TAKE CARE OF THE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE FLOODING OUR
HOSPITALS AND I TO USE. WE HAD
TO MAKE MONUMENTAL OPERATIONAL
CHANGES THAT HAVE CRIPPLED OUR
HOSPITALS FINANCES. OUR WORKERS
HAVE MADE EXTRAORDINARY
SACRIFICES THAT'S WHY
CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITALS
IMMEDIATELY PUT INTO PLACE
POLICIES TO SUPPORT AND ASSIST
THEM. THE EFFORTS TO REWARD AND
RETAIN WORKERS COMES ON TOP OF
COMPENSATION THAT ALREADY LEADS
THE NATION. FOR EXAMPLE
CALIFORNIA'S NURSES ARE THE
HIGHEST PAID IN THE COUNTRY 15%
MORE THAN NOT SECOND HIGHEST
BANK STATE. THIS COMPENSATION
IS NOT INCLUDE THE HIGH LEVEL
BENEFITS ANOTHER PAYMENT
OFFERED BY HOSPITALS SUCH AS
BONUSES AND PAY INCREASES.
CHILD CARE SERVICES SUBSIDIES
EXTENDED LEAVE WELLNESS AND
COUNSELING SUPPORT LIKE YOUR
TODAY- AND EVEN IN SOME CASES
TEMPORARY HOUSING.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR HOSPITALS ARE
FACED WITH STARK FINANCIAL
REALITY THAT COULD CRIPPLE THE
HEALTH CARE SAFETY NET.
HOSPITALS HAVE FIFTEEN TO
FOURTEEN POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN LOSSES DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND RECEIVED ONLY
EIGHT POINT SIX BILLION AND
FEDERAL RELIEF. BELIZE A SIX
BILLION DOLLAR LOSS SPREAD
ACROSS HOSPITALS AND STATE.
OVER HALF OF HOSPITALS ARE
CURRENTLY OPERATING AT A LOSS.
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY IMPOSES
BILLIONS MORE ADVANTAGE COSTS
FOR HOSPITALS ARE STRUGGLING IN
SOME CASES LITERALLY TO STING
OPERATION. THE END RESULT OF
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY IS DEVASTATING
LOSSES TO SERVICE SINCE. AS THE
STORY HEARD TODAY AT AND TO OUR
EMPLOYEES AND IT PUTS OUR
SAFETY NET IN JEOPARDY FOR THAT
REASON WE MUST OPPOSE EIGHTY
SIX FIFTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MILLER NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ANYONE IN THE ROOM. IN
OPPOSITION AB SIX FIFTY. WILL
MOVE ON TO THE PHONES ANYONE ON
THE PHONES IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
SIX FIFTY. IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SIX FIFTY MY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN THE EUROPEAN
OPPOSITION OF A BE EXPECTING.
AND WE WERE BOTH A LINE OF
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MERRITT MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
ONE OF TWO OH NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS TERRIFYING HOPPER
WITH SHARP HEALTHCARE IN SAN
DIEGO THERE OPPOSE A. B. SIX
FIFTY. THANK YOU FOR. YOU. AND
NEXT WE WILL GO THROUGH A LINE
OF THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COUNTY DELGADO
ON BEHALF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORMED IN OPPOSITION
TO EIGHTY SIX FIFTY. THANK YOU.
THANK IN CTOBER TO LINE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SURE MEMBERS
KILLING GIVENS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT A
LINE OF THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SUCH SHORT ON BEHALF
OF BEVERLY HOSPITAL AND
ADVENTIST HEALTH IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A
LINE OF THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN- ON BEHALF OF BANNER
LASSEN MEDICALCENTER WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SIX FIFTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A
LINE OF TWO THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
STATE ORGANS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. THANK CHIU
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR PARENTS ARE BEGINNING
SEVEN HOSPITALS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TED OWENS
WITH THE TAHOE FOREST HEALTH
DISTRICT SERVING NORTH LAKE
TAHOE AND TRUCKEE REGION
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY. THANK YOU. YOUR NEXT OF
A LOT OF TWO TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SURE MEMBERS RAND
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF ON THE ON
HEALTHCARE THE LARGEST PRIVATE
DUTY NURSING COMPANY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AS DESCRIBED IN
OUR LETTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF TWO
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AMBER ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. YOU'RE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND OVER ON BEHALF OF HEALTH IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ZERO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ACTUALLY HOPPING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY SIX SIXTY
AS A JOB KILLER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOT FOR
THE LINE OF FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ADRIN MOHAMMED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. LINE TO TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS CATEGORY ON BEHALF
KINDRED HEALTHCARE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF ONE
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MYERS
SCHNEIDER MARSHALL MEDICAL
CENTER WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE UP TO FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI SEAN FLANAGAN
REPRESENTING REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER GOOD SAMARITAN LOS
ROBLES WEST HILLS AND RIVERSIDE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE STATE
EXCEPT THE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS YOUR WITH ALWAYS
TELL NURSING SERVICE THEN AND
WHILE WE DO BELIEVE IN THE
ATTEMPT AND MERIT FOR THIS BILL
WE OPPOSE THEM BUT LIKE THE
AUTHORS TO CONSIDER PROVIDER
TYPES SUCH AS OURS THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN WITH
COMPLEX MEDICAL NEEDS AND LIVE
WITH A HOSPITAL. BILL STILL
PATIENT AND- AFTER PROVIDE
THERE FUNDED PRIMARILY THROUGH
BENNETT CAL A SERVICES. THANK
YOU. ONE NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON DONNA
DO FOR ON ON BEHALF OF THE
TORRANCE AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE RESPECTIVELY
OPPOSED AB SIX FIFTY. THANK YOU.
THANK TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS MATT ROBINSON ON BEHALF
OF KAISER PERMANENT DAY IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT I HAD ON A DARK ON BEHALF
OF CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP FOR HEALTH IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY SIX FIVE
ZERO. THANK YOU. THANK TO
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AARON TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF
MEMORIALCARE HEALTH SYSTEM AND
READ CARE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ONE
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMY BLOOMBERG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH FACILITIES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NINE TWO
ZERO TWO TWO TWENTY TWO THE
LINE IS OPEN. BURGEONING DOWN
ON BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN
COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE DISTRICT
THE SMALLER HOSPITAL TRINITY
COUNTY IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
TURN MEMBERS BOB ACTED ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RADIOLOGICAL SOCIETY
CALIFORNIA'S IDEA COLLEGES AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
MEDICAL PARTS SUPPLIERS AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. BY NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MEGAN WEBER ON BEHALF OF
THE UNITED HEALTHCARE
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. WINDS TO FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ONLY BANTAM ON BEHALF
OF CEDAR SINAI AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
EXPECTING. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO DO YOU HAVE A TIME
YOU. AND WE WILL GO TO TWO
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS YOUR TRACK OF VICE
CHAIR OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ACTUALLY
CALLING IN SUPPORT APOLOGIES
ABOUT THE TIMING OF THAT
COMMENT THANK YOU THE PROBLEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND ONE
MOMENT- WOULD GO TO ONE AT
NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BY PAUL. I'M SORRY BROKE UP
BEFORE HEAD. I'M SORRY I'M NOT
ABLE. TO HEAR YOU ONE NINETY
FOUR. HELLO YES BUT BY HEAD. GO
AHEAD SIR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
HELLO. OKAY- WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BY TWO FORTY FIVE PM GO
AHEAD PLEASE. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES YES. ABU HI THANK I
REMEMBER THAT MY NAME IS BRETT
OKAY ON THE- FORMER BOYLE
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS BECAME
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I WILL TRY ONE
NINETY FOUR. HI MY NAME IS
JAMES WEBER LOCAL. THREE
SEVENTY PER I. D. P. AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF. HELLO SIX FIFTY AS
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY- SO
LOOKS ARE BEYOND. PUBLIC
COMMENT AND WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. YES SOME
REWARD. THANK YOU- SUMMER CITY
FOR BRINGING THIS. FORWARD I
THINK I'M WE'D BE OVERSEEING OB
ABOUT HOW MUCH DO TO BE ABLE TO
SOME OUR HEALTH CARE WERE FOR
WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN LIFE THAT
THEY'VE- AND- EXPIRY THEY HAVE.
ALSO READ TO THAT YOU IT TAKES
A VILLAGE TO ASSIST YOU KNOW
OUR HOUSE AS WELL- HAVE BEEN IN
IN STRESSED TRYING TO MEET THE
MOMENT AND DO SO WITH THE
DIGNITY IN CARE- AND TO BE ABLE
TO GET THIS RIGHT I THINK IS
THE RIGHT DIRECTION- TO BE
GOING AND I JUST HAD- WHAT WHAT
I HOPE FOR OUR OUR OUR MORE
JUST TECHNICAL QUESTIONS- BUT
YOU KNOW RECOGNIZING I THINK
THE BROAD- INTENT OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE AND THAT IS
MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE
USING THIS OPPORTUNITY AS-
PROFITS HAVE BEEN ASSUMED AND
THERE IS- YOU KNOW MORE THERE
TO REALLY MAKE SURE. ENDS UP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION FOR THOSE
THAT DON'T HAVE BEEN- HAVING
HAVING THE BRUNT OF THE
EXPERIENCES HERE- I GUESS THE
FIRST QUESTION IS- ARE THESE.
THE KINDS OF DECISIONS ARE HOW
WE EVEN. ASKED TO HAVE. MEET
AND CONFER CONVERSATIONS IF
IT'S A RETENTION ISSUE AND
THERE IS A- A THREAT OR A REAL
REALITY THAT. WE MIGHT BE-
REALLY LOSING SO MUCH OF OUR
WORK FORCE THAT- THE HOSPITAL'S
ORDER SYSTEMS THAT MIGHT
COLLAPSE- I FEEL LIKE THAT THAT
THAT'S- ALSO A PLACE THAT MAYBE
THESE CONVERSATIONS. SHOULD BE
TAKING PLACE- ARE. IS NOT GOING
ON COULD THAT BE GOING ON.
THANK YOU MISTER WARD I- I KNOW
THAT- WELL ALL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS INCLUDING OUR
INSTITUTIONS YOU KNOW OUR
CONCERN TO ME BUT WE DECIDED
THE KAISER POLL- THAT THAT
CLEARLY PROVIDES EVIDENCE THAT
THE THAT THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN. OF WHETHER OR NOT TO
HEALTH CARE WORKERS MAY BE
LEAVING THE PROFESSION- SO I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE ON GOING
CONVERSATIONS- BUT IT BUT I
THINK FOR SOME LIKE THAT WHERE
THEY CAN GET ALL THOSE PARTIES
TO REALLY DIVE INTO IT KIND OF
GETS TO MY NEXT SORT OF LAYERS
OF QUESTIONS WHICH IS YOU KNOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT- MAYBE- JUST
KIND OF BROAD BRUSHING CERTAIN
DOLLAR AMOUNTS- WHITE
CATEGORIES OF WHAT WE CONSIDER
A HEALTH CARE WORKER. ON AND AT
WITH NO DISRESPECT MENTORED
MANY PROFESSIONS AND GOOD JOBS
ON TO THINK ABOUT OUR NURSES
AND RESPIRATORY THERAPISTS IN
OUR IN OUR PHYSICIANS WHO HAVE
LITERALLY BEEN OUT OF THE FRONT
DEALING WITH THIS AND- AND
RIGHT IN FRONT OF THEM- FOR
TWELVE HOURS A DAY GOING
THROUGH- THE SUFFERING THAT YOU
KNOW LIKE I I'D I DON'T KNOW-
BUT THAT. FOR ME THAT KIND OF
LIVED EXPERIENCE- AND WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO FOR
COMPENSATION- FOR RETENTION
PURPOSES TIME AND FOR-
RETRACTED HAZARD PAY- FEELS
AGAIN FOR TYING THE TWO
TOGETHER AS A NEXUS HERE- MORE
WORTHY OF SAY SOMEBODY WHO IS A
NON MANAGERIAL ADMINISTRATIVE
STAFFFOR A PHARMACIST WORKING
SORT OF YOU KNOW IN THE BACK
OFFICE- AND YOU KNOW IF THIS
BILL IT IF IT HAS THIS BILL
PROGRESSES I HOPE THAT MAYBE
YOU'LL THINK ABOUT- WAYS TO.
SORT OF A LINE AND FINE TUNE
SOME OF THE- SPECIFIC ELEMENTS
OF THIS- THAT SORT OF ALSO
REFLECT ON THAT THAT THAT THAT
TOO BECAUSE AGAIN A IT YOU'RE
TYING YOUR YOUR INTENT FOR THIS
BILL- AND THE SOLUTION IS THAT
IS A BIT BROAD PRESSED ON AND
THEN FURTHER MORE IF THIS IS
ABOUT YOU KNOW BENEFITING. OUR
EMPLOYEES- WHY ARE ONLY AT-
PRIVATE SECTOR. HEALTH CARE
EMPLOYEES WHY ARE WE LOOKING AT
ALL HEALTH CARE WORKERS. WELL
AS YOUR FIRST POINT- YOU KNOW.
I THINK THE INTENT OF IT OF THE
BILL IS TO- IS TO RECOGNIZE AND
RETAIN NOT ONLY THE THAT THE
DOCTORS AND THE NURSES- THE
DATA- WORD TREATING THE
PATIENTS DIRECTLY BUT ALSO. YOU
KNOW THE SECURITY PERSONNEL
THE- THE CUSTODIANS OF MAINE-
EVERYONE WHO HAD TO. AGAIN GO
AND YOU KNOW DAY IN AND DAY
OUT- TO THE FRONT LINES OF A
ARE ARE- WHEN WE'RE ASKED
PEOPLE TO VERY RISKY
ENVIRONMENT YEAH WHAT WITH
WITHOUT A DOUBT- BUT- I AM JUST
I YOU KNOW I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS TODAY. I HOPE THAT- YOU'LL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH I THINK A
LOT OF THE WHITE STAKEHOLDERS
THAT ARE HERE TO MAYBE SORT OF
FINE TUNING IS BECAUSE AGAIN IF
THIS WERE A MEET AND CONFER
LATER CONVERSATION THAT'S WHERE
YOU'D BE SPENDING HOURS REALLY
YOU KNOW HAMMERING ALL THIS
OUT- YOU KNOW BY THE A
LEGISLATION. I THINK IT
DESERVES YOU KNOW SOME SOME
POINTS DID THE SAME POINTS NEED
TO BE HAMMERED OUT AS WELL TO
SIR THAT IS WHERE I'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO SEE THAT GO IN AND
INTO THAT LIMITING. IT TO
PRIVATE SECTOR ONLY USER. A
RATIONALE. BUT THE MAIN INTENT
OF IT WITH THAT TOO WAS- TO
RECOGNIZE THAT- THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN- AND THE CARES. ACT
HAS PROVIDED BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDING- TO-
THE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS- IS-
MISLED SHE INDICATED- IN A ONE
OF THE JUSTIFICATIONS FOR THE
FEDERAL. AID WAS TO PROVIDE
HAZARD PAY AND YET- WE'RE WE'RE
HEARING. YOU KNOW MANY PARTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT- THOSE- THOSE
MONIES. HAVE NOT REACHED THE
WORKERS- AND SO THAT THAT IS
AGAIN THE INTENT OF THE BILL.
ON THE BUT BUT MONIES ARE ALSO
HEADING TOWARD- PUBLIC
HOSPITALS OR TREAT NOT THE
PROFIT HOSPITALS. WRECKED THAT
IS- THAT IS CORRECT SO- I AGAIN
IF IN AS THIS MOVES FORWARD I'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE AGAIN
THAT- I DON'T WANT TO
DISTINGUISHING OF DIFFERENT
HEALTH CARE WORKERS BECAUSE OF
WHO THEIR EMPLOYER IS- IF
THAT'S THE INTENT OF THIS
LEGISLATION I'D LIKE TO MAKE
SURE ALL OF OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKERS. ARE TREATED EQUALLY AS
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT THE IF I MAY
IF I CAN REFER TO MISTER LEJI
HE MAY BE OF ANSWER YEAH THERE
MIGHT BE A REASON- I'M NOT
THINKING I JUST AGAIN IF THIS
IS ABOUT BENEFITS TO THE
WORKERS I WANNA MAKE SURE
WE'RE- RECOVERING AS MANY
WORKERS AS POSSIBLE. MISTER
CHAIR. YES OF COURSE. YES AND
THAT WAS A WITH THAT VALUE I'M
SORRY THE QUESTION- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BY A NUMBER OF-
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING HAS GONE
DIRECTLY TO COUNTIES CITIES FOR
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AS WELL- AND
SO- AND THAT ONE OF THE
INTENDED USES CAN'T BE FOR
AFTERPAY AND SO- YEAH YOU
REPRESENTS WORKERS AT BOTH-
LOCATIONS AND- I WE WISH WE
SHARE IN YOUR CONCERN TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL HEALTHCARE
WORKERS ARE RECOGNIZED FOR WHAT
THEIR SERVICE DURING. THE
PANDEMIC AND SO YOU KNOW ARE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
WITH YOU ON THAT- AND TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
RECOGNIZING ALL HEALTHCARE
WORKERS WHICH IS REALLY FAST AT
EIGHT TEN OF OUR EFFORTS THIS
YEAR. OKAY THANK YOU YEAH AND
AGAIN- JUST THINGS I'D YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY THAT THERE'S NOT SOME-IS STEPS AHEAD- AS THESE THINGS
GO AND THINGS THAT MAYBE CAN BE
EXPLORED AS YOUR- EACH ONE OF
THE STEPS AT THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR- YOU KNOW CRYPTOLOGY THEM-
THROUGH THIS BILL APPROVED FOR
THE WORKER DOING I'LL BE HAPPY
TO SUPPORT HERE TODAY- AND-
HOPEFULLY AND AGAIN I'M
DEPENDING ON. THE AGE THE LAST
POINT AS WELL TO ITS FIRST
WE'RE LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
OTHER- TYPES OF EMPLOYERS HERE-
AGAIN THINKING IN MIND ABOUT-
THE IMPACT IN THE EXPERIENCE
THAT THEY'VE HAD- THE HAZARDS
THAT THEY'VE EXPERIENCED- UNDER
UNDER THESE COVETED AT TIMES-
YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY WHETHER IT'S
AT- YOU KNOW IN HOME. HEALTH
CARE- AGAIN THIRD THIRD
DISTINCTIONS THAT- YOU KNOW ARE
REASONABLY I THINK YOU KNOW-
SHOULD BE- ALIGNED WITH. HOW WE
ARE APPLY THIS- A AND I JUST
THAT IT WOULD BE IT WOULD
WOULD- WE WOULD DO WELL TO A
PRE. THAT AND TRY TO TRY TO
WORK ON SOME OF THESE FINDINGS.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT I.
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS WILL DEFINITELY FOLLOW
UP ON THEM THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU A SUMMER GONZALEZ. I
WANNA NOT TO. BEAT A DEAD HORSE
IS THAT THE RIGHT THING- I
THINK. IF SOMEBODY WHO HAS-
WORKED EXTENSIVELY LIKE WITH
THE HEALTHCARE WORKERS THAT ARE
YOU SEE AND ASK ME THIRTY TWO
NINE NINE IN PARTICULAR I WAS
PERPLEXED- BY THEM NOT BEING
INCLUDED IN THIS I AND I DIDN'T
HAVE A CHANCE I DIDN'T THINK
ABOUT UNTIL LAST NIGHT WHEN I
READ IT AND THEN. THIS MORNING.
DARTED IT DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE
TO ASK THEM BUT- IT DOES SEEM.
THAT WE SHOULD BE PROVIDING THE
SAME TYPE OF INCENTIVE HEY TO
THE EMPLOYEES OF PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES AND PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AS- REQUIRED. PRIVATE
HOSPITALS TO PROVIDE IS THAT.
S. AS YOU HEARD TO YEAH MR
LEGGIO GOD WILL DEFINITELY THE
INTENT IS TO- RECOGNIZE AND TO
RETAIN ALL HEALTHCARE WORKERS
WHETHER PRIVAE OR PUBLIC AND
SO ONLY LABOR COMMITTEE GET
ASKED TO EXPAND YOUR- BILLS
MORE WORKERS- AND THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAD AND IT'S A BIT
OF A CONCERN I HATE MY DISTRICT
IS SERVED PRIMARILY BY A
COMMUNITY CLINICS. AND
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY CLINICS WHO
DO WE IS THERE A THRESHOLD OR
ANTICIPATION THAT WE WILL KNOW
THAT THEY CAN USE FEDERAL MONEY
FOR THIS PURPOSE IS FOR THESE
PURPOSES- THAT THEY HAVE IT-
THERE THERE IS JUST A- IT IN A-
ABILITY ON ON SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS IS THAT. DID I MISS
KIND OF THAT LEVEL OF SCRUTINY
EIGHT CAN THE STATE FUNDS SOME
OF THIS YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT ARE
WE LOOKING OUT FOR ME CLINICS
THAT WE'RE ALWAYS TRYING TO GET
MORE MONEY TO SURE YEAH OUT OF
I RAISED MANY THAT THE SAME
CONCERNS I MEAN. AND I THINK-
FROM THE OPPOSITION YOU ARE
HEARD A YOU KNOW A COMMON THEME
THAT THAT WHILE WE ALL WANT TO
RECOGNIZE OUR FRONTLINE HEALTH
CARE WORKERS WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T IMPACT
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
ESPECIALLY IN OUR- OUR OUR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES- I HAVE
COMMUTER HEALTH CLINICS ALSO
LINDA BY AND I HAD SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH
REPRESENTATIVES OF COMMUNITY
HEALTH CLINICS. OF AS WE ALL
KNOW MANY REPRESENTING NO
PRIMARILY MEDIC CAL PATIENTS-
FOR WHICH YOU KNOW THEY THEY
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER
THIS WOULD IMPACT THEIR THEIR
ABILITY TO REACH THAT THE
GREATEST NUMBER FOR THE
GREATEST GOOD- AND SO- WELL WE
ARE- CONTINUED THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. THANK. THE
MOTION FOR A SECOND. THE SECOND
FROM SOME REWARD YES THE SUMMER
STARTED. ALL RIGHT HEY HAVE A
FEW CONCERNS- FIRST THE PUBLIC
VERSUS PRIVATE THEY'VE COVERED
THAT PRETTY MUCH AND I THINK
THE ANSWER- WAS ANSWERED BY ONE
OF THE FIRST CALLERS WHO HAD A
PUBLIC HOSPITAL AND PROBABLY
THOUGHT THAT THIS MIGHT APPLY
TO THEM AND- IT WOULD CAUSE
THEM TO PROBABLY GO WONDER IF
THEY WERE TO HAVE TO PAY OUT-
THESE. I GUESS THERE ARE
RETENTION BONUS. SECONDLY. WHEN
WE REFER TO IT AS A RETENTION
BONUS. BECAUSE OF THE STRESS
THAT CENTER AND THE PEOPLE AT
THE BREAKING POINT AT CENTRAL.
IF YOUR DOCTOR MAKING THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
OR MORE- FIFTEEN HUNDRED BUCKS
ISN'T GOING TO MAKE YOU STAY IF
YOU'RE BURNED OUT. BURNOUT IS
BURN OUT. AND I CAN TELL YOU IN
IN THE FIRE SERVICE OR OTHER
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES- IF
SOMEBODY IS THAT BURNED OUT
IT'S CALLED STRESS DISABILITY
RETIREMENT. BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
FUNCTION ANYMORE- SO I DON'T
KNOW HOW THIS PAINT THIS
PAYMENT. CAN BE CALLED REALLY
RETENTION. TYPE OF PAYMENT
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
RETAINED BECAUSE THEY GOT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED BUCKS OR TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED BUCKS. WHAT IT IS
AN APPRECIATION PAYMENT. AND I
DON'T DISAGREE WITH THE
APPRECIATION PAYMENT APPROACH.
BUT WHAT I DISAGREE WITH IS IF
I APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARDS- DEDICATION TO HIS JOB
HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY. I AND I
WANT TO I WANT HIM TO HAVE A
THOUSAND DOLLARS I'M NOT GONNA
TELL YOU TO GIVEN THE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND THEN SHAKE HIS HAND
SAY HEY YOU'RE WELCOME. NOW IF
WE WANT TO TRULY. RECOGNIZE THE
JOB THAT THESE PEOPLE DID. THEN
WE NEED TO ADD UP WHAT THE COST
IS. TAKE SOME OF THAT MONEY
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
SENT US THE STATE. AND AND SEND
OUT THOSE CHECKS JUST LIKE THEY
SEND OUT THE CHECKS FOR- YOU
KNOW THE STIMULUS PAYMENTS-
THAT WOULD COVER ALL OF THE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS. WE WOULD
KNOW WHAT THE COST IS GOING
FORWARD BECAUSE THAT WAS ONE OF
MY OTHER QUESTIONS DO YOU KNOW
WHAT THE POTENTIAL COST IS FOR
THIS FOR PRIVATE INDUSTRY. I
KNOW I'VE SEEN NOW. ESTIMATES
BUT I DON'T HAVE IT OFF HAND
OKAY THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT
WE DON'T WE DON'T NEED TO GET
THE EXACT FIGURES BUT IT'S A
LOT- IF WE CAN ABSORB THAT COST
IS AN ASSEMBLY. AS THE SENATE
IS THE LEGISLATURE THEN WE
SHOULD SAY HEY YOU KNOW WHAT WE
CAN DO THIS WE'RE GOING TO
REWARD THOSE VOTES FOR THE ALL
THE GREAT. GREAT WORK THEY DID.
AND BY THE WAY THEIR WORK
EXTENDS BEYOND CODE. THEIR WORK
IT STANDS IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN
IN A BEES BUSY ER- THERE'S
HEROIC ACTIONS GOING IN ALL THE
TIME- THE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS. I REALIZE THAT THEY
GOT SOME SAID THEY GOT MONEY.
TO HELP RECOVER. AND KEEP THEM
ALIVE. BECAUSE DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND THIS IS SOMETHING
I LEARNED BY TALKING TO THE
CEOS OF THE HOSPITALS. BECAUSE
I THOUGHT WELL YOU GUYS WERE
PROBABLY THE ONLY ONES DOING
OKAY YOU'RE IN BUSINESS. THEY
SAID ACTUALLY NO IN FACT WE'VE
LAID OFF HALF OUR STAFF.
BECAUSE THE REST OF THE
HOSPITAL OUTSIDE OF THE ER WAS
NOT FUNCTIONING. SO THEY DID
LOSE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
MONEY. SO YOU KNOW THOSE ARE
THE KIND OF THINGS THAT YOU
KNOW I. THESE BILLS ARE HARD
BECAUSE YOU'RE IN ON ONE HAND
WE'RE TRYING TO REWARD PEOPLE
FOR DOING THIS AWESOME JOB. AND
RECOGNIZE THEM FOR THAT AND WE
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO RECOGNIZE
THESE THESE VALIANT WORKERS-
THROUGHOUT THIS THING. BUT I
THINK IT'S THE WRONG APPROACH I
THINK THE APPROACH WE NEED TO
TAKE IT FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
COST IS. MAKE SURE THAT ALL
THOSE FOLKS AND IF WE'RE GONNA
GIVE THEM A REWARD THEN WE
GIVEN THE REWARD. AND NOT PUT
THIS ON AND SURPASSING USE THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO THE DO THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS.
THAT THAT IF THEY'RE GOING TO
GET IT FROM THE EMPLOYER SHOULD
BE DONE. THEY SHOULDN'T BE-
GRANT AND THERE SHOULD BE IN
AND AROUND THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS. AND I WOULD SAY THAT
NO MORE ANYMORE THAN IF WE WERE
TO TAKE FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
FROM EACH EMPLOYEE FOR. FOR IT
WAS A PRETTY SLOW YEAR. THEY.
TO MAKE SURE IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
AND SO THIS WOULD BE THE SAME I
THINK THIS IS THE SAME WAY I
THINK WE'RE INTERFERING WHERE
WE CANNOT. LOVE THE IDEA. BUT I
THINK THERE'S A DIFFERENT WAY
OF DOING IT AND I THINK THAT
THAT SHOULD BE EXPLORED BECAUSE
THAT WOULD INCLUDE THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES. AND IT WOULD GIVE US
THE IDEA HOW MUCH IT WOULD COST
AND WHETHER WE CAN AFFORD IT.
IS THAT THAT BECOMES A BUTTON
AND TURNING FACTOR IN A LOT OF
THESE. THANK YOU FOR THE IDEA I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU. AND
IF I MAKE A BRIEFLY ON THE
CHAIR US IN MISSISSIPPI ARE TO
AYE. I'VE HAD MANY SIMILAR
CONVERSATIONS TO. GET AWAY WITH
MY- CEOS OF HOSPITALS- IN IN IN
MY DISTRICT AND- YEAH AND IN
FACT I ASKED TO- THE ECONOMIST
SAID THAT THE RESEARCH
RESEARCHERS AT S. YEAH YOU FOR
DATA ON- THE HOSPITAL'S I.
THINK SO WE ARE YOU KNOW TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
ROOTED IN REALITY THAT THEY
WERE TRYING TO- YOU KNOW
ACHIEVE THOSE DUAL GOALS OF
RECOGNIZING A RETAINING ARE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME NOT IMPACTING ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE- I THINK THAT'S
THE BOTTOM LINE- AND SO- I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME YOUR
COMMENTS- AND- WELL WE WILL
CONTINUE TO FINE TUNE THE BILL.
I HAVE A GREAT EDUCATION THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ONE
OF THE COMMENTS- WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FOR SUMMARY GONZALEZ
SECOND BY SOME MEMBER WARD- IN
AND AS THE AUTHOR MURATSUCHI AN
INDICATOR EARLIER I DIDN'T.
SIGN ON TO THIS BILL AS WELL I
THINK THAT- EVEN HEARING FROM
OPPOSITION EVERYONE IN
PRINCIPLE AGREES THAT THESE
HEROES NEED TO BE. WE NEED TO
BE SHOT SHOW OF. APPRECIATION
AND I THINK GOING FROM. A
PRINCIPLED POLICY IS ALWAYS THE
CHALLENGE AND SO. I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS- AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION. WE JUST HAD SO.
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT I'M
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ON A.
B. SIX FIFTY. MOTION IS DUE TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA
FIVE KALRA AYE FLORA. FLORA NOW
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE DON'T.
SEE I DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW
FOUR. WORDS I WRITE THOSE OUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
SEVERAL READERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE YOU HAVE TO ITEMS
A. B. SEVEN A. B. ELEVEN OH
FIVE. IT'S- MOVE FORWARD THEM
WE DO HAVE A SCHEDULED RECESS
ONE THIRTY TO TWO AND A TIME
CERTAIN BILL AT TWO PM. LET'S
SEE WHAT WE CAN DO ON YOUR
BILLS RIGHT NOW- HAND SO THAT'S
LEAST- START WITH THE FIRST ONE
A. B. SEVEN. AND YOU MAY BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MISTER MEMBERS. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENTED.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY. LAST
YEAR THIS COMMITTEE PASSED AB
TWENTY NINETY TO A SIMILAR
BUILT TO THE ONE BEFORE. S. TO
THE ONE BEFORE YOU TODAY.
HOWEVER WHEN THE BILL REACHED
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK IN THE FORM
OF A SUBSIDIZED PROGRAM FOR.
BODY PROTECTIVE GEAR IT WAS
ULTIMATELY VETOED. AB SEVEN IS
THE REINTRODUCTION OF THE SAME
ADDRESS AND ADDRESS OF THE
CONCERN POSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. THOSE CONCERNS
LACKED A LACK OF PROVISIONS
REGULATING THE USE OF GEAR AND
THAT EMPLOYEE SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO PAY FOR THE SECURE IN THE
FIRST PLACE. AND WAS WITH MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WORKING IN
THE M. S. I. AGREE. EMPLOYEE
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO PAY FOR THIS
YEAR BUT THAT'S WORSE THE
THOUGHT THIS UP THERE THEY
AREN'T EVEN PROVIDED THE SCARE
IN THE FIRST PLACE. THERE WAS
ANOTHER MASS SHOOTING THIS PAST
WEEK AND OUR PRESIDENT SAY
THERE'S A GUN EPIDEMIC. AND YET
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS DON'T HAVE
ADEQUATE YOUR PROTECT HIMSELF
ONCE BOND TO THESE EMERGENCIES.
YOU MAY ASK WHY DOES THIS BILL
ONLY APPLY TO THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. THAT'S BECAUSE IN
CALIFORNIA OVER EIGHTY PERCENT.
OF THE PRIVATE SECTOR MS
EMPLOYEES. ARE EMPLOYED IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. OVER SEVENTY
SIX OF THE SENATE PLOYS. RUN
76% OF THE NINE ONE CALLS IN
THE STATE YOU MAY HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT THIS GET YOUR
IS NOT NECESSARY WHILE THEY
BEGIN TO NATIONAL ROLL OUT
THEIR OWN SUBSIDIZED PROGRAM
FOR THE VERY SAME HERE THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE. EVERY NINE
ONE ONE CALL THAT EMS RESPONSE
TO HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BECOME
A DANGEROUS SITUATION
OFTENTIMES THERE ARE SO TO BY
THE PEOPLE THEY ARE TRYING TO
HELP. THE OCCUPATION OF AN EMT
CAN BE DANGEROUS WITH THE HIGH
RATES OF MORTALITY INJURY AND
MENTAL AND PHYSICAL TRAUMA THIS
IS ACCORDING TO A UCLA LABOR
REPORT ON WORKING CONDITIONS IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR EMS. MEMBERS
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION OF THIS%
ADMINISTRATION ON ACHIEVING THE
MAIN GOAL OF THIS BILL. THAT IS
MAKE SURE THOSE WOULD COME TO
OUR AID ARE WELL PROTECTED TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TODAY THE
SHELLEY HUDSON WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
EMTS AND PARAMEDICS WHO SHOULD
BE ON THE LINE THANK YOU SO
MUCH- SHELLEY HUDDLES IN UP TO
TWO MINUTES PLEASE. THANK YOU
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN EVERYBODY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN CARLA
AND MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
SHELLY HOW OPEN AND I'M A
NATIONAL LABOR REPRESENTATIVE
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION. OF EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS. I AM ALSO A
LICENSED PARAMEDIC MYSELF. I AM
SPEAKING HERE TODAY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT IN PASSING A D. SEVEN.
AND TO SHARE WHY I WITH MY
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE AS A
PARAMEDIC. BELIEVE THE MULTI
THREATEN HERE THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE IS NECESSARY FOR OUR
WORKFORCE. WHEN I WAS A YOUNG
IS HE I WAS ON THE SCENE OF A
LATE NIGHT CALL. I WAS STANDING
WITH SEVERAL POLICE OFFICERS
AND FIREFIGHTERS IN FRONT OF A
RESIDENTIAL HOME. ALL OF A
SUDDEN WE NOTICED A RED BLAZER
WITH SWEEPING ACROSS OUR CHAT.
I WAS TOLD TO GET DOWN STAY
DOWN BY THE OFFICERS WELL THEY
PULLED THEIR GUNS TO PROTECT
THE- FIND THE THREAT. IT WAS AT
THAT MOMENT I REALIZED THAT I
WAS THE TARGET. AND I HAD NO
PROTECTION. I WILL NEVER FORGET
THAT DAY. I GOT OFF WOK THE
NEXT MORNING AND WENT DIRECTLY
TO THE UNIFORMS STORE. AND
BOUGHT A BULLET PROOF VEST. I
COULDN'T AFFORD IT BUT MY LIFE
IS MORE IMPORTANT. THESE TYPES
OF SITUATIONS WILL HAPPEN AND
STILL OUR EMS WORKERS HAVE NO
PROTECTION. IT MAY NOT BE AN
EVERYDAY SITUATION BUT IT CAN
HAPPEN AT ANY TIME. HOW LONG
ARE WE GOING TO KEEP PLAYING
RUSSIAN ROULETTE WITH OUR LINE.
SOME COMPANIES MAY HAVE A FEW
WOULD BE THE BEST AND THEIR
SUPERVISOR VEHICLES HOW LONG
WILL IT TAKE FOR THEM TO GET ON
SCENE WHERE THEY ARE NEEDED.
WILL IT BE TO WAIT. TILL THEY
HAVE ENOUGH. MOST COMPANIES
DON'T HAVE ANY. AS MASS
SHOOTINGS HAVE INCREASED OVER
THE YEARS AND MONTHS. NOW IS
THE TIME DON'T WAIT ANY LONGER
GIVE OUR EMS WORKERS SOME SENSE
OF PROTECTION. LET THEM KNOW
YOU HEAR THEM AND UNDERSTAND
NAY NEED WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MAN RODRIGUEZ FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. AND CONTINUING TO
FIGHT FOR EMERGENCY AMBULANCE
FIRST RESPONDERS. YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I WILL CONCLUDE
MY COMMENTS BY URGING THE
COMMITTEE THE PAST EIGHTY
SEVEN. I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- IF WE CAN
MOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
ANYWHERE IN THE ROOM. IS AB
SEVEN. IF NOT WE'LL MOVE ON. TO
THE PHONE- A. B. SEVEN ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN ON THE
PHONE LINE. YOUR PARENTS PART
OF AB SEVENTY MY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO
FARE IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF THE
TWO FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS JACK AND DEL
BITES PRESIDENT FOR I. A. P.
LOCAL THREE SEVENTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS JAMES WEBB WITH LOCAL
WHAT I EIGHTY P. LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS AB SEVEN AS WELL. THANK
YOU FOR. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
ONE MORNING ONE MORNING Q. ONE
MOMENT. ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DON'T
THINK HE WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS TO SPEAKING IN
OVERWHELMING SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH WILL MOVE ON OPPOSITION
SHAUNA HENSCHEL- IF YOU'RE
READY TO GO YOU HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES AND YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SOMETIMES
APPEAR ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN MEDICAL RESPONSE
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST. PROVIDER
OF NINE ONE ONE EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE SERVICES. RADICALLY
AIMAR MUST OPPOSE THE
LEGISLATION FOR SEVERAL REASONS
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE IN
OPPOSITION LETTER. WELL MY
CLIENT HAS A GREAT RESPECT FOR
THE AUTHORS YEARS OF SERVICE IN
THE INDUSTRY THEY ARE CONCERNED
THAT EVEN WELL INTENTIONED
POLICY WILL HAVE SIGNIFICANT
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON OUR ABILITY
TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY SERVICES.
ON ITS FACE THIS WOULD BE AN
EASY BILL THE SUPPORT HOWEVER
THE DATA TEMPLATE DOES NOT SHOW
THE NEED FOR BALLISTIC BODY
ARMOR. IT CAN BE ATTRIBUTED TO
FIFTEEN TWENTY PRACTICES
DEFYING THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
NOT. ENTERING HOT- I WOULD CALL
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO LOOK
AT THOSE DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY
THIS BILL IT SHOULD BE
NOTICEABLE THAT WELL A MARKET
IS A PRIVATE PROVIDER. ALMOST
FORTY LARGELY UNIONIZED AND
REPRESENTED BY ASKED ME WHO IS
NOT TAKING A SUPPORT POSITION.
IT'S UNCLEAR WHY THIS
LEGISLATION HAS BEEN LIMITED TO
ONLY PRIVATE PROVIDERS AND
NOTHING BY TAKING REQUIREMENTS
FOR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES DOES NOT
EQUAL THE IMPORTANT. AND IS
INSTEAD CARVED OUT OF THE BILL.
SEVERAL LAWS FOR INDUSTRY OF
FIRST RESPONDERS THAT PROVIDE
THE SAME SERVICES CRAZY
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT.
ADDITIONALLY EIGHTY SEVEN
ISRAEL BETTER WAY THAN WITH
ALSO APPLIED TO DISPATCHERS NOT
OUT IN THE FIELD OR ATHLETIC
UNITS CAUSING UNNECESSARY
DANGEROUS WHITE WEIGHT
INCREASES. STEADILY COMMITTEE
THE MELTED ON THE BILL IT
CORRECTLY NOTES THAT MOVING
FORWARD BE AUTOMATED WAIT MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER INCLUDING
PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEES SO IT'S
NOT. CREATE THE DIFFERENT
STANDARD. IF THE REST OF
VIOLENCE IS TO IT IS HERE NEW.
OTHER INDUSTRY PARKS. AND YOU
CAN. WERE RIGHT TRYING TO BE
COURT OF LAW ENFORCING. FINALLY
IF IS QUITE THAT. THIS IS
INCREMENTAL ACROSS A PART OF.
IT WOULD ONLY MAKE SENSE IF I
MUCH OF A- WHEN APPLIED EQUALLY
ACROSS ALL PROVIDER. INSTEAD OF.
THAT'S NOT WHAT PROPOSED HERE
INVALID AGAIN FOR IS NOT
SOMETHING. WANTS TO SEE. A
MARBLE BELIEVES THAT STATE OF
THE TEMPLE IS. HOWEVER ANY LAW
SHE BE INTO ADDRESSING WORD OF
A- AND NOT SET UP DIFFERENT.
FOR THE PAYMENT OF. I DO TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE SPOKE TO
THE DOUBLE STANDARD ISSUE ON
THE- AND THEN WE- TO THE OFFICE
BECAUSE- JUST NOW MARK DOES.
PROBABLY TO WHY THE THAT FALLEN
TO BE A- INSERTED. AND UTILIZED
BEST WE SIMPLY OPENED UP THE
PURGE TO FIELD. TODAY ONLY
SMOKER. LESS THAN 5% HAVE YOU
THAT BENEFITS. WITH NOT TO
PROVIDE THEIR DUTY. ANYMORE
WITH. BECAUSE THEY NEED THAT
AND REQUESTED COMMITTEE NOW
DEPORTED THE- THANK YOU THANK
YOU- ANYONE IN THE ROOM AND ALL.
WILL MOVE ON TO THE FOR ANYWAY
AN OPERA. ON THE PHONE ON- AB
SEVENTY. THANK YOU FAIR AND UP.
OF AB SAID YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ONE OF THEIR
OFFER IN OPPOSITION. WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF TWO FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWO FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
RETURNED COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR SOMERS
ORDER. ADD LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION FORWARD-
THE NECESSITY FOR SAFETY
EQUIPMENT LIKE THIS AS A GROWN
OVER THE YEARS AND- IN ANSWER
TO ONE OF THE QUESTION ARE-
COMMENTS BY- I ONE OF THE-
WITNESSES. PUBLIC SECTOR
EMPLOYEE EMPLOYERS HAVE
ACTUALLY MADE THIS A STANDARD
ISSUE ITEM- WE CAN'T WE GET
WHEN WE GET ON THE ON THE FORCE
AND WE- WE TURN IT IN WHEN WE-
WE DON'T WE LEAVE. AND YOU KNOW
AND THEN THAT GETS RE USED IT'S
NOT A IT'S NOT A- SOMETHING
THAT- THEY HAVE TO THEY KEEP
BUYING. NEW EQUIPMENT ALL OF
THE TIME. IT IS A COST OF DOING
BUSINESS AND PUBLIC SAFETY. IS
WHAT IT IS AND WE'RE GONNA PLAY
IN THAT ARENA THEN WE NEED TO
PROTECT THE EMPLOYEES THIS IS
NOT A NICE TO HAVE OR A BENEFIT
OR A BONUS. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT. IF YOU'RE WORKING IN THIS
INDUSTRY YOU WILL FIND TIMES
WHEN- YOU CAN DO EVEN WHEN YOU
DON'T EXPECT IT. LAND THIS IS
MUCH NEEDED EQUIPMENT. AND SO-
YOU KNOW I REALLY SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY AND- AND- HI I THANK
YOU FOR RECOGNIZING. THAT IT
DOES NEED TO BE EXTENDED INTO
THE PRIVATE SECTOR FROM THE
PUBLIC SECTOR. TO PROTECT THOSE
FOLKS AS WELL YOU KNOW THAT THE
EMTS- ON THE AMBULANCE A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE THAT THEY
ARE DIFFERENT THE FIRST LINE
MEDICS FOR WHATEVER AREA
THEY'RE CONTRACTED FOR. AND SO
THEY GO INTO SITUATIONS EVEN IF
THEY'RE TOLD TO HOLD OFF A
BLOCK AND A HALF. UNTIL THE
SCENE IS SECURE YOU DON'T KNOW
WHO'S A BLOCK AND A HALF AWAY-
WITH YOU. SO IT DOESN'T MEAN
IT'S SAFE- YOU KNOW AND SO
ANYWAY I RECOGNIZE THAT AND
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET TO THIS SUMMER'S-
OTHER BILL IF YOU COULD BEFORE
THE RECESS OR ANY OF THE
COMMENTS AS A REWARD. ALSO
THANK YOU FOR THE BILL AND-
AGREED MANY OF THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS AS WELL I'M JUST KIND
OF CURIOUS HOW- BY BY REQUIRING
THIS UPON THEIR REQUEST HOW
MONEY- THE- NEED TO HAVE THE
BODY PROTECTIVE GEAR- IMPACT
RESPONSE TIMES- SO WHAT IF IT'S
NOT IN THE VEHICLE ITSELF- HE'S
GONNA HAVE TO BE EQUIPPED. IN
ALL VEHICLES. BUT THIS WOULD BE
PROVIDED TO THEM PUN STARTED
THEIR SHIFT OKAY SO THEY'LL
HAVE A DURING THE DURATION OF
THE SHIP SO WOULDN'T BE AFTER
THEY- THEY GET AFTER THE START
IT'S GOING TO BE PART OF THE
JOINT AUTHORS THEY'RE ALREADY
OUT THERE IN THE MIDDLE THEIR
SHIFT AND THEN THEY'RE
APPROACHING A SITUATION REALIZE
LIKE NOEL I. MIGHT NEED TO FOR
THIS ONE AND THEN. THE REQUEST
WOULD COME IN AT THE START OF A
CHEF'S YES START OF YOUR SHIFT
OKAY ARE AVAILABLE IN THE
OFFICE HE THE DIFFERENT SIZES.
AS WELL FOR OBVIOUSLY THE ITEM
I THINK IT'S GREAT HOPEFULLY
YOU KNOW YOU COULD KIND OF- I
AGREE AS WELL ABOUT NOT PUTTING
DIFFERENT STANDARDS SO AS THIS
IS MOVING QUARTER. LOOK AT YOU
KNOW THE APPLICABILITY TO THE
PRIVATE. TO THE PUBLIC SECTOR-
AND HOPEFULLY THERE'S A GRANT
PROGRAM- OR SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN ENVISION AS WELL TO BE ABLE
TO HELP OFFSET. SOME OF THE
COSTS THAT THAT MIGHT BE
IMPOSED ON THIS YEAR GREAT IN
LIKE THAT I MEAN THEY'RE
ALREADY OFFERING IT TO SOME
DIVISIONS AS WELL SO. OBVIOUSLY
THEY SAY THERE'S A NEED FOR TO
THE ALREADY. IS BEING PROVIDED
DURING CERTAIN NOT INCIDENTS
ARE BARGAINING AGREEMENT SO WHY
NOT. JUST PROVIDE IT TO
EVERYONE. NOT JUST SOME. RIGHT
WELL THANK YOU. VERY MUCH THANK
YOU FOR. YOUR FOR. ON ISSUE I
KNOW YOU TO WORK ON THIS OW
FOR A COUPLE YEARS- AND WE DO
HAVE A MOTION FROM SOME OF HIS
AUTHORED BY. SUMMER JONES
SAWYER. LIKE TO CLOSE. AFFECT
VS RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF MADAM SECRETARY
CALDERON EIGHTY SEVEN. MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA HI. KALRA HI FLORA.
GONZALEZ JONES SAWYER. JONES
SAWYER HI STONE. THE ART OF ART
SEATTLE FIVE WARD. WORD I.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE BILLS OUT
AND- LET'S JUST KEEP MOVING IN.
ON ELEVEN OH FIVE. US IF YOU
CAN BEGIN RIGHT AWAY AND THEN
WE'LL SEE IF WE CAN GET THIS
DONE BEFORE A- BREAK. THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS THANK YOUR
PROPERTY 2% A. B. ELEVEN OH
FIVE THIS MEASURES ABOUT
PROTECTING OUR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES AS
THEY CONTINUE TO BE AT. THE
FRONT LINES BATTLING THIS
PANDEMIC. THAT HAS PERSISTED
FOR OVER A YEAR. AND AS WE'VE
SEEN SINCE THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC THE FAILURE TO SCREEN
TEST AND TRACE ALL COVERT
NINETEEN FACTIONS THAT. HAS
RESULTED IN UNDETECTED
TRANSMISSION DELAYED CRITICAL
TREATMENT AND- SPEEDING UP OF
THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS.
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC. HEALTH ISSUE
GUIDANCE FOR WEEKLY TESTING OF
HEALTH CARE WORKERS. A. B.
LEVEL FIVE BUILDS ON THE
GUIDANCE BY REQUIRING EMPLOYERS
TO PROVIDE PP. TOSSED FROM
PLACE DEVELOPER PROGRAM TO
OFFER WEEKLY TESTING. FOR
PERSONAL REQUIRE EMPLOYERS TO
TEST PATIENTS FOR COLBERT
NINETEEN. PART BOB PARTED
MISSION. AS A BILL FORWARD A
WILL CONTINUE TO GET TO A CH A
AND ACP ON THEIR- THEY HAVE
RAISED TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
FACE CRITICIZING. BUT THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES STATION WAS
ALSO ON THE LINE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MISTER LANG HAVE UP TO
TWO MINUTES SIR YOU MAY BEGIN
IF YOU'RE READING. THE
RESEARCHER GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR NUMBER ONE PERSON
ONE OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION. REPRESENTING OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
REGISTERED NURSES. WANTED OF A
DEAL I'M NOT BY. WE THINK THE
PROJECT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RODRIGUEZ WAS LEADERSHIP. AND
BRING FOR THIS MUCH NEEDED
MASTER. AND AS A- MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ INDICATE THE
PROTECTION OF HEALTHCARE
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
FROM THE ACQUISITION OF COVERT
NINETEEN IMPROPER THIS CRITICAL
TO COMBATING THIS DISEASE IN
THE PANDEMIC. ONE YEAR TO THE
PANDEMIC ARE NURSES DEAL
REPORT. INADEQUATE READING OF
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND PATIENTS
ADMITTED TO HOSPITALS AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES.
INCLUDING THAT NOT ALL PATIENTS
ARE TESTED BEFORE ARRIVAL. AND
THAT IN SOME CASES PROCEEDED UP
A FORM WELL PATIENTS TAX. UP
TEST RESULTS ARE STILL PENDING.
BY NOT BEING ALL PATIENT
POPULOUS BUILT INSURE PROPER
PRECAUTIONS ARE IN PLACE TO
PREVENT TRANSMISSION WITHIN THE
FACILITY. ACCORDINGLY AB ELEVEN
OH FIVE REQUIRES GENERAL TEAM
HERE HOSPITALS TO NUMBER ONE.
DEVELOPING IMPLEMENT WEEKLY
CLUB IN NINETEEN TESTING OF
HEALTHCARE PERSONNEL. WHO MAY
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO OR HAVE
CLIENTS SYMPTOMS CONSISTENT
WITH COPIES OF IT NINETEEN.
BECAUSE IF THEY ARE SYMPTOMATIC
OR ASYMPTOMATIC. NUMBER TWO IT
REQUIRES- CONTINUING
IMPLEMENTATION OF OTHER
INFECTION. PREVENTION AND
CONTROL AND INTERVENTIONS
INCLUDING MONSTER ALL
HEALTHCARE PERSONNEL. AND
PATIENTS FOR SIGNS. AND
SYMPTOMS OF PUBLIC NINETEEN.
UNIVERSAL MAP. PHYSICAL
DISTANCE AND CLEAN AND THIS.
THIRD INTO TED YOU KNOW HELP
PERSON EVEN IF THEY HAVE BACK
TO. AND WILL JUST OFF FOR OVER
NINE FIVE TO WHICH IS ABOUT.
AND TO MY ALL PATIENTS DURING
THEIR HOT STAY. WITH THE FOR
THE NIGHT IN SAN. SOME THAT THE
TYPES MEASURES ARE NO LAW WARM.
AND THAT CAL ONE UPWARD WE HAVE
INDEED MADE SOME PROGRESS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE PREVALENCE
OF VARIANTS. THE PERVASIVENESS
OF VACCINE RESISTANCE FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS COMMUNITY
AND THE LACK OF AN IMPROVED
VACCINE FOR CHILDREN UNDER
SIXTEEN ARE SERIOUS ISSUES IN
THE VISION BEEN THE CASE THAT
WE ARE NOT OUT OF THE WOODS.
AND THERE'S STILL WORK TO DO TO
POTECT PROTECT CALIFORNIANS.
EVEN APPELLEE SUCH AS
PROFESSIONAL AND COLLEGE
BASKETBALL FOOTBALL AND
BASEBALL PLAYERS ARE ROUTINELY
TESTED. SOMETIMES DALY BUT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS WHO SAVE
LIVES STILL CAN'T FIND OUT
EASILY IF THEY HAVE TO BE
NINETEEN. IN ORDER TO PROTECT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS PATIENTS IN
THE OVAL OFFICE MEETING
CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE MEASURES
OUTLINED IN THIS BILL MUST BE
IMPLEMENTED. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS TODAY ON A.
B. ELEVEN OH FIVE AND I'MAVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ON A. B.
ELEVEN OH FIVE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM IN SUPPORT. IF NOT LET'S
GO TO PHONES ANYONE ON THE
SINCE OF AB ALLOW- FOR.
GEFEIERT WURDE F. A. B. OFF YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE- EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MAP PROPERTY CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS AT THE COURT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT THE LINE OF ONE EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SPORTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU AND
I KNOW WE HAVE AN OPPOSITION
BARBARA GLAZER- SO- IF YOU'RE
ON THE PHONE YOU MAY BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. AFTER
TWO MINUTES PLEASE. HERE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I WILL BE
BRIEF IF THE PART REQUIRED
THERE WITH A CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE DO HAVE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON A. B. ELEVEN OH
FIVE. THE COMPANY NINETEEN HAS
PRESENTED INCREDIBLE AN
UNFORESEEABLE CHALLENGES FOR
ALL OF THAT AND HOSPITALS HAVE
MET THE CHALLENGE TIME AND
AGAIN BY TAKING CARE OF THE
SICK AND KEEPING THEIR
EMPLOYEES SAFE WITH. SIGN STATE
INSPECTION CONTROL AND
PROTECTION. THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC HOSPITALS HAVE
FOLLOWED THE REGULATORY
GUIDANCE FROM THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION.
IN THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. IT IS IMPORTANT
TO MAINTAIN FLEXIBILITY TO
ADAPT AND ALLOW THE LATEST
SCIENTIFIC FINDINGS TO GUIDE
ORGANIZATIONAL PRACTICES
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC.
UNFORTUNATELY ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN OH FIVE WOULD PREVENT
HOSPITALS FROM CONTINUING THEIR
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES TO
INFECTION CONTROL. IN ORDER TO
ALLOW FLEXIBILITY IN THE
HOSPITAL DECISION MAKING C. H.
A. YEAH THE FOLLOWING AMENDMENT.
PERMIT TAXABLE MATH IT
SUPPORTED BY FINE AB ELEVEN OH
FIVE WOULD REQUIRE ALL HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS WHERE MATH.
ACTIVATE THE PERFECT
PROFESSIONALS BACK IN STATUS
WELL THAT IS CURRENTLY FOUND
GUIDANCE HA BELIEVES THAT OUR
MEMBERS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ADJUST THEIR MATH POLICY TO
FUTURE GUIDANCE FROM THE AGENCY.
FORTUNATELY H. THANK AB OH FIVE
WOULD REQUIRE CLOSE THE
NINETEEN TESTING OF EXPOSED
HEALTHCARE PERSONNEL BUT IT
DOESN'T SPECIFY THE EXPOSURE
TIME LINE C. H. A. BELIEVE THAT
AB ELEVEN OH FIVE SHOULD ALIGN
WITH EXISTING LAW. IN FUTURE
GUIDANCE INTENSIFIED THAT THE
CODE NINETEEN EXPOSURE THAT
TRIGGERED MANDATORY TESTING OF
FIFTEEN MINUTES. OR MORE THE
TWENTY FOUR HOUR PERIOD. AB
ELEVEN OH FIVE BUT ALSO
REQUIRED THAT ALL PATIENTS BE
TESTED PROPOSED NINETEEN BEFORE
BEING ADMITTED. WE DO ASK THAT
THERE BE SOME LIMITED
EXCEPTIONS TO THIS. VISION AND
THEN LASTLY WE BELIEVE THAT- WE
NEED TO ALIGN THE DURATION OF
THESE REQUIREMENTS WITH
EXISTING LAW. LAST YEAR EVERY
BECAUSE THE NINETEEN BILLS
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR HEADED
SUNSET DATE OF JANUARY THE
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE HAS
BEEN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE
CONSTANTLY CHANGING NATURE OF
THE VIRUS AN APPROPRIATE
RESPONSE TO IT. HM I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT HE BE
ELEVEN OH FIVE BE BROUGHT INTO
ALIGNMENT WITH EXISTING SUNSET
DATE. TO PERMIT A HOLISTIC
REVIEW. OF EXISTING CULVERT
NINETEEN LAW. AND INTAKE IN A
ACCOUNT THAT WILL BE THE NORM
IN NEW TREATMENTS AND
SCIENTIFIC DEVELOPMENTS WILL BE
MATURE. YOU TAKE A LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS TO
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. ANYONE
IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. ELEVEN OH FIVE WILL GO TO
THE PHONES- ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONES TO AB
ELEVEN OH FIVE. GIVEN
OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN OH FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF A. B. ELEVEN OH
FIVE. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NOBODY IN OPPOSITION AT THE
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IS A REWARD. ONE OF
ONE OF THOSE UNITS INTRODUCED A
YEAR AGO- WITH URGENCY-
DEFINITELY WOULD HAVE HELPED
OUT IN IN IN- IN SOME
SIGNIFICANT CAPACITY- OVER THE
LAST TWELVE MONTHS BUT- I'M
GOING FOR I GUESS THE WHAT ONE
CONCERN I HAVE IS YOU KNOW- ON
THE ON THE COURSE OF ITS OWN
RIGHT NOW IT WOULDN'T EVEN BE
IN EFFECT UNTIL JANUARY. FIRST
AND SO CERTAINLY TO THE- ONE OF
THE POINTS RAISED ABOUT A
SUNSET- AND I'M NOT SURE IF WE
WANT TO YOU KNOW TRY TO. PICK
OUT HARD AND FAST DATE AYE
TYING INTO POSSIBLY YOU KNOW
THE END OF THE DECLARATION OF A
STATE OF EMERGENCY OR SOMETHING
ELSE I THINK WOULD. PROVIDE
CONCERNED BECAUSE- WE
DEFINITELY WOULDN'T WANT
ANYTHING MEMORIALIZED IN CODE
THAT'S REQUIRING UNNECESSARY
TESTING- AND PROCEDURES SO ARE
THESE THE KINDS OF THINGS
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT WHEN YOU
MENTION YOU WERE WORKING WITH
THE CURRENT OPPOSITION ON SOME
OF THE POINTS THERE CREEK TO
APPARENTLY GO. ONE TO TALK TO
HIM ABOUT MORE DETAILS WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE BUT WE TALK
ABOUT A SUNSET I THINK BECAUSE
OF. WE'RE SEEING THESE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF- PROCREATION
THE COPA NINETEENTH AND OTHER
THINGS THAT MAKE MORALES SAID I
THINK WOULD BE A ISSUE IF WE
HAVE A SENSE OF BECAUSE WE NEED
TO. BE PREPARED FOR THE FUTURE-
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
OUT THERE IN A YEAR FROM NOW OR
TWO YEARS FROM NOW RIGHT IT IS
VERY HARD WE DON'T WE DON'T AND
HEAVEN FORBID THAT THAT DOESN'T
THAT- THIS GETS BETTER
PRESIDENT THAN WORSE THAT- BUT
IT'S SITTING AT THE IT GETS
BETTER- YOU KNOW AND THERE.
THERE MIGHT BE SOME KIND OF END
POINT WHERE THIS IS NO LONGER
AT THAT MAJOR RISK FOR THREAT-
TO HAVE MEMORIALIZED CODE THAT.
HAS THESE REQUIREMENTS AND- YOU
KNOW JUST OPENED IT TO THINK
ABOUT THAT THERE THERE MIGHT BE
AN AND ACCEPT NEXANT MECHANISM
A REASONABLE EXIT MECHANISM IN
HERE- AND THEN YOU KNOW SEVERAL
THE OTHER POINTS RAISED HERE TO
WITHOUT. A PERMIT THAT
PERMITTING FLEXIBLE MASKING-
AND THEN YOU KNOW THAT I'M KIND
OF WORKING WITH YOU KNOW SOME
NARROW EXCEPTIONS ABOUT WHEN. A
PATIENT IF THEY REFUSE TO TAKE
A TEST OR THE THAN TONIGHT ALL
HEALTH CARE- AND I THINK HE'D
BE. DESERVES A REASONABLE
THINGS THAT THAT THAT SHOULD BE
WORK ON SO IT'S SO YOU'RE
COMMITTEE ARE GONNA CONTINUE
WORK WEATHER PROBLEM THAT
HUSTLES HE'S ON THAT OKAY
THANKS HAVE WITHOUT WILL BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU IS THAT A
MOTION SIR- ALL MELT ALL.
BECAUSE THAT- AND- WITH THE-
SERVICE CHARGE. OKAY WITH THE-
BUT WITH THE COMMENT. OF THE
BILL. GET COMMENTS MADE. OF AN
IN AND- I DO. THAT YOU. ALSO
ANOTHER ONE PER. AND POLICY
OKAY. OF FRONTLINE HEALTHCARE
WORKER. THAT'S ACT BUT THE-
THAT DO IT. I THINK THERE IS.
DENOUNCED ALIVE YET. TO KNOW TO
BE NO. ABOUT THESE VERY. SO AS.
YOU KNOW PART TIME OF LIKE HOPE
FOR THE BEST PAIR OF THE- WITH.
THIS IS TAUGHT ALL. US ABOUT
THAT. SO BUT I BUT I APPRECIATE-
THE FACT YOU'LL BE WORKING.
WITH THE OPPOSITION- AND ON
SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS- BUT
ULTIMATELY. I THINK THAT THOSE
THAT WERE ASKING. TO BE ON THE
FRONT LINE AND CONTINUE TO BE
ON THE FRONT LINE- I THINK
THAT- WE NEED TO. OFFER SOME OF
THE BASIC PROTECTION. ARE
INCLUDED TO THE PATIENTS ARE
GOING TO THE HOSPITAL. YOU KNOW
I AND I THINK NOW THAT WE HAVE
THESE OF THE RAPID TESTING YOU
CAN TURN AROUND BY TEN MINUTES.
AND ALLOW FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR THOSE REMITTED WHAT HAVE
YOU SO- BUT IF THERE'S NEED FOR
MORE FLEXIBILITY OR- WHAT HAVE
YOU DOES THE CONVERSATION A
MEASURE THAT WILL CONTINUE. AND
SO WITH THAT. WE DO HAVE A-
PROMOTION- BY MR. SUMMER WAR
SECOND ABOUT ME- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. OUR RECORDS PRIVATE.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY. CALLED FOR THE VOTE.
MOTION IS THE PATH TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA. I KALRA
HI FLORA. GONZALEZ JONES
SAWYER. STONE CRT NO. SORROW
NO. WARD WARD I. THOUGHT THAT
WAS. WHAT IS THAT THOSE ON CALL
THANK YOU GUARDRAIL TO GET YOU.
THANK YOUR PATIENCE. WE GET OUT
HERE AND STUFF. WE'RE GOING TO
GO ON A RECESS. FOR MEMBERS
THAT PUT IN ORDER- THERE SHOULD
BE A CHALLENGE FOR YOU IN THE-
IN THE MEMBERS LOUNGE. AND SO-
GO SOMEWHERE YOU COULD TAKE
YOUR MASK OFF AND- EAT. AND-
WAS IT TO REACH WE CAN DO THAT
TOO PM. A TIME CERTAIN OVER
HERE A TO AN THEN AFTER THE
BILL WILL GO A LONG. THE ORDER
BILLS.
TERM FACING PERIOD UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE GIVING EMPLOYEES
PLENTY OF TIME TO PUT ANY
PROCESSES THAT THEY MIGHT NEED
TO COLLECT A REPORT. WITH
RESPECT TO THE REQUIRED METRICS
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
DRUCKER INSTITUTE AT CLAREMONT
GRADUATE UNIVERSITY BE
PROTESTERS EIGHTEEN METRICS
CONTAINED IN THE BILL BUT A
HANDFUL OF LARGE COMPANIES A
RETAILER A TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDER AND MEDICAL DEVICE
MAKER IN A PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES FIRM. EACH FOLDER THE
SAME THING THAT WOULD BE
DIFFICULT TO CALCULATE AND
SHARE THE STATUS IF THEY WERE
OBLIGATED TO DO SO AND I'M
HAPPY TO BE JOINED BY REPORTS
MINT WHAT THE TRUCKER
INSTITUTE. IT'S PART OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL MOVE TO. OF
AN. H. MISTER CHAIR NUMBER
SEVEN YEAH I'M REPORTS NONE OF
THE DRUCKER INSTITUTE A SOCIAL
ENTERPRISE BASE TO CLAREMONT
GRADUATE UNIVERSITY. AND I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY BEFORE YOU TODAY.
THE MISSION OF THE DRUCKER
INSTITUTE IS STRENGTHENING
ORGANIZATIONS TO STRENGTHEN
SOCIETY. AND IN THIS ROLE WE
PRODUCE AN ANNUAL RANKING OF
THE NATION'S BEST RUN COMPANIES
FOR THE WALL STREET JOURNAL AND
ACTIVELY CONSULT WITH THE CEOS
OF SEVERAL MAJOR CORPORATIONS.
IN OTHER WORDS WE'RE NOT
STRANGERS TO THE BUSINESS WORLD
AND WHAT I CAN TELL YOU WHAT
THE CONTROLLER MENTIONED IN THE
CHAIR MENTIONED IS THAT
CORPORATE AMERICA IS MOVING AND
IN SOME CASES MOVING SWIFTLY.
IN A DIRECTION THAT AB ELEVEN
NINETY TWO WOULD TAKE US. FOR
EXAMPLE THE INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESS COUNCIL LED BY BANK OF
AMERICA CEO BRIAN MOYNIHAN AS
ISSUE THE STANDARDIZED DATA
DRIVEN DISCLOSURE REGIME
COVERING WAGES DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION A QUALITY ON PAY
TRAINING AND HEALTH AND SAFETY.
MORE THAN SIXTY COMPANIES HAVE
AGREED TO ADHERE TO THIS
ARRANGEMENT INCLUDING SIDE TO
BE A BIT OF A DELL TECHNOLOGIES
IBM MASTERCARD PAYPAL AND
SALESFORCE. A NUMBER OF
COMPANIES MEANWHILE ARE ALREADY
SHARING METRICS THAT WE DO THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED UNDER EIGHTY
ELEVEN NINETY TWO. FOR INSTANCE
HALF OF THE ONE HUNDRED LARGEST
PUBLICLY TRADED COMPANIES ON
THE U. S. HAVE NOW AGREED TO
FULLY DISCLOSE DATA ON THE
RACIAL ETHNIC AND GENDER MAKE
UP OF THEIR PROPOSALS. OTHERS
ARE URGING EVEN MORE ACTION THE
COALITION FOR INCLUSIVE
CAPITALISM RECENTLY ISSUED A
FRAMEWORK THAT CALLS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF UNIFORM AND
MANDATORY DISCLOSURE STANDARDS
EXACTLY WHAT'S PROPOSED IN AB
ELEVEN NINETY TWO. ON WAGES AND
BENEFITS WORKFORCE TURNOVER USE
OF INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND
OTHER KEY INDICATORS. NOTABLY
MANY OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMISSION RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
FRAMEWORK ARE THEMSELVES
BUSINESS LEADERS TO INCLUDE A
HALF DOZEN CORPORATE DIRECTORS
AT TEXACO EXXON ALPHABET AND
OTHER LARGE COMPANIES. THIS IS
A UNIQUE. MOMENT IN HISTORY TO
WALK THE TALK OPTICA MAKES. CAP
MEASURABLE KLAUS SCHWAB THE
CHAIR OF THE WORLD ECONOMIC
FORUM HAS NOTED. AB ELEVEN
NINETY TWO STANDS TO PUT THE
STATE AT THE FOREFRONT OF THIS
BROADER MOVEMENT WHILE MOST
IMPORTANTLY ENCOURAGING THE
CREATION OF HIGH QUALITY JOBS
FOR CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. WE WILL
NOW GO TO OTHERS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI
ELEVEN NINETY TWO IS THERE
ANYONE. HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NONE ANYONE AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR AB ELEVEN
NINETY TWO FOR THOSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT AND WE
ARE ASKING THAT PEOPLE GIVE US
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THAT THEY SUPPORT AB ELEVEN
NINETY TWO. THANK WHICH EVER
SINCE IF YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN NINETY. THIS PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE. WHEN THE LINE NUMBER
NINETY NINE THESE SO I HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRY MEMBERS
DIED APRIL AT THE FD W. BACK
TRANSLATE COUNSELING TO STRONG
SUPPORT YEAH. AN HOUR TO GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
SHANE GOT SPENT ON BEHALF OF
THE TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT.
THAT'S A GOOD LINE NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY THREE BUT. SACRAMENTO
COULD NOT BE HAPPIER CONTRACTED
WORK IN SUPPORT. ALKALINE
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHEN I BY OUR WITH AT
THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. NOW GO TO LINE TWO
NINETY THREE BEFORE. THERE ARE
FLOCKS REPRESENTING THE
TRANSPORT WORKERS UNION
CALIFORNIA STATE CONFERENCE IN
SUPPORT. WHAT ONE NUMBER TWO
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPORT. A LITTLE LINE
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY THREE PEOPLE
AHEAD. MARK SHOCK FOR
CALIFORNIA WORLD LEGAL FIFTEEN
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. AND ONCE
AGAIN LAYS GENEROUSLY JEWISH
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB ONE ONE
NINE TWO THIS PRESS ONE OF THEM
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE MULTIPLE
WAYS WHAT PARTY. JUST ONE MORE.
WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY ONE PEOPLE AT. THREE
ZERO FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF FEDERAL CONTRACT
COMPLIANCE PROGRAMS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR IN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION FROM. TWO
THOUSAND NINETY TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WHERE I REGULATED
FEDERAL CONTRACTORS WITH
RESPECT TO NONDISCRIMINATION
AND AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. IN
SUPPORT. AND MISTER CHAIR
PERSON AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER PARTY. IF YOU ONLINE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE OF THE
MOMENT TAKE. YEAH MISTER
CHAIRPERSON OF NOBODY ELSE. IT
IS OKAY BUT IT. YEAH AND I'M
NOT SURE IF YOU HEARD ME BUT
THERE ARE NOBODY ELSE IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
OPERATOR I DID NOT CATCH THAT-
YOUR YOUR VOLUME IS A LITTLE
BIT LOW- THERE WERE ALSO
LOOKING FOR AN ADDITIONAL
WITNESS DOUG BLOCKED. YOU OPEN
UP THE WITNESS LINES AGAIN FOR
HIM TO BE ABLE TO. THIS
INDICATES SUPPORT AS WELL. YES
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. MISBACH YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU DOUG BOCK WITH
TEAMSTERS JOINT COUNCIL SEVEN
AND A MEMBER OF THE FUTURE OF
WORK COMMISSION. ADDING MY
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT NOW LET'S MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE
OPPOSITION WITNESS LISTED
ACTUALLY HOFFMAN WHO IS WITH US
ON THE PHONE TALKING ARE YOU
WITH US. YES GOOD AFTERNOON GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
ACTUALLY HOW OFTEN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY ELEVEN NINETY TWO IS A
JOB KILLER- AS AMERICANIZATION
THAT REPRESENTS OVER THIRTEEN
THOUSAND IT DOESN'T CALIFORNIA
VARYING SIZES I CAN ASSURE YOU
THE BILL AS WRITTEN HAS EXTREME
CONCERN BY THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY. AB ELEVEN NINETY TWO
WILL BE USED TO UNFAIRLY PUBLIC
SHAME PUBLISHING BUSINESS
CENTRAL AWFUL MENTIONING THAT
CONDUCT THEIR REQUIRES
EMPLOYERS TO REPORT DATA
REGARDING WAGES BENEFITS
SCHEDULING AND SAFETY WITH THE
EXPLICIT INTENT OF USING THAT
DATA TO COMPARE BUSINESSES TO
ONE ANOTHER. THE SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL STATES THAT THE
INTENT FOR THE DATA TO READ
LIKE A NUTRITION LABEL LIKE
WHAT YOU WOULD SEE AT THE
GROCERY STORE TO COMPARE
PRODUCTS. THE DATA WOULD THEN
BE USED TO DETERMINE WHICH
BUSINESSES SHOULD GET
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS AND
GOVERNMENT FUNDING THE DATA
WOULD ALSO BE PUBLIC FOR THE
WORLD TO SEE. AND THE BILL'S
PROBLEMATIC FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS FIRST BUSINESSES WILL
BE HIT WITH LAWSUITS AND DEMAND
LETTERS BASED ON DATA THAT HAS
THE APPEARANCE OF A WAGE
DISPARITY EVEN WE'RE NOT
ACCEPT. A PRIOR BUILDING TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WOULD HAVE REQUIRED
THE PUBLICATION OF DATA FROM
EMPLOYERS ON THE WAGE
DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN MALE AND
FEMALE EMPLOYEES. IN AN ARTICLE
THAT YEAR IN THE SACRAMENTO
BUSINESS JOURNAL OF SACRAMENTO
AREA PLAINTIFFS ATTORNEY THAT
IS WELL KNOWN FOR CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT.
STATED IN THAT ARTICLE THAT BY
POSTING THE DATA THE GOVERNMENT
IS BASICALLY GIVING PLAINTIFFS
LAWYERS THE DATA THY NEED TO
GO IN THERE AD HAMMER
COMPANIES HE AGREED HE WOULD
ABSOLUTELY USE THAT DATA TO
START SERVING DEMAND LETTERS
AND LAWSUITS. EVEN IF THE
BUSINESS OR TO BE ABLE TO SHOW
THAT. THERE ARE LEGITIMATE
REASONS FOR THE PLATE. FOR
COMMERCIAL. THAT WOULD BE AFTER
SO ABOUT THE OF DOLLARS DEPEND
ON SUCH A CLAIM AND THAT. IT
WAS VETOED IN PART DUE TO PER
OF WHETHER. SECOND BUT THAT IT
DOES NOT PROVIDED. REPRESENT OF
HOW COMPANIES. AND EMPLOYER A
MAJOR OF ITS EMPLOYEES. AND
STATE THE FLOOR MINIMAL WASTE
WATER AREAS WITH LOWER COST OF
LIVING WILL HAVE LOWER PAY. AND
IF THE STATE OR CITY THROUGH
THE EMPLOYER IS LOCATED HAS A
HIGHER NUMBER OF WOMEN OR
RACIAL MINORITIES IN ITS
WORKFORCE ANOTHER. AREA OF THE
COUNTRY THAT WILL IMPACT AND
SKEW THE DATA REPORTED. SO
REALLY AB ELEVEN NINETY TWO
REQUIRES EMPLOYERS TO IDENTIFY
THE NUMBER OF INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS THAT USE THAT.
EMPLOYERS WITH A LARGER
WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA'S
OBJECTION ABC TEST IS LIKELY TO
HAVE A VERY DIFFERENT
STATISTICS. SENATE MCGUIRE
BASED IN THE STATE THAT
FOLLOWED FEDERAL LAW OR A
DIFFERENT STANDARD. PROPONENTS
OF THE BILLHAVE SAID THAT THE
DATA COMPARISON IS NOT A
PROBLEM BECAUSE THE COMPANIES
WILL BE STORED IT IN. TWENTY
FOUR INDUSTRY EXPERTS. HOWEVER
THE TWENTY FOUR INDUSTRY GROUPS
ARE QUITE BROAD INCLUDING
CATEGORIES SUCH AS MATERIALS
CAPITAL GOODS MEDIA AND
ENTERTAINMENT AND CONSUMER
SERVICES. EACH ONE INCOME THIS
IS A WIDEVARIETY OF TYPES OF
BUSINESSES AND BUSINESS MODELS.
FOR EXAMPLE IN MEDIAN
ENTERTAINMENT COMPANIES THE
DATA FOR A PRODUCTION COMPANY
THAT REGULARLY USES DALY HIRES
ARE BACK FOR PERFORMERS. HAD
UNIQUE SCHEDULING NEEDS IS
GOING TO LOOK SIGNIFICANTLY
DIFFERENT FROM AN ADVERTISING
AGENCY IN THAT SAME CATEGORY.
IN CAPITAL GOODS COMPANIES
ENGAGE IN AEROSPACE AND DEFENSE
LOOK FAR DIFFERENT FROM THOSE
THAT MANUFACTURE SMALLER MORE
SPECIFIC PRODUCTS LIKE AN
ELECTRIC WIRE OR A TRADING
COMPANY. UNDER THIS BILL BOTH
COMPANIES THAT COULD HAVE STATE
BENEFITS ARE CONTRACTS WITH
HELP FROM THEM. OR BE SHAMED IN
NEWS HEADLINES OR LAWSUITS
BASED ON AN APPLES TO ORANGES
COMPARISON THAT RESULT FROM THE
PROPOSED METRICS. FOR THOSE
REASONS AND OTHERS WHO DO
OPPOSE EIGHTY ELEVEN NINETY TWO
THAT THE. JOCULAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW GO TO
OTHERS IN OP TO CERTAIN HE AND
HERE ROOM SITTING ANYWHERE THE
REMOTE STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES PLEASE FOR THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN NINETY
TWO I MEAN WE ARE TAKING NAME
AFFILIATION AND THAT THEY ARE
OPPOSED TO AB ELEVEN NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRPERSON. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB ONE ELEVEN NINETY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. FIRST ONE GUIDELINE
NUMBER TWO NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS KATIE HANSON WITH A
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. THANKS WATER LINE
NUMBER TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN
LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. NOW WE'RE GONNA LINE
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS LORD TODAY NO GAP THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY SOCIAL WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION. AND ONCE AGAIN LAYS
GERMAN IF YOUR OPPOSITION AB
ONE ONE NINE TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU
OPERATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THE
LINES FOR A BI ELEVEN NINETY
TWO OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. I HAVE WITH A SERRA.
THANK A COUPLE QUESTIONS- ONE
OF THE WITNESSES- ONE OF THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES SAID THE
CORPORATE AMERICA IS MOVING
SWIFTLY TOWARDS DOING WHAT'S
ALREADY IN THIS BILL. SO I'VE
DONE A PRIVATE INDUSTRY IS
MOVING SWIFTLY TOWARDS DOING
THAT WHY DO YOU NEED A BILL.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT. IT COMES
OUT WELL I THINK A COUPLE
THINGS ONE IS FOR UNIFORMITY
ONE IS. BUT IT DEFINITELY IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE DATA THAT WE
AND AGAIN THIS IS COMING OUT
OF- OVER YOUR LONG.
PARTICIPATION IN THE FUTURE
WORK COMMISSION AS ONE OF THE
KIND OF THE GOALS OF THE
COMMISSION. AND SO IT'S YOU
KNOW THAT THERE ARE DIFFERENT.
MANNERS IN WHICH CORPORATE
AMERICA THEY MAY BE LOOKING AT
ONE ASPECT OF THE OTHER THIS IS
GOING TO CREATE A UNIFORM
STANDARD. IN ORDER FOR US TO
REALLY HAVE A JOB QUALITY INDEX
THAT INDICATES A RECRUITING
GOOD QUALITY JOBS. AND SO- WITH
THE THAT'S- THAT'S THE REASON
WHY WE WANT SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO BE VERY CLEAR LOOKED
AT THAT AND I GOT TO GIVE
CREDIT TO STATE CONTROLLER BUT
HE'S HER TEAM AND PUT A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK IN
TERMS OF THE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIZATION OF WHAT DATA IS
IMPORTANT. AS WELL AS THE
DIFFERENT SECTORS AND THEY'VE
BEEN WORKING WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH A NUMBER OF BUSINESS
LEADERS AND BUSINESS
ORGANIZATIONS TO DETERMINE WHAT
THOSE CRITERIA AND CATEGORIES
SHOULD BE AND I THINK HAVING
SOMETHING UNIFORMS FAR- THAT IS
A USEFUL WELL FOR US AS A STATE
IN TERMS OF ELEVATING HIGH ROAD
EMPLOYERS- IT IS WHAT MATTERS
THE MOST I THINK AS A- AS A
STATE LEGISLATOR AS A IN TERMS
OF PUTTING PART OF POLICY SO
YES ARE THERE THINGS HAPPENING
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
ABSOLUTELY OF THAT REALLY
INDICATES. THE FACT THERE'S A
RECOGNITION THAT THAT THIS
INFORMATION AND- DOES MATTER
BUT THERE'S NOT A UNIFORM
STANDARD THAT'S WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS CREATE ONE THAT MAKES
SENSE OF WORSHIP CALIFORNIA
RIGHT WELL MIGHT NOT WORK FOR
ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
WHY SOME CORPORATIONS ARE
MOVING TOWARDS THAT AND SUMMER
LAGGING BEHIND BECAUSE THEY
MIGHT THEY MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO
AND CREATING THIS UNIFORM
STANDARD IN A BILL THAT SAYS
YOU HAVE TO DO IT- FORCES THEM
INTO TERRITORY THAT THEY'RE NOT
READY TO BE ABLE TO- TO
PARTICIPATE IN. AND SO THE
SECOND QUESTION I HAVE IS I
HEARD SEVERAL TIMES THIS IS
ENCOURAGING HIGH PAYING JOBS
HOW DOES ADVERTISING HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS AND HOW HOW
MUCH IT COSTS TO DO BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA TO THE WORLD CREATE
HIGH PAYING JOBS WHEN THAT
WOULD DISCOURAGE ANYBODY FROM
SETTING UP A CORPORATION HERE
WELL I WOULD AGREE WITH THAT
CONTENTION BUT I WOULD SAY THAT
THIS IS JUST REQUIRING
PUBLISHING INFORMATION- OF THAT
THEY ALREADY HAVE THESE
COMPANIES FOR THE MOST PART. OF
A THOUSAND MORE EMPLOYEES
RIGHT- HAVE THIS DATA AND TO
MAKE IT ACCESSIBLE- MY AT THE
END OF THE DAY- IS THAT THE
REALITY IS THAT EMPLOYERS HAVE
DONE WELL IN. CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY WELL IN CALIFORNIA WE
WILL TO MAKE SURE THE AND- AS
THEY'RE DOING- CAN IN- HOW
THERE'S- IS ALSO TRYING. TO
HIGH QUALITY- AND THAT'S WHAT
I'VE- OF. A JOB AND THIS WAS
NATURE. I WOULD DO AND THE
REALITY IS THAT LOOK I MEAN A
LOT OF THE FOLKS THAT MAY BE.
HAVING SOME CONCERNS IN
OPPOSITION- I HAD MEMBERS ON
THIS COMMISSION. YOU KNOW THEY
WERE PART OF SETTING FORTH THIS
IS ONE OF THE GOALS- THE COMING
OUT OF THE COMMISSION. AND SO.
ULTIMATELY I THINK AT LEAST IN
THE WORK OF THE COMMISSION. WE
WERE ALL IN AGREEMENT. THAT
CREATING HIGHER QUALITY JOBS
IMPORTANT GOAL FOR THE FUTURE
OF WORK IN CALIFORNIA HI. SO IF
YOU'RE IN TEXAS AND YOU'RE
COMPETING WITH CALIFORNIA TO
BRING IN A PLAYER A LARGE
EMPLOYER- THAT HAS A LOT OF
WELL PAYING JOBS. AND
CALIFORNIA LET YOU KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE COMPETING. AGAINST
YOUR TEXAS AND YOU DON'T. WELL
GUESS WHAT. TEXAS WINDS. AND
THEY'RE WINNING A LOT. FROM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SIR FOR. YOURSELF WHY DID
WE EXEMPT THE PUBLIC SECTOR
HELLO THIS. HI MICHAEL I CAN
ALLOW THE CONTROLLER TO SPEAK
TO THAT BUT- THE REALITY IS
THAT A LOT OF THE- PUBLIC
SECTOR INFORMATION INCLUDING
OUR OWN. SALARIES ARE. PUBLICLY
DISPOSABLE- AND ANOTHER SET
BACK I CAN I CAN SPEAK TO THAT
MR OUR PERHAPS YES PLEASE
MONITOR ABOUT OFFICIALS AND THE
PUBLIC SECTOR- MOST OF THEM
BECAUSE OF THE FIRST OF THOSE
WAS REALLY TO TIE. UP THE
REPORTING OF THE STANDARDS THAT
SET OF DATA ON THE- ON STATE
SPENDING SO IN OTHER WORDS TO
LOOK AT HOW WE COULD NOT. HAVE
THE IMPROVEMENT OF CONDITIONS
FOR WORKERS THAT- WOULD BE
INCENTIVIZED THROUGH THE STATE
SPENDING SO. THAT'S MOSTLY WHAT
THE PRIVATE SECTOR PARTICULARLY
HAS REPLACED IS. NOT DIVERTED
BE DIRECTING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO A LARGE SCALE
INITIATIVES- BUT- RESPECT
INSPITE ENERGY TRANSPORTATION
AND OTHER OTHER OTHER AREAS AS
WELL- YOU KNOW I DO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE. THAT- FEEL ABOUT
THAT. TEKHELET SERVER IN THE
BILL ARE REALLY WORK FORM A
SURVEY BUT BUSINESS CAN. AND UP
BEING ALMOST SEE. THAT THE WERE
THE BEST THAT UP OR WERE EASY
INITIALLY- OKAY FOR REPORTED
AND KEPT TRACK OF BY- BY
COMPANIES AND THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY SO OF THESE WERE NOT
INVENTED OUT OF THIN AIR. I
THINK THERE'S A CONSENSUS
AROUND IS THAT TRICKS BEING
READILY. AVAILABLE BY COMPANIES.
SO THE PUBLIC SECTOR- BECAUSE
THEIR DATA IS PUBLISHED THEY
WOULD NOT BE HELD LIABLE. I
MEAN UP A PRIVATE ATTORNEY CAN
COME NTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SCOOT AND SUE
SOMEBODY FOR PAY DISCREPANCY
CORRECT. BECAUSE THERE'S
MEMBERS ON THIS COMMITTEE THAT
HAVE HAD BILLS. TO ALLOW OUR
STAFF TO COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN
BECAUSE OF THE DISCREPANCY.
WITHIN THIS PARTICULAR
INSTITUTION. SO MY FRUSTRATION
ONCE AGAIN AS WE CONTINUE. TO
HAMMER THE PRIVATE SECTOR WITH
ALL OF THESE RULES BUT WE DON'T
CONTINUE TO FALL IN OUR OWN
HOUSE. THERE'S A MASSIVE
DISCREPANCY. WITHIN STAFF PAY
IN THIS BUILDING WITH OUR
EMPLOYEES. SO I'M JUST CURIOUS
WHAT. DOES THIS EXAMPLE STATE
FROM BEING SUED FOR PAY
DISCREPANCIES. I THINK I CAN
ANSWER THAT NO BECAUSE ALL THAT
INFORMATION IS PUBLIC AND IF
ATTORNEYS WERE GOING TO TAKE
THAT INFORMATION TO SUE THE
STATE ALL THAT DATA IS READILY
AVAILABLE SO THEN WHY IS IT
REMOVAL FOR PRIVATE BUSINESS IF
THEY PUBLISH ALL OF THIS. THE
WHITE OF THE WISER PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION TO THIS. IF
THEY CAN SUIT A PRIVATE
BUSINESS FOR THIS BUT THEY
CAN'T SEE THE STATE. WHAT AM I
MISSING. I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER
FOR THAT THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION WAS THE AVAILABILITY
OF DATA FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES YES
THAT IS AVAILABLE AND IF
SOMEONE WERE. WANTED TO BUILD A
SUIT AROUND THAT. THEY
CERTAINLY COULD. SO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS. AVAILABLE FOR
LITIGATION OVER PAY DISCREPANCY.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S PUBLISHED.
BECAUSE IT IS AVAILABLE IF
SOMEONE WANTED TO MAKE THAT
CASE THEY COULD TAKE THAT DATA
AND BUILD A CASE THERE'S
NOTHING THAT PREVENTS THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU. THE DALLAS. WE
DO HAVE PROVISIONS EQUAL PAY
ACT THAT. WOULD ALLOW FOR THAT
IN I. S. AS SOMEBODY WHO WROTE
A BILL AND REFERRED AT THIS
TIME AND FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE THE TO PROVIDE OUR STAFF
WITH A VERY IMPORTANT REAL.
OPPORTUNITY TO ORGANIZE INTO A
UNION- I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT. I OTHER PEOPLE MAY RENT
BILLS FOR OTHER REASONS BUT
THAT DID NOT HAVE TO DO WITH
THE PAY DISPARITY BECAUSE UNDER
THIS- SPEAKER WE ACTUALLY DON'T
HAVE A MALE AND FEMALE I THINK
IT'S DOWN TO LIKE 2% OR
SOMETHING INCREDIBLE COMPARED
TO ANYTHING IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR SO- WE- WE SUFFER MANY.
BILLS IN THIS BUILDING
ESPECIALLY TOWARDS OUR
EMPLOYEES AND I AGREE WITH YOU
THAT WE DON'T- WE DON'T FOLLOW
ALL THE RULES. OF LABOR LINE I
FIND THAT OFFENSIVE. BUT- IN
THIS PROVISION. ALL OF OUR
STAFF- INFORMATION ANY ANY
EMPLOYEE THE STATE CALIFORNIA
YOU CAN GOOGLE IT AND FIND IT
ONLINE I MEAN THERE'S A WHOLE
WEBSITE FOR ITSELF- IT'S
READILY AVAILABLE ARE READY THE
STRESS. I LOVE OUR CONVERSATION
ABSENT BUT ON THAT NOTE LIKE WE
MAY NOT HAVE A PAY DISCREPANCY
BUT WE CERTAINLY HAVE A
STAFFING DISCREPANCY. SO IF
THERE'S A WORKLOAD ISSUE IF WE
ARE ASKING CERTAIN MEMBERS IN
CERTAIN OFFICES TO DO THE SAME
AMOUNT OF WORK THAN OTHER
MEMBERS WITH SIGNIFICANTLY
LARGER STAFFS. THERE IS A
DISCREPANCY. AND I COULD. GIVE
ENTERED ARE YOU A PAY
DISCREPANCY AS WELL BUT YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M WHERE DO I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING I
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE I MEAN I
HANDLE. MY DISTRICT OFFICE I
DON'T AND WE DON'T EVEN TO THIS
NOW WITH MY DISTRICT OFFICES
HANDLE AS MANY COMPLAINTS ABOUT
EDT FROM THE REPUBLICANS IN MY
DISTRICT GRANTED THEY MIGHT BE
MORE UNDERSTAFFED BUT THE
WORKLOAD IS DIFFERENT IN
DIFFERENT OFFICES AND THAT IS
NOT BY ITSELF. A. F. A
VIOLATION OF ANY KIND OF. RIGHT
TO HAVE STAFF BUT I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IT'S JUST
THAT IT DOESN'T APPLY TO THIS.
PIECE OF INFORMATION THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ELICIT FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IN ORDER TO
DETERMINE. WHO WHO'S DOING A
GOOD JOB. SADLY A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WE DO AND IN THIS BUILDING
NEVER APPLIES TO US. I
UNDERSTAND BUT- THIS IS SEEKING
DATA THE DATA IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR. IS AVAILABLE HAS BEEN
AVAILABLE FOR QUITE SOME TIME
OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU LOOK THIS IS
ABOUT- FOR THE METRICS ABOUT
GETTING INFORMATION AND IN THE
PUBLIC OF MOBILE REGARDING.
AGAIN AS OUR STATE CONTROL
INDICATED THE METRICS THAT WERE
PUT TOGETHER WITH THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY THAT THEY ARE THAT
WOULD BE OVERLY BURDENSOME ON
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY BECAUSE
THESE ARE TYPICAL PIECES OF
INFORMATION THAT THEY ALREADY
COLLECT. I AND THAT THE IDEA IS
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY CREATE A HIGH ROAD
EMPLOYER PROGRAM THAT QUALIFIES
FOR INCENTIVES SO IT'S A WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. THE OF THE STATE
RESOURCES IF WE'RE GOING TO PUT
STATE RESOURCES- IN TO. YOU
KNOW PULL INTO ANY KIND OF-
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE WE MUST TO
CHANNEL THOSE RESOURCES TO HIGH
ROAD EMPLOYERS AND SO THIS
AGAIN IS THE WORD THAT CAME OUT
OF THE COMMISSION- THAT- IT IS
REALLY FOCUSED ON. GETTING THE
DATA THAT'S READILY AVAILABLE
FIRST OF AVAILABLE BEFORE WE
EVEN GO DOWN THE STEPS OF
CREATING A HIGH ROAD EMPLOYER
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS OF THIS IS
THE CRITICAL FOUNDATIONAL PIECE
FOR IT. THEN AGAIN WANT TO
THANK OUR STATE CONTROLLER
BETTY YEE AND HER TEAM WILL PUT
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK
INTO THIS AS WELL AS MY OWN
STAFF. AND OTHERS THAT HAVE
BEEN- PART OF THIS JOURNEY FIVE
MEN TO GET US HERE. ON BEHALF
OF A RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
GET THE GOVERNOR'S COMMISSION
THAT I SERVED ALONG WITH THE
STATE WAS TO CONTROL HE AND
DOUG BAKU SPOKEN OTHERS AND AS
WELL AS A NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF
THE BUSINESS CAN DO THAT WERE
ALSO ON THAT COMMISSION. SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK. YOU MISTER CHAIR I
AM LOOKING FOR A MOTION. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. THANK YOU I WILL
SECOND THAT SECOND OKAY THANK
YOU WE DO A MOTION BY MISTER
WARD AND SECOND BY MISS
GONZALEZ AND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS THANK
YOU. KALRA PLEASE. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA
FIVE KALRA HI FLORA FLORA NO
GONZALEZ RIGHT GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER STONE HI STONE I DON'T
KNOW DON'T KNOW WARD WARD I.
FELT THE BILL THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SUMMER STONE. THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES FOR THE DIALOGUE
ON THAT AND SO WE WILL MOVE
BACK UP IN ORDER- AND WE HAVE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE. OKAY
ITEM ELEVEN WHICH IS AB SIX
SIXTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AB SIX ONE SIX IS A
BILL THAT IS VERY TIMELY
BECAUSE IT PROVIDES AN OPTION
FOR FARMWORKERS TO CAST VOTES
IN SIMILAR WAYS THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED FOR THE STATE AND
THAT IS BY MAIL SO THERE ARE
TWO OPTIONS THAT COULD HAPPEN.
FOR FARMWORKERS. ORGANIZATIONAL
TYPE ELECTIONS AND THAT THE
CURRENT ONE IS MORE LIKE IN A
POLLING PLACES WE WOULD
UNDERSTAND IT AND THE SECOND
WOULD BE THE WHAT WE'RE
CREATING HERE IS AN OPERA BY. A
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT WE ARE
PROTECTING THE- SECURITY AND
THE SECRECY OF THE BALLOTS AS
WELL WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT
UNDER THIS CONTEXT. BUT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS ENSURE
THAT ALL THE FARMWORKERS HAVE
READY ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
CAST THAT BALLOT. AND WE'VE
LEARNED OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS THE EFFECTIVENESS OF MAIL
IN BALLOTS AND HOW THAT SYSTEM
WORKS AND HOW IT IS PROTECTIVE
OF THE RIGHT TO VOTE. AND
ENSURES A FAIR AND EQUITABLE
OUTCOME. SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE
PROPOSING THAT IN THIS CASE.
BECAUSE THIS IS A SOMETIMES A
DIFFICULT POPULATION TO REACH
ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE A FAIR
WAY TO BE ABLE TO VOTE WHETHER
TO THE POLLING PLACE OR BY THIS
BILL ALSO THE OPTION. OF DOING
VOTE BY MAIL. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO PROVIDE HERE SO THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES I DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES
TERESA ROMERO PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS. AND MARIO
MARTINEZ WHO IS AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IF A TO
THE TRANSFER AMERILA IS ON THE
PHONE SHE MAY BEGIN UP TO TWO
MINUTES AND WE ALSO HAVE A
MARIO MARTINEZ I BELIEVE
PROTECTING QUESTIONS AS
INDICATED BY. SUMMER STONE SO-
MAYBE I'M- YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON. AGAIN MY
NAME IS THAT IT SACRAMENTO AND
I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS. UNDER
THEIR CORPORATE LABOR RELATIONS
ACT WHICH WAS ENACTED INTO LAW
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE. FARM
WORKER UNION REPRESENTATION
ELECTIONS. ARE CONDUCTED THE
WAY POLITICAL ELECTIONS WERE
CONDUCTED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE. PERSON AT A PHYSICAL PART
IN PLACE. SINCE THEN THE WEIGHT
CALIFORNIA CONDUCTED ELECTIONS
PRODUCTS IT HAS EVOLVED AND
CHANGED IN ORDER TO INCREASE
PARTICIPATION. REGISTERING TO
VOTE IS. BIG TIME EVERYONE HAS
TO VOTE HAS INCREASED BORDERS
AND ALLOW SOME OUT SOMEONE ELSE
TO TURNING THEIR BALLOT IN
CALIFORNIA'S NEW VOTING CHOICE
ACT HAS CREATED OPTIONS FOR HOW
PEOPLE CAN CAST THEIR BALLOTS.
GOVERNING MUSEUM HAS STATE AND
I QUOTE I THINK MAKING VOTER
EACH YEAR PROVIDING MORE CHOICE
AND MORE OPPORTUNITY IT'S- AND
QUOTES WE'RE GRATEFUL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON EIGHTY SIX
ONE SIX. REPORTER LABOR
RELATIONS VOTING CHOICE ACT
REPORTS FARMWORKERS TIM MILLER
OPPORTUNITIES TO VOTE ARE IN
UNION REPRESENTATION ELECTIONS.
WELL BALLOTS WILL REMAIN SECRET
FARMWORKERS WILL HAVE A CHOICE
IN VOTING AT A PHYSICAL PUTTING
PLACE AS THEY DO NOW. OR THEY
CAN FILL. OUT THE PRESENTATION
BALLOT CARDS. HE DAVID DAVIS
TONYA FINDING CAN FEEL OUT THE
CARD THE PURSE QUITS. COSTS
SIGNIFICANT BALLOT CARD AND THE
BALLOT CARD IS RETURNED TO THE
AREA MIGHT BE IN A- FIELD IN
SIGNED INTO LAW. JUST AS WE'VE
DONE FROM ARE RIGHT NOW. FOR
OUR BORDERS ELECTING YOU.
SENATOR ALEX THE GIVEN YOU THE
CLIP. ALLEGES WHEN HE WAS
SECRETARY OF THE STATE AND HE
SUPPORTS THE EFFORT TO ALLOW
FARMWORKERS TO PARTICIPATE. IN
DECIDING THEIR FUTURES THREE
FOUR EIGHT NINE S. FORM A VOTE
SUPPRESSION. WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE IS
THE ONE HERE IN THE AUDIENCE
WILL GO TO THE PHONES RINGING
ON THE PHONES. IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SIX SIXTEEN SIX ONE SIX. YOU IF
YOU AREN'T SUPPORT OF AB SIX
ONE SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO
APPEARED SUPPORT. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF. TWO EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON GUSTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO ONE OF TWO
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU REEE BAYARDO WITH AT
THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FOR THANK
YOU WILL GET A LINE OF TWO
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
EXACTLY WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF THREE OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS SENDING CHAU WILLIAMS
AND I SUPPORT AB THROUGH THE
PRODUCT DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE THREE POINT.
MEXICO LINE OF TWO EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE HAVE
MATTHEW ALLEN AS WELL AS ASHLEY
HOFFMAN ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION SO IF YOU CAN BE
CHEEKY JAB UP TO TWO MINUTES
AND YOU MAY BEGIN- MATTHEW
ALLEN- GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MATTHEW ON WITH
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION. WE
ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AB-
SIX ONE SIX- THE PURPOSE AND
INTENT OF THE ADLAI RELATIONS
ACT IS TO GUARANTEE THAT
EMPLOYEES HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO EXPRESS FREE CHOICE WITH
RESPECT TO UNION REPRESENTATION
THROUGH. THE EXISTING SECRET
BALLOT ELECTIONS THAT HELD AT A
TIME AND PLACE CONVENIENT TO
THE EMPLOYEES AND IT IS UNDER
THE DIRECT SUPERVISION OF THE
AD LABOR RELATIONS. BOARD AB
SIX ONE SIX WATER ROAD THIS
GUARANTEE AND SEVERAL A
CRITICAL WAYS AND IT RAISES THE
RISK THAT UNION REPRESENTATION.
AND THE ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES
FROM PLACE TO BE REQUIRED TO
PAY DUES AND OBEY UNION RULES-
COULD BE IMPOSED. I WENT
EMPLOYEES I DO NOT WISH TO HAVE
UNION REPRESENTATION- SIGNING
AN OPERATION AUTHORIZATION COR
CARD- IS AN INDICATION OF
POSSIBLE INTEREST IN UNION
REPRESENTATION TRIGGERS A
PROCESS WHEREBY THE L. R. B.
CAN SUPERVISE A SECRET BALLOT
ELECTION. BUT IS NOT BY ANY
MEANS THAT- THE- DISCERNING OF
A DESIRE FOR THE UNION
REPRESENTATION AMONG THE
MEMBERS OF THE POSSIBLE
BARGAINING. DYSTER AND
COLLECTION OF THE SIGNED
AUTHORIZATION CARDS IS NOT
SUBJECT TO ANY MEANINGFUL
SUPERVISION OR SCRUTINY FROM
ANY AGENCY- THE DECISIONS AS AN
OPPOSITION CAR OR VOTE FOR
UNION REPRESENTATION IS NOT OF
EQUAL WEIGHT OR VALIDITY WHICH
IS EXACTLY WHY THE A. L. R. A.
HAS ENSURED. THAT SECRET ABOUT
ELECTIONS ARE THE EXCLUSIVE
MEANS FOR THE RECOMMENDATION OF
THE UNION. AND EMPLOYEE- IT'S
FREE TO VOTE THEIR CONSCIENCE
IN A SECRET BALLOT ELECTIONS
WHERE NEITHER THE EMPLOYER NOR
THE UNION- BOTH OF WHICH HAVE A
FINANCIAL INTEREST IN THE
OUTCOME- CAN INFLUENCE OR
OBSERVE- THEIR VOTE. I'D ALSO
JUST LIKE TO MENTION FINALLY
THAT THE BONDING REQUIREMENT
THAT'S PRESENT IN THE BILL ALSO
REPRESENTS A DIRECT THREAT TO.
EMPLOYERS DUE PROCESS RIGHTS-
AB SIX ONE SIX WOULD PLACE A
STEEP HURDLE IN FRONT EMPLOYER
WITH AN ESSENTIALLY STATE THAT
THE EMPLOYER IS NOT ALLOWED. TO
APPEAL OR EXERCISE THEIR DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS. I'M NOT THE
BOND IS POSTED IN AN AMOUNT AND
AT THE TERM AND BY THE
ENFORCING AGENCY. AGENCY AND
THAT IS THE L. R. B. R. THE
AYLER B. IS NOT A NEUTRAL PARTY
IN THIS CONTEXT AND IS AN
INHERENTLY PART PREJUDICIAL
INTEREST IN THE OUTCOME OF THE
APPEAL. IT IS FOR ALL THESE
REASONS AND MORE THAT WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- AND ASHLEY HOFFMAN.
THANK YOU. KERR MEMBERS
ACTUALLY HAPPEN- ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY SIX POINT SIX AS A JOB
KILLER. AND UNDOUBTEDLY BOTH
SIDES HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
POTENTIAL MISCONDUCT WHEN IT
COMES TO UNION ELECTION
CAMPAIGNS AND IT IS FOR THAT
REASON THAT THEY ARE B. AND L.
RB HAVE SPECIAL WILL BE
BASICALLY TO ELIMINATE LAST
MINUTE PRESSURE ELECTION
HEARING. IT FOR THAT REASON
THAT THE PEOPLE ABOUT PROFITS
HAS BEEN LONG SUPPORTED BY THE
NLRB AND OTHERS ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT IT IS TRULY THE MOST
ACCURATE REFLECTION OF AN
EMPLOYER. AND EMPLOYEE USED A
FIRE AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WANT TO UNIONIZE WE ARE AFRAID
THIS BILL WOULD ESSENTIALLY
DESTROY THOSE PROTECTIONS.
THERE ARE REPORTS OF COURSE IT
IS AND IF WE CAN CONDUCT THAT
OCCUR IN ELECTION CAMPAIGNS IN
DECISIONS BY THE A. R. B. AND
R. B. AND BY COURT. THAT
CONDUCT INCLUDES EMPLOYEES OR
UNION REPRESENTATIVES
PRESSURING EMPLOYEES TO SIGN
PETITION CARDS SAYING THEY
MIGHT LOSE THEIR JOB. OTHER
DOCUMENTED CONDUCT INCLUDES
MISINFORMATION SUCH DISTURBING
WRITTEN MATERIAL- WITH CALLS
THAT WERE NEVER STATED BY OTHER
EMPLOYEES OR WITHOUT EMPLOYEES
NOTICED THAT THEIR NAMES ARE
BEING PLACED ON A FIRE. EVEN
JUST PUTTING THAT MORE SERIOUS
KIND OF THE SITE IS ALSO JUST
NATURALLY MORE DIFFICULT TO
TAKE A POSITION CONTRARY TO THE
PERSON STANDING BEFORE YOU
ACTUALLY NEED TO FIND A CARD
THAT THEY FILLED OUT FOR YOU.
SHE WAS NOT PERSON MAYBE A CO
WORKER SOMEONE POSITION OF
POWER. THE SECRET BALLOT
INSURANCE EMPLOYEE HAS THE
ABILITY TO CAPTURE BUT WITHOUT
THAT SAME PRESSURE AND GIVE
THEM THE- ABILITY TO KEEP
THEIR- SECRET IF THEY SO WISH.
AND IF THIS NEW PROCEDURE IS
TRULY BETTER IT'S UNCLEAR WHY
THE BILL WOULD NOT PROVIDE
MEETING PROCEDURE WHEN IT COMES
TO. DECERTIFYING UNION- THE
RETALIATION PRESUMPTION IS ALSO
CONCERNING TO OUR MEMBERS THE
BILL HAS A PRESUMPTION OF
RETALIATION WHERE AN EMPLOYER
DISCIPLINES ARE TERMINATE AN
EMPLOYEE DURING A BALLOT CARD
CAMPAIGN. AND FUNDING OF AN
ADVERSE EMPLOYMENT ACTION IS
ALREADY TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION IN RETALIATION
CLAIM. FURTHER AT THIS
PRODUCTION EFFECTIVELY
UNLIMITED AT THE TIME I
CAMPAIGN COULD CONCEIVABLY GO
ON FOR MONTHS AND INDEED THE
BALLOT CARD AND THAT THE STATE
WOULD BE VALID FOR AN ENTIRE
YEAR. TO BASICALLY ANY.
DISCIPLINARY ACTION TAKEN BY AN
EMPLOYEE DURING THAT WOULD FALL
UNDER THIS. THAT AN EMPLOYER
HAVE TO OVERCOME BY CONDEMN. IN
OVERWHELMING. WHICH IS AN EXTRA.
HIGH BRINGS. AN EMPLOYMENT.
EMPLOYERS SHOULD HAVE TO. THE
FOR TWO YOU SIMPLE. FOR EVERY
PERSON TAX. TAKEN DURING A
GIVEN YEAR. I FOR THE REASONS
WE OPPOSE SB SIX ONE SIX. THANK
THANK YOU IS THERE A- ONE IN
THE MORNING ROOM NOT- GO TO THE
PHONE. ANYWHERE ON THE PHONE
AND OPPOSITE. TO ABC ONE SO.
THANK YOU IF YOU'RE NOT.OF
EIGHT. SIX ONE SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO TO LINE UP TO EIGHTY
THEY DROPPED OUT THIS ONE TIME
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOUR GO TO
LINE THREE ALL THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS KATIE
HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY APPROACHED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BOOK ONLINE OF
TWO EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MUGSHOT THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT I APOLOGIZE I WAS NOT
ABLE TO GET INTO THE- PORT.
EARLIER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WHAT KIND OF THREE TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BUT YOU CARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE REALLY
BROWN CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF
THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS THE
GROWER SHIPPER CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL. MARSILLI CALIFORNIA
CONDOR CESSATION AND THE
WESTERN ACT PROFITS
JUSTIFICATION ALL IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
ONE OF THREE SEVENTEEN- THREE
FIFTEEN I'M SORRY THREE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MICHAEL
MILLER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF WINE GRAPE
GROWERS EXPECT OPPOSITION TO AB
SIX SIXTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE OF
THREE THIRTEEN. HE LORD GAME
WILL BE AT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY SO IF
YOU IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE OF THREE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
KAREN MEMBERS HASN'T TURNED OUR
WITH AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
BRIAN LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR HERE ISN'T ON THE TABLE
DOES ANYONE. HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SOME OF HIS HOUSE. I
WAS JUST THINKING AM PROUD TO
BE A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR THIS
IT'S IMPORTANT POINT BILL AT
JUST TO PROVIDE YOU KNOW THE
MOST CONVENIENT AND SAFE WAY
FOR PEOPLE TO EXPRESS THEIR
VIEWS BUT IT'S STRANGE TO HEAR
THE KIND OF- THE WARNINGS I
SUPPOSE BY THE OPPOSITION
BECAUSE JUST THIS MORNING I WAS
THINKING ABOUT THIS MY- THE
NINETEEN SCHOOLS. IN MY- MY
CHILDREN'S CHARTER SCHOOL
COLLABORATIVE- YOU KNOW DURING
THE PANDEMIC THAT THE TEACHERS-
ON THEIR OWN THE EMPLOYEES WENT
AND GOT SIGNATURES TO FILE A
PETITION. IN BECAUSE THE RULES
AND PER WHICH IS ALSO
CALIFORNIA RELATED THING THEY
WILL GET UNION RECOGNITION
FROM. SIMPLY TURNING IN A
PETITION WITH YOU KNOW.
EMPLOYEES AT WHO WANT TO JOIN
THE UNION AND WE BELIEVE THAT
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES ESPECIALLY
TEACHERS HOSPITAL EMPLOYEES
THAT THAT IS SUFFICIENT- AND
YET SOMEHOW. THIS IS ACTUALLY
MORE STRINGENT RUBIO THAT IS
WHAT IT WOULD STILL BE
HAPPENING UNDER THE L. R. B.
SOMEHOW IS NOT- I. I THINK THAT
INADEQUATE I THINK THOSE
INEQUITIES THERE ARE STRIKING
AND ONE OF THE REASONS PROBABLY
WE HAVEN'T SEEN- SUCH AS-
BARRIERS TO POOR MEAN- FOR
WORKERS TO FEEL SAFE FORMING A
UNION AND AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY
SELF THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I THINK THIS THIS
MAKES SENSE WITH VOTE BY MAIL
WE DO THIS OFTEN YOU CAN HAVE
SOMEBODY HELP YOU DO IT AND IT
MAKES SENSE THAT THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO IT FORMALLY. AS THE
UNION AS WELL. THANK THANK YOU
THE BILL THE SOMERSET SIR AND
I'M GOING TO TAKE OUT ALL THE
STUFF WE'VE HEARD AND GO
STRAIGHT TO KIND OF PRACTICAL
EVERYDAY THING I WAS A MEMBER
OF A UNION FOR MANY MANY YEARS
ONE OF THE BEST UNIONS IN THE
STATE. AND WE ALWAYS GOT OUR
BALLOTS WE ALWAYS VOTED. AND
FRANKLY AS A SUPERVISOR AT
TIMES AND THERE WAS STILL
BECAUSE WE WERE UNION UP UNTIL
WE'RE BATTALION CHIEF. AND AS A
SUPERVISOR IN CAPTAIN. FRANKLY
I WOULDN'T WANT TO KNOW IF THE
GUY NEXT TO ME IT WASN'T.
DIDN'T VOTE FOR BEING IN A
UNION OR NOT- AND THE REASON
FOR THAT IS BECAUSE THERE IS
GOING TO BE A BIAS. IF YOU
BELIEVE IN THE UNION AND
SOMEBODY NEXT TO YOU. WAS
PARTICIPATING IN A IN A BALLOT
THAT WE KNEW WHAT HE DID. AND
NOT ONLY THAT BAD FOR HIM. BUT
THAT'S BAD FOR US TO. AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S WRONG WITH
THE CURRENT PROCESS. IT HAS
ALWAYS SEEMED TO WORK
ESPECIALLY FOR UNIONS BECAUSE
YOU HAVE A CONTROL GROUP THIS
ISN'T LIKE THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA IS A CONTROLLED GROUP.
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO. GET A
BALLOT IN PHILADELPHIA WITHOUT
SOMEBODY STANDING IN FRONT OF
THEM. WATCHING WHAT'S GOING ON
OR GIVING THEM A PRE FILLED
BALANCING HEY MAKE SURE YOU
SIGN THIS BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING
TO. NO MATTER HOW THEY FEEL.
AND IT FOR UNIONS GOOD ENOUGH.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
IT EVERYBODY'S GOING TO SIGN UP.
BUT MAYBE THAT'S A THEIR REPORT
CARD AND THANK YOU FOR. BUT
MAYBE THAT'S THEIR REPORT CARD.
IS IF THEY IF THEY HAVE THEIR
BALLOT FOR UNIONIZING AND IT
ISN'T THERE YET. MAYBE THEY
NEED TO DO MORE TO BE ABLE TO
GET PEOPLE ON BOARD. BUT I
DON'T THINK CREATING A COERCIVE
ENVIRONMENT FOR PEOPLE. IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF ANY WORKER.
SO THAT'S WHY I'M OPPOSED TO.
THANK YOU. A SUMMER WAR DIGITAL.
I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR- DOING
THIS BILL I RECOGNIZE IT'S A
STRAIGHTFORWARD OBVIOUS AND NOT
IMPORTANT AND HAPPY THAT A CO
AUTHOR OF THERE'S STILL
OPPORTUNITY ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO HAVE. OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A RESULT
I'M ALSO. PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS. BILL I THINK
THAT- AS WE'VE SEEN. OF IT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE MAIL IN
BALLOTS. AS WELL AS THE NATURE
OF THE WORK THAT OUR CULTURAL
WORKERS I THINK THAT- THIS
ADDS- IF YOU CAN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT TO ENSURE THAT.
ELECTIONS ARE FREE AND FAIR AND
ACCESSIBLE TO EVERYONE AND SO
WITH THAT- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I WOULD THANK YOU I I'M
A LITTLE ASTONISHED AT THE
OPPOSITION CREATING THIS THIS
SPECTER. THAT WHAT THIS
REPRESENTS IS SOMETHING LIKE
SOMEONE WHO IS GOING TO BE
HANDING A PRE FILLED OUT
BALLOT. OR STANDING IN FRONT OF
SOMEONE THIS IS JUST LIKE OUR
BALLOTS. THIS WOULD CREATE A
PROCESS WHERE SOMEONE CAN GO TO
A POLLING PLACE AS WE DO
NORMALLY OR OR AS IS EXISTENCE
UNDER THE CURRENT CODE. FOR ASK
FOR A MAIL IN BALLOT THAT WOULD
BE MAILED TO THEM THAT THEY
FILL IT OUT AND SEND IT BACK IN.
WE HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS THAT IF SOMEONE IS
HAS ASSISTING. THE INDIVIDUAL
CASTING THE BALLOT THAT THEY-
INDICATE THAT ON THE BALLOT TO
SO THAT WE KNOW SOMEONE WAS
ASSISTING. BUT WHY THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THAT GUARANTEES
THAT SOMEONE IS GOING TO SAY A
FOLKS STANDING OVER. AN
INDIVIDUAL SAYING THIS IS HOW
YOU'RE SIGNING IT I'M FILLING
YOUR BALLOT OUT IS JUST A
LITTLE BIT. BEYOND THE PALE.
BECAUSE NOBODY DOES THAT WHEN I
VOTE. I RECEIVE A BALLOT IN THE
MAIL AND I SENT IT AND WERE
USED TO THAT AND WE HAVE.
GOTTEN A LOT MORE COMFORTABLE
WITH THE MAIL IN BALLOT PROCESS
WE'RE JUST CREATING A PROCESS
HERE. THAT INDIVIDUAL. FOR A
UNION ELECTION COULD ASK TO
RECEIVE A MAIL BALLOT AND THEN
MAIL IT IN. TO THE- A RP. WHO
HAVE OBLIGATIONS AND THIS BILL
TO KEEP IT SECRET. SO THE
SECRECY PROVISIONS STILL APPLY
THERE'S NOTHING THAT'S GOING TO
BE LEAKED THERE'S NOTHING THAT
THAT THAT IS GOING TO. TO
BREACH THAT OBLIGATION BECAUSE
WE DO UNDERSTAND AND RESPECT
THE FACT THAT THESE ARE SECRET
BALLOTS. WHO SO. THE LETTER
HYPERBOLE AROUND THIS IT'S A
SIMPLE PROCESS I ASKED HER
ABOUT. THANK YOU SO MUCH- MADAM
SECRETARY WE ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION FROM SOME OF HIS ALSO
PROVIDES A MEMBER AWARDS PLEASE.
IT WILL CALL THE ROLL ON AB SIX
SIXTEEN. OCEAN OF THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA HI KALRA
AYE FLORA FLORA NOW BEEN SALAS
HI GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER
STONE HI STONE ICE ZERO NO
BETTER KNOWN WARD. WARD I. WHAT
THE BILL'S OUT THANK YOU. MR
WITH WAREHOUSES THAT THAT'S
OKAY BECAUSE I HAVE SOMEBODY
WAITING FOR THE- I THINK THE
REST OF THE AFTERNOON IS THERE.
GONZALEZ CALL RATIO. AND SO
WE'LL START TO WITH THE CENTRE
GONZALEZ I BELIEVE AB SEVEN OH
ONE IS WHAT SHE IS GOING OFF TO
START WITH IT WHICH IS FINE.
THAT'S FILE ITEM THIRTEEN.
THESE ROOMS ARE COLD. THAT HE
COULD HAVE THINK IT THOUGH THE
GENTLEMAN. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
START WITH AB SEVEN A ONE- SO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO MAKE
NEXT DOOR NEXT DAY DELIVERY
POSSIBLE CORPORATIONS LIKE
AMAZON AND WALMART HAVE
STRETCHED THEIR WAREHOUSE
WORKERS THAN BY FORCING THEM TO
WORK FASTER TO SERVICE MORE
CUSTOMERS WITH MORE ORDERS IN
RECORD AMOUNTS OF TIME. THE
COMPANY'S OBSESSION WITH
CONVENIENCE HAS COME AT THE
EXPENSE OF WORKERS PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH IT'S TIME WE CAN
FOR THE TRUTH THE WORKERS WHOSE
LABOR MAKES THIS CONVENIENCE
POSSIBLE. RECORDS HAVE SHOWN
AMAZON WORKERS ARE INJURED AT
THE JOB TWICE THE AVERAGE RATE
OF OTHER WAREHOUSE IN INDUSTRY
AND THREE TIMES THE AVERAGE
RATE ACROSS ALL PRIVATE SECTOR
EMPLOYERS. THESE COMPANIES HAVE
CREATED ENVIRONMENT WHERE
WORKERS ARE TREATED LIKE
MACHINE SUBJECT TO CONSTANT
SURVEILLANCE MANAGE THEIR
ALGORITHMS EVERY DAY THEY FACE
CRUSHING WORK SPEEDS TO MEET
RELENTLESS PRODUCTIVITY QUOTAS
THAT CAN CHANGE WITHOUT ANY
NOTICE THEIR TIME MOVEMENTS AND
HOW QUICKLY THEY CAN PACKAGE IT
TIMES UP TO FOUR HUNDRED ITEMS
IN AN HOUR IT'S STRICTLY
TRACKED. MINUTES BETWEEN
SCANNING PACKAGES WHERE THE
SYSTEM DETECTS THE WORKERS OFF
TASK CAN RESULT IN AUTOMATIC
DISCIPLINE OR EVEN TERMINATION.
NO WORKER SHOULD HAVE TO ACCEPT
SUCH UNDIGNIFIED CONDITIONS FOR
PAYCHECK WE SHOULD HAVE TO
SPECIFY IN LAW THAT WORKERS
HAVE A RIGHT TO USE BATHROOM
INSTEAD OF URINATING A WATER
BOTTLE OR THAT THEY HAVE A
RIGHT TO WASH THEIR HANDS AND
SANITIZER CLEMENT DURING A
PANDEMIC AND FORTUNATELY
STORIES OF COUNTLESS WAREHOUSE
WORKERS HAVE MADE IT CLEAR WE
DO HAVE TO ACTUALLY DO THAT.%
WORKERS HAVE REPEATEDLY GOTTEN
INJURED ON THE JOB BECAUSE THEY
WERE FORCED TO RUSH THROUGH
SAFETY PROTOCOLS TO TRY TO.
MEET RATE YET MOST CNNOT SPEAK
OUT FOR FEAR OF LOSING THEIR
JOB AB SEVEN A ONE WOULD MAKE
IT CLEAR WORKERS COULD NOT BE
DISCIPLINED FOR FAILING TO MEET
A QUOTA THAT DIDN'T ALLOW THEM
TO COMPLY WITH EXISTING HEALTH
AND SAFETY LAWS. THAT
COMPLIANCE TIME COULD NOT BE
COUNTED AGAINST THEM AS BEING
OFF TASK IF A WORKER FACES
DISCIPLINE WITHIN NINETY DAYS
AFTER THEY COMPLAINED ABOUT A
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERN TO
THEIR EMPLOYER OR STATE AGENCY
THAT AB SEVEN OH ONE WOULD
CREATE A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION. THAT THE ADVERSE
ACTION TAKEN BY THE COMPANY
WITH RETALIATORY ONCE A
COMPLAINT IS FILED THE BILL
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE- CAL OSHA TO
NOTIFY. WORKERS A GIVEN
WORKSITE. OF THEIR RIGHTS TO
REPORT UNSAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS TO SEE IF THERE IS A
PATTERN. FINALLY A. B. SEVEN OH
ONE CREATES MUCH NEEDED
TRANSPARENCY REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING THE BASIC EXPECTATION
THAT AFRAID WAREHOUSE OPERATES
WITH A PRIVATE. PRODUCTION
QUOTA. THAT THEY NEED TO TELL
THEIR WORKERS WITH THE QUOTA IS
IN WHEN IT CHANGES. IN ADDITION
TO ANY VERSE ACTIONS THAT COULD
FACE FOR FAILING TO MEET THE
QUOTA I WANT TO BE CLEAR HERE
WE ARE NOT SAYING THAT THERE
CANNOT BE A PRODUCTION QUOTA.
WE'RE SAYING THE WORKER HAS TO
UNDERSTAND THE COURT THE
PRODUCTION QUOTA TRANSPARENCY
IF IT SHOULD CHANGE. AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE TO NOT MEET IT.
UNDER THE BILL EMPLOYERS CANNOT
FIRE RETALIATES AGAINST
EMPLOYEES FOR FAILING TO MEET A
QUOTA THAT THEY DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT. IF THEY KNEW ABOUT THE
QUOTA. AND KNEW ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES HOWEVER THEY COULD
STILL BE FIRED. ULTIMATELY AB
SEVEN NO ONE WOULD ALSO ALLOW
STATE AGENCIES TO ACCESS THESE
WAREHOUSE QUOTA RECORDS AND
DIRECT CAL OSHA TO THEN CREATE
A WAREHOUSE SAFETY STANDARD.
THAT MINIMIZES WORKER INJURIES
AND WAREHOUSES THAT USE
PRODUCTION QUOTAS. THIS IS NEW
IT'S SOMEWHAT COMPLICATED BUT
IT IS TIME AND NECESSARY THAT
WE ACT ON THIS I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE FOR
BRIEF TESTIMONY STARTING WITH
RICK ROSE MARIE MOLINA WITH LA
COUNTY FEDERATION OF LABOR.
THANK YOU SO THANK YOU SO MUCH-
WILL ASK THE WITNESSES NOW ROSE
MARIE MOLINA FOLLOWED BY THE
SENATE BHARARA UP TO TWO
MINUTES A ROSARY IF YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY BEGIN. YOU SO
MUCH CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. THANK
YOU HI MY NAME IS ROSE MARIE
MOLINA AND I'M WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR WE REPRESENT OVER THREE
HUNDRED UNION FOR THE LA AREA
AND WE'RE SPONSORING AB SEVEN
ALONG AT SEVEN OH ONE ALONG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL AND
WAREHOUSE WORKER
RESTRICTIONISTS ARE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND WAREHOUSE
WORKERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THIS NUMBER IS
INCREASING BECAUSE OF ON DEMAND
DELIVERY. AMAZON IN THE
WAREHOUSING GIANT AND MORE
COMPANIES ARE COMPETING WITH
AMAZON TO PROMISED ONE DAY
DELIVERY IN OUR EGION AND
SOMETIMES EVEN TWO HOURS WHAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IS THE
COST OF THE CONVENIENCE ACROSS
INDUSTRY. WAREHOUSE WORKERS
FACE WIDESPREAD INJURED
INJURIES CONSTANT SURVEILLANCE
AND PACE OF WORK STANDARDS THAT
ARE INHERENTLY DANGEROUS EIGHTY
SEVEN OH ONE PROVIDES MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND SAFETY
PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS IN THE
INDUSTRY ARE REQUIRING WORKERS
AND EMPLOYERS I'M VERY
EMPLOYERS TO THE CONCORD.
ADVOCATE THE WORK STANDARDS. WE
SPOKEN TO NUMEROUS. WHO HAVE
BEEN IN TRYING TO UP WITH PACE
OF. ONE YOUNG FROM PAIRS OF I
THOUGHT TO WAS NOT FOR HOW
PACKAGE PER HOUR. THAT SEVEN
TAX PER MINUTE A PACKAGE AND
ELEVEN. AND PEOPLE KEEP UP WITH
THIS THAT TEN OUR AT A TIME.
AND THE WOMAN I SPOKE TO TORN
LIGAMENT IN HER KNEE TRYING TO
KEEP UP WITH THE PACE. AND
BEFORE SHE WAS INJURED SHOULD
BE HARASSED BY THE MANAGERS TO
WORK FASTER. WHEN SHE ASKED HIM
IF SHE SHOULD WORK FASTER.
SAFER HE TOLD HER TO FIGURE IT
OUT. MONDAY MY OR- BROUGHT.
WORKS BY. TO THE- OF THE
CAPITOL. HE SAID OF THE WHITE.
DEMONSTRATION AFTER DECIDED TO
WORK IN ASSEMBLY LINE AT THE
PACE OF WORK THAT THE WORKERS.
FOUR HUNDRED PACKAGE PACKAGES
IN OUR- I COULD GO TO JUSTIFY
EVEN LIKE THE FACT THAT ON THE
BOND ON RECORDS SHOW THAT ITS
WORKERS ARE INJURED ON THE JOB.
AT MORE THAN DOUBLE THE AVERAGE
RATE OF GENERAL WAREHOUSING.
BUT WE THOUGHT IT WAS BETTER TO
SHOW FOLKS- THE AMAZON WORKERS
ARE MORE FREQUENTLY INJURED
THAN. MOST OTHER WORKERS STATE
REGULATORS COULD FEEL THE CALL
OF THIS WORK ON THEIR BODIES.
IF THEY CAN SEE HOW THEIR
BODIES HAVE TO RECALIBRATE
QUICKLY TO MOVE PACKAGES AT
DIFFERENT WAIT. MAYBE THEY
WOULD BE ASKING. THE STATE FOR
STANDARDS TO. WE BELIEVE THAT
THE- SHOULD KEEP UP WITH DEMAND.
FOR I THINK ABOUT IT. CAN BE
STATE. YOU KNOW IT CAN BE DONE
SAFELY HIGH. THE THIS AN ACTIVE.
SUCH AS THE- OF THIS. DAY AND
WE FOR BELIEVE. THAT WORK
SHOULD IT. WE FEEL WITH OF
CALIFORNIA AN OBLIGATION TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR INDUSTRY
VERY EFFICIENT PRODUCTIVE BUT
OFF OF BATES. AND THAT EIGHTY
SEVEN I WON THE STATE'S
OBLIGATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. YES I KNOW BOROUGH. I DO
NOT SEE HIM ON THE LINE BUT IF
YOU ARE ON THE LINE YOU CAN
PRESS STAR ZERO AND I WILL OPEN
YOUR LINE. YES SANTA BARBARA.
FRUM'S BREZOVICA OKAY SO IF IT
WILL THE FIRM IF ISRAEL GETS ON
THE LINE WILL ALLOW HER TO- TO
SPEAK BUT FOR RIGHT NOW WHILE
WE GO AHEAD AND GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN OH ONE AND THE BEFORE
WE MOVE ON FROM THAT WE'LL SEE
IF SHE GETS SOMEONE SO SB SEVEN
A ONE IN SUPPORT. THE NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION PLEASE.
YOUR PARENTS SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN OH ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND WE ABOUT THE
LINE OF THREE TWENTY FOUR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN A MEMBER SHANE
DUSTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THE BILL ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF TWO EIGHTY ONE. YOUR
LINES OPEN. RATHER ON BEHALF IN
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER OPENED WHAT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND IT'S NEXT PHOTO
ONE OF THREE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BERNAY BAYARDO AT
THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ACROSS THE LINE OF THREE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SPORTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
ACROSS THE LINE OF THREE THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTINE VALMONT
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK IN
MEXICO TO LINE OF. THREE THANK
THREE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HI MY NAME IS EVELYN
BULLARD AND I WORKED FOR A LONG
FROM HOLDEN. AND I'M- CALLING
FOR A STRONG FOR A. FIFTY
SEVEN. RECOVERY OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE'RE ON BILL AB
SEVEN OH ONE IN SUPPORT. THANKS
TO GO TO LINE OF TWO EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MARK
SHOCKED THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OVER TO LINE OF THREE
FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THE WASTE OUR TIME WITH
WORKING PARTNERSHIPS IN SAN
JOSE AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF TWO
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR
CHAIR. TWO SEVEN OF THE HUNG UP
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTING
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU-
WE WILL THEN MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION OLIVIA IS YOUR SON
EVER WE HAVE TO GET ONLINE. IF
YOU ARE ON A- GO AHEAD PLEASE.
RIGHT HELLO MY NAME IS THE
THING ABOUT IT I'M I'M I'M A
MOTHER WHO LIVES IN THE AND THE
EMPIRE AND THE FORMER WORKER
AND I'M OF OPPORTUNITY. AMAZON
WAS ONE OF THE MOST STRESSFUL
JOBS I'VE HAD IN MY LIFE. I'M A
CO WORKERS HAVE BEEN A TO TEN
HOUR DAYS FOR FIVE DAYS A WEEK
AND THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE
MANDATORY. OVERTIME WEEKEND ON
HOLIDAYS WILL SPEAK. OUR
NETWORK IS FOR THAN PARTIAL
BODY I THINK. IT FIRST HAND IN
MY TIME THERE- WE ARE CARING
SENDING REACHING TWENTY MILLION
PACKINGITEMS FROM. THIRTY TO
SIXTY CALLING HOURS. WALK
FIFTEEN TO THIRTY MILES A DAY
WITH NO PROPER REST TIME IN
BETWEEN- I WAS A SEASONAL
EMPLOYEE I WORK HARD TO BE ABLE
TO. CONVERT TO A PERMANENT FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES- AT THE RIALTO
FULFILLMENT CENTER- WHEN THERE
WAS APPROACH BY MY MANAGER
BECAUSE- THE MONITORING SYSTEM.
I WASN'T PRODUCTIVE ENOUGH THAT
THEY- I RECEIVED IT RIGHT UP
AND WHEN I CAME BACK TO WORK
FOR MY NEXT SCHEDULED. TO SHIP
MY BADGE TO. THE ALGORITHMS ME.
AND WORK. CHECK BY EVEN THOUGH
WERE ALL WORKING AT AS WE.
AMAZON HAS ENTERED A AND MORE
TURN SYSTEM KEEPS TRACK OF THE
WORK PARTY COMPANY I THE
COMPACT FIRST. PER HOUR. EVEN
INFORM MANAGER ONE WORKER HAD
NOT OF THE BOXER COUPLE OF
MINUTES. INVESTORS IF YOU RID
ENOUGH FOR LET GO. THIS CALL IS
NOT THE WORK TO WORK. BUT THE
COST OF THE BY. WHAT AT WORK
END OF DAY YOU KNOW ENTRY IN
THE- MACHINE SHOULDERS. AND
BUILDERS STRAINS TEARS OR
ANYTHING GIVEN TO THE OF COURSE.
WE WENT SHOPPING DAY UNTIL JOB
WORKER BUT WE CAN STILL GET
FIRED BECAUSE THE FIRST. I WILL
FELT THE STRESS OF HAVING TO
WORK. EVEN IGNORE MY OWN. NEEDS
SUCH AS- GOING TO THE REST ARE
GETTING. BE I DIDN'T TO BE
READY UP FOR ALL ETERNITY THE-
WE ARE NOT ROBOTS. YOUR HUMAN.
SEVEN A ONE WORD HELP SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS IT WOULD HELP FOR
LIKE ME THEY SAY AND OFFER
PEOPLE TO KEEP OUR JOBS AND FOR
FAMILIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND THANK HAVE BEEN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- SO THAT CAN CAUSE
SUPPORT SYSTEM AND CALLING SO
WE'LL GO TO OP ASSEMBLY ROBERT
MOVED. IS ON THE AND SERVE YOUR
ON YOU MAY BEGIN. YES MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU AND MEMBERS-
RUBBER TREE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE- AND WE ARE OPPOSED
TO AB DE IN A ONE DAY JOB
SELLER- I SHOULD NOTE THAT THAT
IT WOULD PUBLICLY DEDICATED
JUST YESTERDAY SO- POLICY
THREAT INFORMATION THAT NEEDED
ONE BUT I BELIEVE EVERYONE
SHOULD I WANT TO MAKE IT WORK
OUT FOR THE CUT- AB THAT'LL
MAKE THE HOST OF CHANGES TO
OFFER ANYWHERE HOW THE- AS- I
THINK THE AUTHOR. CORRECTLY
THAT THERE'S A LOT HERE
COMPLICATED- OUR STUDY CONCERT
INCLUDE A NEW PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION NEW PARKING ENFORCEMENT
NEW NOTICE REQUIREMENTS THE
DISCIPLINARY REQUIREMENTS. AND
TO NEW REGULATIONS RELATED TO
WORK'S BEEN WAREHOUSE THAT ONCE
LABOR COMMISSIONER AND ANOTHER
ONE HELLO SURE. AND IN ADDITION
WE HAVE A PRESUMPTION THE
RETALIATION OR WE COULD DO IT
DAY TO DAY ACTIVITIES THAT
WOULD RESULT IN A- CAN
CONSTANT- PROVOKE THAT HAVE
DELEGATION. I'LL GET THE
THOUGHT THAT BEFORE I TURNED IT
UP WE THOUGHT WOULD BE CLEAR
THIS BILL IS NOT LIMITED TO ANY
ONE EMPLOYER ONE SITUATION THAT
COVERS ALL WAREHOUSE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA YOU CAN LOOK AT THE
ENACT YET THE BILL FOR THAT.
AND THAT'S WHY YOU SEE A KIND
OF BROAD COALITION OF CONCERN
ON.OUR SITE- I TO BRIEFLY
TOUCH THE- THAT SOME SHOULD THE
BILL WHICH IS THE USE OF METRIC
FOR PRODUCT. WOULD YOUR
PREFERRED QUOTA ARE IN. AND
ALSO TO MOST WAREHOUSES. ON
THAT. EVER TO THE CONCLUSION.
BECAUSE PRO. HOW BEEN. THAT
WHAT IS THAT EIGHT. HOW
PERFORMANCE OF AN AVERAGE
EMPLOYEE IT'S NOT AN ARBITRARY
NUMBER THAT. FITS WHAT IS
ACHIEVABLE WHAT BEEN DONE IN
THE PAST THAT'S WHAT WE USE-
TURNING TO THOSE SPECIFIC
PROVISIONS- SO THE FIRST THE
PART RIGHT ACTION PAGO WE HAVE
CONCERNS WILL CERTAINLY LEAD TO
LITIGATION BECAUSE- EIGHTY
SEVEN OF ONE INCLUDES A RATHER
BIG STANDARD. THAT ALL.
WORKPLACE METRICS MUCH QUOTE
LEAVE TIME FOR EMPLOYEES TO
COMPLY WITH HEALTH AND SAFETY
LAWS. AND THAT BIG REQUIREMENTS
LEAVE TIME FOR EVERYTHING TO DO
WITH HEALTH AND SAFETY WE
THINK. IT'S HAVING A BIG ENOUGH
IT'LL BE HARD TO FIGHT ABOUT IT
WILL BE TO THE GAUGE OF CURRENT
PLAYERS EVEN WHEN THEY PROPERLY
DID THE PLAN INTO PLACE-
TURNING WE ALSO HAVE A- THE
ISSUE OF A NEVER ENDING PERCENT
RETALIATION. IF YOU DON'T WANT
TO PROVIDE THEIR PRODUCTION
RETALIATES I COULD BE A
PRESUMPTION OF RETALIATION.
AFTER NINETY DAYS WHATEVER
EMPLOYEE REQUEST DATA ON THEIR
PATCHWORK SPEAK. SO ALL YOU DO
IS EVERY THREE MONTHS. HEY CAN
YOU GIVE ME AN UPDATE ON OUR
PROGRESS IT. AND I WILL HAVE A
PERENNIAL- A PRESUMPTION OF
RETALIATION. FOR ANY DISCIPLINE
GET. I OTHER NOW I BELIEVE THE
OPERATE TEN THE FACT THAT BUT-
ANOTHER NO ABOUT THE RUNNING
BACK. WHICH I WANT TO. HERE IS
THAT PRESENTLY THE RIGHT ABOUT
PROVIDE FOR. FEES TO BE
RECOVERED. REGARD OF WHETHER
THE ACT IS MERIT. EVEN IF YOU
BRING THEM PRINT TO. YOU HAVE
THE RIGHT TO RECOVER ITS FEES
WHICH- IS UNPRECEDENTED FAR AS
WE KNOW IN. PROVISIONS IN LAW-
AT THE TO REGULATION SHOWING
THE FLAG. THIS BILL CALLS FOR
REGULATION OF THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER AND ALSO FROM CAL
OSHA BOTH FOCUSED ON
WAREHOUSES- AND PATHETICALLY BE
CALIFORNIA'S RECALL THAT
MUSCULOSKELETAL INJURIES- I'D
LIKE TO MAKE THE POINT THAT.
HELLO. CHAU ALREADY HOW THE
REGULATION. THE MOTION INJURY
STANDARD SECTION FIFTY ONE TEN.
THAT CALL THAT MUSCULOSKELETAL
INJURIES AND TOUCHES THAT SO I
DON'T THINK IT WOULD BE
CREATING DUPLICATIVE AND
POTENTIALLY CONFLICTING
REGULATIONS THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE ONE ON THAT- IN TERMS OF.
HOW TO CHECK THIS ISSUE AT THAT
THE CONCERN. BOB THERE'S ALSO A
HOST OF NOTICE REQUIREMENTS FOR
PURPOSE THE TIME IN LIGHT OF
THE LINK THAT THE HEARING THAT
THE COMMITTEE HAD IN FRONT OF
IT. I WILL NOT GO THROUGH THE-
BUT THEY THEY OFF THAT
LOGISTICAL CONCERNS SUPPORT IN
TERMS THAT THE VILLAGE DO. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AB SEVEN
OH ONE AT THE JOB KILLER AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOR THE
ROOMS WILL GO TO THE PHONES IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVEN OH ONE ON THE PHONES.
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
YEAH. IF THEY'RE NOT POSITION
OF SEVEN ZERO ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF THREE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BY THREE FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ABOUT
THE LINE OF THE THREE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
AND MISTER CHEN MEMBERS I
POLITICS KEEP AND THEY GET
REPRESENTING THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF TEAMSTERS PORT
DIVISION AND UNITE HERE LOCAL
ELEVEN WE ARE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT I APOLOGIZE I WASN'T
CALLED ON DURING THE SUPPORT
PORTION. AND ALSO THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS ACCESS TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
TEAMSTERS LOCAL THREE NINETY
SIX WAREHOUSE WORKERS RESOURCE
CENTER SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH CENTRAL COAST
ALLIANCE UNITED FOR A
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY CENTER ON
POLICY INITIATIVES SAN DIEGO
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITIES
ORGANIZED FOR RESPONSIBLE
DEVELOPMENT. IF THE ALLIANCE
FOR SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY HUMAN
IMPACT PARTNERS POTENTIAL
EXCELLENCE FOR NEW ECONOMY
PARTNERSHIP FOR WORKING
FAMILIES UCLA LABOR CENTER
UNITED PERSPECTIVE WHICH
JUSTICE CENTER WORK STATES
WORKING PARTNERSHIPS AND UNITED
FOR RESPECT THANKS. SO MUCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF THREE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
MORGAN ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA MAY
AFFECT YOUR TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WHERE RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF TWO
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS RANDALL LANE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OF A LINE OF TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BRYAN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT UP CUTS A LINE OF THREE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS HASN'T
CHANGED NOW WITH THE CIVIL
JUSTICE THIRTY SURE CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. I'M TO NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS REX W.
HINE BEHALF OF NAPA CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OWNERS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS%
TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH SPRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR MOTIONS.
THE MOST. THE MOTION FROM A
SERVER STONE. AGO IN SECOND IT.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR THERE'S NO OTHER FURTHER
AND NOW FOR THE QUESTION
COMMENTS- WILL BRING BOB. I
THINK THAT I APPRECIATE YOU
KNOW CLEARLY. I THINK I WAS
CALLED FOR LAST YEAR'S VERSION
BUT- ANY CASE APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FOURTH AND- WOULD
BE INCLINED ALSO- JOINT AGAIN
AS A CO AUTHOR AND I THINK
THAT- LEAVE ME SEE WHAT THE I
GUESS IS AS- BUT THE HOT
WEATHER THERE'S A HIGH COST LOW
PRICES SOMETIMES. ESPECIALLY AS
IT APPLIES TO THEM THE RAPIDLY
INCREASING USE OF WAREHOUSES
WAREHOUSE WORKERS IN THIS NEW
ECONOMY- AND THERE'S GONNA BE
SOME LIMITATION TO THAT THEM
AND THEN THESE ARE HUMAN BEINGS
YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT ARE
WORKING AND- THERE'S GOT TO BE
SOME STANDARDS IN PLACE. AS A
HOW MUCH YOU CAN PUT AN
INDIVIDUAL PUT THE BODY THROUGH
WE'VE GONE THROUGH. THE
GOVERNOR AND US REVOLUTION
WE'VE GONE THROUGH ALL THESE
DIFFERENT. MOMENTS IN OUR
HISTORY. YOU KNOW TO TRY TO
PROTECT WORKERS TO HAVE TO GO
BACK UP AGAIN- AND CREATE THE
SELLERS CONDITIONS AND
SITUATIONS WHERE- WERE TREATING
INDIVIDUALS LIKE ROBOTS. AND
THIS KIND OF DYSTOPIAN. IN OF
BEING TRACE AND FOLLOW IN BEING
FIRED BY AN ALGORITHM I THINK
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME SENSE OF
WHAT KIND OF- AS AS THESE JOBS
ARE INCREASING AND THE PROFIT.
BEING MADE IS INCREDIBLE-
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE ONLINE
MARKETING ONLINE. ACADEMY SO
WITH THAT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I DO I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT A COUPLE THINGS THAT
WERE- I WOULD SUGGEST
MISREPRESENTED BY THE
OPPOSITION AND I WANT TO BE
CLEAR- FIRST AND FOREMOST IT
DOES NOT AFFECT ALL WAREHOUSES
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES AT A SITE OR THOUSAND
STATE WIDE PORT TO BE TRIGGERED
SELF. SMALLER WAREHOUSES- ARE
NOT AFFECTED BY THIS IT ALSO
DOESN'T AFFECT WAREHOUSES THEY
DON'T HAVE WORK QUOTAS WE HEARD
FROM SOME INDIVIDUALS WHO SAID.
WE DON'T USE A COMPUTER SYSTEM
AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE WORK
QUOTA YOU HAVE NOTHING TO- TO
DISCLOSE TO YOUR WORKERS SO I
WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
HELLO SHOULD DOES HAVE
WORKPLACE STANDARDS FOR
REPETITIVE MOTIONS HOWEVER
THESE AREN'T SUBJECT TO THE
PRODUCTIVITY QUOTAS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS BILL SO IT
WOULDN'T IT WOULDN'T. MATCH UP
TO WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE AND WE
KNOW S WORK CHANGES AND
ESPECIALLY WITH THE
INTRODUCTION OF A. I. AND
ALGORITHMS TO WORK. BUT THIS
TYPE OF REGULATION IS GOING TO
BE NECESSARY UNFORTUNATELY WHEN
YOU TAKE THE HUMAN COMPONENT
OUT OF EVALUATING WORKPLACE
SPEED AND- PRODUCTIVITY. YOU'RE
YOU'RE MISSING- THE ABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND IF SOMEBODY. HAD TO
USE THE RESTROOM ONE DAYER ARE
HOW TO WASH THEIR HANDS YOU'RE
YOU'RE LOSING OUT ON THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE. FIRSTHAND
BY HUMAN BEING IF THINGS ARE
JUST GOING TO FAST IN OUR
DANGER SOME PEOPLE ARE GETTING
HURT. SO WE NEED TO MAKE- OUR
OUR RULES AND REGULATIONS
ESPECIALLY OUR HEALTH AND
SAFETY REGULATIONS MATCH UP TO
THE REAL WORLD WORLD WORK PLACE
THAT WE'RE IN TODAY AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE-
OBVIOUSLY AS- YOU KNOW THE-
THESE COMPANIES. CAN AFFORD- TO
DO THIS- I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT
THAT THE PAGA- IMPLICATIONS IN
THIS BILL. OUR REBUTTAL ARE NOT
REBUTTABLE THEY'VE RIGHT HERE
THERE IN THAT PORTION OF THE
LABOR CODE SO THAT'S IMPORTANT
TO KNOW AS WELL- AND DOES. THE
SUGGESTION THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER AND OSHA HAVE
DIFFERENT STANDARDS THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER ONLY HAS- THE
RETALIATION PORTION OF THIS
BILL IT OSHA HAS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY SO THAT THEY CAN'T
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO END UP
WITH. WITH DUPLICATIVE ARE ARE
ARE CONTRADICTORY ADVICE THERE
SO- THE EXAMPLE USED ON
RETALIATION IT. OF I'M ASKING
FOR YOUR DATA EVERY THREE
MONTHS I UNDERSTAND FIRST OF
ALL. I COULD ARGUE THAT
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION FOR
RETALIATION IS ALWAYS EASY FOR
AND THE POWER OF THE EMPLOYER
TO BE ABLE TO- TO PUSH BACK ON
BUT WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE DATA
PIECE. OF IT AS BEING THE ONLY.
AS FIGURING OUT HOW HOW TO WORK
THROUGH- A CRAFTY EMPLOYEE WHO
WHO WANTS TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
BY ASKING FOR DATA WHICH I
THINK IS A REASONABLE THING TO
DO- GIVEN THAT YOU WOULD JUST
STILL HAVE TO READ BUT- ANY.
ANY QUESTIONS OF RETALIATION
BASED ON WORK PERFORMANCE WHICH
BY THE WAY. YOU'LL HAVE BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
HERE. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I ABOUT.
THANK YOU. SOME AND SOME
MEMBERS ACTUALLY HAVE A MOTION
FROM MADE BY SUMMER STYLE
SECOND BY KALRA. PLEASE TAKE A
ROLE IN AB SEVEN OH ONE. MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA THANK KALRA HI FLORA.
FLORA NOW GONZALEZ. HI GONZALEZ
I JONES SAWYER STONE FIVE STONE
AYE ZERO NO. GUARDINO WARD HI.
WARD HI. SO THAT THE OUT- AND
WE WILL GO NOW WHICH ONE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO DO I'D LIKE TO DO
AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN IF THAT'S
OKAY COURSE OF ECONOMIC BOTTOM
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AB TWO
FIFTY SEVEN BEGINS TO ADDRESS
LONG STANDING ISSUES IN THE
PAST FOOD RESTAURANT INDUSTRY
THROUGH THE CREATION OF A STATE
WIDE FAST FOOD SECTOR ACCOUNTS
ON BY HOLDING EMPLOYERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR PROTECTING THE
WORKERS. THE FAST FOOD INDUSTRY
REPRESENTS THE LARGEST AND
FASTEST GROWING A PRIVATE
SECTOR LOW WAGE WORKERS IN THE
STATE. DESPITE WORKING IN THE
FASTEST GROWING SECTOR IN THE
STATE FAST FOOD WORKERS
EXPERIENCE SOME OF THE LOWEST
WAGES ALONG WITH WAGE THEFT
HARASSMENT AN UNSAFE WORKPLACE
CONDITIONS. THE PANDEMIC IS
ONLY MAGNIFIED THESE-
SYSTEMATIC ISSUES. WITH THE
NUMEROUS FROM HOPE IN NINETEEN
AMHERST LAWS AND REGULATIONS
WERE INSTITUTED TO TRY TO
PROTECT WORKERS FROM INFECTION
ALLOW THEM TO STAY SAFE AND
RECOVER WITHOUT FEAR OF LOSING
THEIR LIVELIHOODS. HOWEVER
EMPLOYERS HAVE FAILED HIM FOR
THE WORKERS ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS
AND PRESSURED EMPLOYEES TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN WORKING IN
UNSAFE CONDITIONS ARE LOSING
THEIR LIVELIHOODS. WORKERS HAVE
FILED NUMEROUS COMPLAINTS
DOCUMENT VIOLATIONS OF CODE
SAFETY MEASURES PUBLIC HEALTH
LAWS AND LABOR LAWS. IN ONE
NOTABLE EXAMPLE FAST FOOD
FRANCHISE IN THE LOS ANGELES
ILLEGALLY FIRED FOUR EMPLOYEES
WHO PROTESTED WORKPLACE
CONDITIONS THAT WERE UNSAFE FOR
MANAGING THE SPREAD OF COVERED.
THINGS ARE CHANGING WE'RE GOING
TO GET OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC BUT
THAT WON'T CHANGE THE
CONDITIONS AND THE FAST FOOD
INDUSTRY AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN
EMPOWERS WORKERS AT LARGE FAST
FOOD ESTABLISHMENTS WITH THE
AUTHORITY SHAPE THEIR OWN
WORKPLACE STANDARDS TO THE
CREATION OF A STATE WIDE FAST
FOOD SECTOR COUNCIL.
FURTHERMORE THIS BILL WILL HOLD
CORPORATE FRANCHISOR
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ENSURING
FRANCHISEES COMPLY WITH THE
HEALTH SAFETY EMPLOYMENT
STANDARDS WE EXPECT ALL
EMPLOYERS TO BYE BYE.
ADDITIONAL AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN
WOULD PROHIBIT RETALIATION GETS
WORKERS. ASSEMBLY SOUNDING THE
ALARM AND PROTESTING AGAINST
WORKPLACE- AT CONDITIONS. AND
EMPOWERED WERE FIRST PAIRED
WITH POLICIES TO ENSURE THE
LARGE FAST FOOD COMPANY SHARE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR EMPLOYMENT
HEALTH AND SAFETY CONDITIONS IN
THE RESTAURANT THIS CRITICAL TO
REFORMING AN INDUSTRY THAT MUST
DO BETTER BY ITS WORKERS AND
ITS CUSTOMERS. I HAVE- ONE
WITNESS AND THEN. AN ATTORNEY-
FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE WILL ONE
WITNESS WAS THAT LIKE A LOT OF
MAY. BE USING A TRANSLATOR
THEMSELVES TAKE THAT DISCOUNT
IN TERMS OF THE TIMING- AND
THEN A BJ CHISHOLM AS YOU
MENTIONED THIS SUMMER BECAUSE
FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
SERVICE OCULAR IS READY SHE MAY
BEGIN. I DO A LOT THINK THAT
ARE NOT ON THE MCDONALD'S. YEAH
OF THANK YOU. I WILL ORGANIZE
ALL YOUR THEN THEY ARE BAD NOT
WHEN THEY THAT BUT NOT HELLO
THIS IS INVALID. THE COMPANY OF
THE ABOUT FOR EAGLE. THE
MCCARTY OF THE THAT BENEFIT
DON'T ELECT THAT BUT I'M NOT
GONNA CHARGE OF BUT I PERFECT.
OF COMMERCE ON MONDAY MA'AM AT
THE- ALSO BUT I'M LOOKING BY
READING UP IN A MONTH AND A
LOOK OUT OF IT BECAME. ALL
FUNDAMENTAL. NORWALK BECAUSE OF
MONTH GIVE. ENOUGH TO GETTING.
THAT WOULD. OF THE- THAT. YOU
CAN KNOW WHAT ABOUT BODIES
BANANA THE OF OUR. I DON'T KNOW
A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT LOOK
ON THE PHONE DOOR. FROM. I'VE
READ IN THE. AT THE END OF THIS
I MEAN OF THE MONTH BY MONTH ON
THAT NO MATTER AND YOUR THAT
ALREADY LINE ABOUT THE-
SETTLEMENT NEAR WHAT THIRTY YOU
NEED OTHER OF THE MEN YEAH. ON
THE END OF THE FUNDING JOHN.
BUT GIVE THEM IN AN APOCALYPSE
AND NOT SOME I'M NOT ALLOWED TO
GET STATE. OF THE ONLY SPOT ON
THE FEDERAL OR NOT THERE ARE
YOU TO SOMEBODY NEEDS OF. W.
ALREADY GOT UP AND OF THE AND
BLOOD IF THEY THOUGHT OF.
DONALD DECEMBER. SEPTEMBER NOT
BY ANY OF THEM ARE IT YEAH BUT
BUT BUT I'M- OF THE BIG. FIVE
ELIGIBLE TO USE THE FAMILY
MONEY THAT OF THOSE OF THE
PRODUCT. WHAT ABOUT THE WHETHER
BECAUSE OF THE FINAL BILL FROM
YOUR WRITING STYLE. YEAH MEANS.
THAT ARE MADE THE BALKANS WHEN
THEY GET THE ENTERTAINMENT OF
THE BUT I LOVE WHAT I LOOK.
MARKET FOR OTHER WHICH OTHER
MORE. YEAH BUT OKAY WHAT THE
HELL ABOVE THE- I'VE BEEN DON'T
WHEN THEY THANK YOU GOT YOUR
PARKING ON. MORE GOOD ACTORS
I'M THE- LACK AND I'M NOT SOME
WORK IN THE IN THE OF FIFTY AND
I UNION. I NEED BEGIN IT'S UP
FOR DEBATE TWO SAID. I BUT IT
ISN'T THAT WHAT. MICHAEL WHAT
AND I OF SIXTY SACKS OF BOTH
CEMEX IN THE COULD. THAT NOT
THE OWNER OF BENEDICT ABOUT THE
OF. DID INDEPENDENT MAKE AT MY
GUESS. THEIR WORK NOT BOTH AT
THE- NO MATTER ENFORCEMENT
ENOUGH MONEY GET. I SIX STATES.
THAT WHY I WENT ON THE- WITH
SEVEN GOALS THE WIN BETTER TAKE
THE EXPAND THAT. IT IS NOT
GOING TO. WELL NOT THAT
BENEFITS THE SITE AND ALL BY
MARC. WHAT I'M GETTING THE UP
GOOD SENSE ACTUALLY BE OUT IF
IT DOES WORK THERE THANK ALL
THAT THAT. WHAT FATHER. THIRTY
IS NOT DONE NOT DONE DEAL UP
BUT BLACK YEAR. THIRTY IN LA.
YOU WORK AND WHAT'S NOT IN
DETAIL. WITHOUT THE VIDAK AND
THE IS THAT IN MIND OF STATE OF
THE. SIX AND I THANK YOU FOR
NOT DONALD IT'S VERY WHAT FIFTY
FOUR WHAT ABOUT SIX HAVE A- IF
I THAT FIFTY NINE. WE HAVE
ABOUT UP WHAT'S IT GOING ON
FACT BUT THAT'S CONDITION LIKE
THESE. BY THE OF MIRACLE WORKER
IN THE INDUSTRY MY COMING
WORKERS EFFECTS WITH BECAUSE-
COULD NOT THERE. IT BUT GETS
BETWEEN FIFTH AVE STORE IF
THANK YOU SO. WE NEED SOMETHING
TEN ACCORDING TO THE- SB THIRTY
AT SEVEN SIX THAT THE CHEATING
THAT. I COULD WILL BOTH IN
FAVOR EIGHTY TO FIFTY CENT
THANK YOU. THIS ON THE BILL.
YOUR FEAR IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
FIFTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO IF
YOU AREN'T SUPPORT OF AB TWO
FIFTY SEVEN. WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF THREE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS WERE NAY BAYARDO WITH
SEIU CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR THE BILL WITH THE
FIGHT FOR FIFTEEN ENOUGH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO ONE OF THE THREE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
MUCH TIGHTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO ONE OF THREE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR NUMBER SHANE
GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF COURSE ONE OF
THREE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE THREE NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN DO YOU HAVE A TIME
YOU. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. OKAY WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF THREE FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU LOUIS FARRAKHAN
WITH WORKING PARTNERSHIPS IN
TEN DAY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF THREE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MICHELLE RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO CITY
COUNCILMEMBER KATIE BALANCE
RIGHT AWAY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ABOUT THE LINE
OF THREE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE SIX TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IT WILL GO TO THREE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FINAL THREE FOUR SIX. HELLO
THIS IS JOE THOMPSON FROM
PUBLIC COUNSEL REPRESENTING THE
WOMEN AND GIRLS RIGHTS PROJECT-
WE WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THESE
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS FOR FAST
FOOD WORKERS OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO SO LINE OF
THREE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BY JOYCE MARC- SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF SUNRISE SACRAMENTO
WE ARE INTO COURT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO A LINE OF
TWO SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWO SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES THE LIES ABOUT THE
FIGHT FOR FIFTEEN I JUST LIKE
TO READ THE NAMES OF ALL THE
FAST FOOD WORKERS THAT HAVE
BEEN WAITING ONLINE AND ARE
HAVING DIFFICULTY SPEAKING. ON
THE- THOSE FOLKS ARE NAY CHAU
WILLIAMS IN MELBOURNE SALLY.
JUANITA KONMARI NOW CARLA
VALENZUELA COOLEY AT THAT IDEA.
PROBLEM THE VIRUS AND
BARTOLOME. THANK YOU THAT MADE
IT MORE EFFICIENT AND WE
APPRECIATE THEIR FEEDBACK THANK
YOU. GIVE US A CALL AT THE LINE
OF THREE OLD FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
THREE OH FOUR- WHEN ASSEMBLY
FOR MANY EMPLOYEES THE WHOLE
POINT OF MILLIONS OF BEG YOUR
FOR YOUR LACK. OF THE OPEN
TICKET. PRESS YOU AND ONE
MOMENT WE HAVE TWO MORE IN Q.
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF THREE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THREE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN DO YOU HAVE A SOME NEW.
NUMBER ABOUT THE LIMITATIONS
THEY APPOINT A LOBBY LOOKING
WITH THE TYPICAL BUT MULTIPLE-
PROCESS. THANK YOU THANKS ABOUT
THE LINE OF THREE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND DON'T
THINK. PLEASE GO AHEAD. WARNER
BROTHERS. I DON'T THINK SAY YES
GO AHEAD. OKAY RENO
RECOMMENDABLE FARLEY THE
PROBLEM I'M GONNA SAY I KNOW HE
ARE FOR YOUR LAB BUT YOU ABBY.
PROCESS THANK YOU NXR KOTO LINE
OF THREE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THREE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEXICO TO
LINE OF THREE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU THIS IS
ROSEMARIE NOW WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. X. ABOUT THE
LINE OF THREE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE NUMBER THAT'S
GONNA IT ABOUT- BUT- MIGHT
DON'T UNDER SOMETIMES DIFFICULT
BUT IF YOU'RE TRYING YEAH YES
YEAH WELL YEAH AND ALL AVE.
BOTH IN COURT DATE YET THANK
YOU FOR THE TICKET I'M OFTEN ON
THE CAN IS THAT THE BOMB ALSO
CALM YOUNG. BUT OUR THERE. A
STATEMENT COURT. HELLO SPOKE
ABOUT HOW THE ORDER. PROCESS
THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE UP TO
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWO SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND WE HAVE NO MARIN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WILL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
RANDY POLLOCK. AND WE HAVE
MAKAYLA MENDELSSOHN BOTH BY
PHONE AND SERVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES EACH RANDY IF YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU.
THE CARE PERSON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRANDI POLLOCK IN
BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
FRANCHISE ASSOCIATION WHICH
REPRESENTS FOURTEEN HUNDRED
GRANTED TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
FRANCHISE THE- EIGHTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN WOULD DESTROY A
SUCCESSFUL MODEL OF BUSINESS
OWNERSHIP FOR THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIA. REFILL PROCESS SHOW
GROWING NUMBERS OF WOMEN AND
MINORITIES OWNED FRANCHISES
THAT WITHIN TEN EIGHTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN WITH SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACT THE OWNERSHIP THE BILL
THAT. ALITY FAST FOOD
FRANCHISES ARE LOCALLY OWNED
SMALL BUSINESSES OPERATING
UNDER A NATIONAL BRAND OUR
IDENTITY. THERE WERE TWO OTHER
SMALL BUT- LOCAL FRANCHISE THE
BUSINESS OWNER IS IN CHARGE OF
ALL DAY TO DAY ACTIVITIES THE
COOKING AND POINTED AT THE
ASIAN HIRING FIRING WAGES AND
BENEFITS. THE LOCAL FRANCHISEES
OWNS AND OPERATES AT THAT
INSTANT NOT THE FRANCHISE DOOR.
AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN ONE BECAUSE
THEY PER SE LIABILITY ROLE ON
FRANCHISES THAT HAVE NO ROLE
WHATSOEVER. IN THE ISSUES
ADDRESSED IN THIS BUDGET. FRANK
I NOT WITH HALF OF CALIFORNIA
LAW REALLY THE WAY. BENEFITS
HOURS WORKING CONDITIONS AND
WORKER THEY- TEL REDUCE
FRANCHISEES FROM INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS OWNERS THE CORPORATE
MIDDLE MANAGERS. TO DESTROY THE
FRANCHISE MODEL THE VERY
RESTRICTED BILLION PEOPLE TO
OWN THEIR OWN SMALL BUSINESS.
AS L. THE BILL ALSO CREATES A
FAST FOOD SECTOR COUNCIL WHICH
WOULD HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
ISSUE ENTIRELY NEW AND
DIFFERENT LABOR EMPLOYMENT WAIT
AN HOUR AND HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS. BUT A. FIVE WEEK THE
FAST FOOD CHAIN. THOSE ARE ALL
SUBJECT THAT BY STATE AND
COUNTY LAWS RUNNING THERE BUT-
WHY WOULD THE LEGISLATURE UP IN
THE STORE ONE I KNOW WHAT THE
BOARD TO MAKE THE THINGS. THERE
ARE SOME QUESTIONS THAT
COMMITTEE SHOULD CONSIDER WHY
IS THE FAST FOOD FRANCHISE
INDUSTRY BEING SINGLED OUT WHEN
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF OTHER
BUSINESSES THAT ARE NOT SUBJECT
TO THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
I WANT TO DECIDED THAT THE BILL
ONLY APPLIES TO FAST FOOD
FRANCHISES WITH THIRTY OR MORE
LOCATIONS NATIONWIDE. IS THERE
ANY EVIDENCE THAT FRANCHISEES
ARE NOT BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
THERE THE WORKPLACE VIOLATION.
IF THERE IS A LACK OF
ENFORCEMENT THIS BILL TO BE
MORE FOCUSED ON ENSURING THAT
THE WAY THE COMMISSION HAS
SUFFICIENT A THIRD PARTY BOSS.
FINALLY WHY WOULD THE
LEGISLATURE UNDERMINE THE RIGHT.
OF FRANCHISE BE TO RUN THEIR
OWN BUSINESS. AB TWO FIFTY.
CRIME THAT GRANT. ARE COMP
ENOUGH RUN THEIR- OWN BUSINESS.
THEMSELVES EVERY BUSINESS IN
THE STATE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- MAKAYLA MENDELSSOHN IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE YOU MAY
BEGIN. THE AVERAGE. HELLO YES
WE CAN. OKAY GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER MEMBERS I.
MAKAYLA MENDELSON CEO ACQUIRE
WEST CORP A MULTI UNIT
FRANCHISEE PROFILE LOCAL
RESTAURANTS IN THE WESTERN
REGION. AND A LONG TIME MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. I CURRENTLY SIT ON
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS THE
MAYOR THIRTY FELLOW WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WOULD VOTE
THE FACE TO DIVERSITY THE
CALIFORNIA AND NATIONAL
RESTAURANT INDUSTRIES. I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN WHICH TARGETS QUICK
SERVICE AND FAST CASUAL
RESTAURANTS UNDER BROWN WITH
THIRTY OR MORE RESTAURANTS OR
STORES NATIONWIDE DEVELOPMENT
ALARMING PROPOSAL TO EMPOWER A
NEW UNELECTED BODY THE FAST
FOOD SECTOR COUNCIL ESTABLISHED
BY THE BILL STATE WAGE AND
WORKPLACE REQUIREMENTS
RESTAURANTS. SETTING WAGE AND
WORKPLACE STANDARDS IS AN
AUTHORITY CURRENTLY RESERVED
FOR THE LEGISLATURE ENFORCEMENT
COMING FROM THE APPROPRIATE
STATE AND LOCAL ENTITIES CHARGE
FOR DOING SO. AB TWO FIFTY
SEVEN SOCIALLY AND THAT'S LYING
ABOUT STARTING OVER TO SECTOR
COUNCIL HAD ZERO ACCOUNTABILITY
TO VOTERS AND THAT WOULD BE
ABLE TO IMPOSE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT POLICIES THAT
SUPERSEDE THOSE BEING MADE BY
ELECTED OFFICIALS. THE OTHER
PORTION OF THE BALLOT PACKS THE
RESTAURANT FRANCHISE MODEL
TURNING THAT MODEL ON ITS HEAD
AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN SIX DOES
THAT WAS JOINED SEVERAL
LIABILITY FRANCHISE DOORS BY
TEMPE TO MAKE BACHELOR'S NORMS
THE JOINT EMPLOYER THE
FRANCHISEES. ADVOCATE FOR THIS
CHANGE AND ACCURATELY I THINK
THE OWNERS OF THE FRANCHISE
BRANDS THE FRANCHISE STORES BY
THE TWO OPERATORS OF THE
STORMS. NOTHING COULD BE MORE
FALSE REALITY FRANCHISE
ESTABLISHMENTS LIKE MINE UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OR LOCALLY
OWNED. BUSINESSES OPERATING
UNDER A NATIONAL BRAND OR
IDENTITY AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN
RESULT IN ME AND SO MANY OTHER
FRANCHISEES LOSING OUR ECONOMY
TO THE STATE WOULD ESPECIALLY
BE STRIPPING US OF OUR IDENTITY
AS BUSINESS OWNERS AND MAKE
YOUR. MANAGERS OF LARGE
CORPORATIONS. THE EXISTING
PHONE MOM CAL. GAVE ME ARE. TO
PUT MY CARD ARE STAVING IF A MY
FIRST REST THIRTY AGO. JOINT
LIABILITY WOULD REMOVE FOR
THEIR OWN FOR. IN SAN FOR
FRANCHISORS HAVE BEEN WITH ANY.
LIKE ME AND ANYONE THAN LARGE
CONGLOMERATES APPEAL MY
TEMPLATES HAVE BENEFITTED
GREATLY FROM MY ABILITY TO
OPERATE WITHIN THE EXISTING
FRANCHISE MODEL AND THE SUPPORT
RECEIVED TO GROW AS WE GROW AND
TAKE CARE OF THEIR FAMILIES. MY
OFFICE SAYS IN THE FRANCHISE
I'M ABLE TO GIVE BACK
ADVOCATING FOR TRANSGENDER
WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE THROUGH
MY WORK WITH A CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION AND ITS
FOUNDERS TRANSCRIPT TRANSCRIPT
WORK WHICH CREEK MODEL FOR
TRANSFERS OF WORKPLACES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE RESTAURANT
FRANCHISE MODEL IS ONE MADE UP
OF AMAZING STORIES OF
OPPORTUNITY IN A WONDERFUL
REFLECTION OF OUR GREAT
DIVERSITY IN CALIFORNIA. EITHER%
A WAGE SECTOR COUNCIL OR
TURNING THE FRANCHISE MODEL ON
ITS HEAD HELLO GRANT THESE
IMPORTANT CAUSES ANNA FROM
FORCE MADE. PUBLIC VETTING
LABOR EMPLOYMENT LAWS IS REALLY
THE ISSUE. AT ADVOCATES FOR AB
FIFTY FIVE SEVEN SAY THAT LET'S
PLEASE HAVE THAT DISCUSSION NOT
CHANGED OR LEGISLATIVE SYSTEM
BASED ON A FEW BAD ACTORS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE NO
ON AB TWO FIVE SEVEN THANK YU
THANK YOU- THERE'S NO ONE IN
THE ROOM SO LET'S GO TO THE
PHONES FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO FIVE SEVEN AGAIN
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
FIFTY SEVEN JUST YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION A PLUS ON THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
POSSESS OF A TWO BY SEVENTY MY
PRET AT THE ZERO. ONE AND THEN
THEY OPEN UP AT THE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF THREE SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ASHLEY HOFFMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE
WILL GO TO THE LINE OF. THREE
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I
APOLOGIZE ARE WE GONNA BE ABLE
TO GET IN ON THE SUPPORT SIDE
BUT THIS IS MICHAEL RAT AGAIN
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
WILL START WITH OUR VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IS A-
MRS MILLS MILLS AND STILL ON
THE PHONE WITH. THIS MENTAL
SYSTEM FOR THE- CHRISTMAS OF
MCCALLUM M. MENDELSON. SERVICE
HERE YUP. THE PROCEDURE YOUR
TESTIMONY I JUST HAD A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU BECAUSE- WE
ACTUALLY MET A FEW YEARS AGO
WHEN YOU TESTIFIED IN PERSON
AND SO I APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
TIME AGAIN- TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF- YOU KNOW. THE
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION. I JUST
WANTED TO ASK YOU-ABOUT THE
FRANCHISE MODEL THE PROVIDED
YOU PERSONALLY WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR UPWARD
MOBILITY. AND QUITE FRANKLY-
HOW YOU GIVE THAT BACK TO THE
EMPLOYEES AND IN THE WORKPLACE
CULTURE IN THE COMMUNITIES IN
WHICH YOU OPERATE THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF SESSION TODAY ON CO
THE NINETEENTH IN THE WORKPLACE
I'M CURIOUS OW YOU HANDLE COVR
NINETEEN PRODUCTIONS IN YOUR
WORKPLACE FOR YOUR GUESTS. AND
YOUR EMPLOYEES- THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ANSWER THAT-
APPALLED BY SOME OF THE BY THE
STORY TOLD BY THE ONE. EMPLOYEE
AND THAT WAS OBVIOUSLY- AN
OWNER OF A RESTAURANT THAT WAS
NOT HANDLING THINGS PROPERLY.
BUT IN IN MY RESTAURANTS AND
RESTAURANTS. OWNED BY
FRANCHISEE THAT I KNOW- THINGS
WERE QUITE DIFFERENT DURING THE
PANDEMIC WHEN IT HIT WE SET OUR
MINDS THAT THE SAFETY OF OUR
EMPLOYEES. AND OUR CUSTOMERS
WERE SEPTEMBER SPOTS ABILITY.
AND AGREED THOUGHT PLEXI
SHIELDS MASTER ONE BY ALL
EMPLOYEES FACE CARD BY THOSE
HAVING CONTACT WITH CUSTOMERS
IN WASHINGTON SANITIZING
STRICTLY ENFORCED AND ALL OF
THEM THIS WASN'T EASY BUT WE'RE
USED TO IN THE RESTAURANTS WE
KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE IN SPAIN
COUNTY GUIDANCE THAT WAS
CONSTANTLY COMING DOWN AND
CHANGING WE CLOSELY FOLLOWED
ALL THE FIFTY ONE IS AN
IMPLEMENTED BY THE NEXT
BUSINESS DAY. AND I'M NOT HAPPY
THAT WE DID SCREENING OF
EMPLOYEES BEFORE EVERY SHIFT
INCLUDING ASKING QUESTIONS OF
THE CONTACT BEHAVIORS OUTSIDE
THE WORKPLACE AND THOSE
ATTENDING LARGE GATHERINGS ARE
ASKED TO GO BACK TO QUARANTINE
AND COME BACK TO WORK FIVE DAYS
LATER THEY HAVE NO SYMPTOMS
EACH EMPLOYEE WE DID HAVE SOME
CASES EACH PERSON REPORTING A
POSITIVE CASE PUT THE
QUARANTINE WELL AS OTHER
EMPLOYEES WERE CLOSE CONTACT
WITH THEM FOR OVER TEN MINUTES
BY DOING THIS. WE WERE ABLE TO
TRACE IT BACK TO ITS ORIGIN AND
THAT ONE CASE DURING THE WHOLE
PROGRAM WE FOUND WAS TRACED
BACK TO OUR WORKPLACE COMMON
SOURCES WERE. A LARGE FAMILY
AND SOCIAL GATHERINGS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT.
BEEN GIVEN I MEAN THIS OF
CALIFORNIA HAS IN. HAS A NOW
LIKE FIFTEEN PAID. OF
RESTAURANT. FOR KOBE NINETEEN
PROTOCOLS TO FOLLOW AND THEN
EACH COUNTY HAS THEIR OWN.
ADDITIONAL SECTOR REQUIREMENTS.
IN ORDER TO FILL IN THE ORDER
OF ALL THESE BEING ISSUED
WITHOUT NOTICE AND I LITERALLY
CHANGING DAY BY DAY HOW DID YOU
RESPOND IN YOUR WORKPLACE THESE
KINDS THAT SUDDEN SHIFTS. I'M A
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS WHO
WERE IN IN DOING THE BEST JOB
THEY COULD. BUT SOME OF THE
MEASURES WERE CONSTANTLY
CHANGING AT A MOMENT'S NOTICE
HOW DID YOU ADJUST ALL THE ON
THE FLY. LIKE I SAID WE- WILL
USE THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
KEEPING THE PUBLIC SAFE. KEEP
EMPLOYED SIX SO. IN RESTAURANT
BUSINESS THAT'S- ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS WE DO.
HAVE SO PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT ANYWAY SO EVERY DAY
THAT WOULD COME DOWN THAT NIGHT
I'D BE UP TILL WEE HOURS OF THE
MORNING WITH MY OPERATING
PARTNER AND WE CAN MAKE SURE WE
PUT OUT. MEMOS THAT SET UP EACH
OF OUR MANAGERS THAT MEETINGS
WITH THEIR EMPLOYEES TO MAKE
SURE ALL THOSE GUIDELINES WERE
FOLLOWED VERY CLOSELY. AND
OTHER FRANCHISEES I KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO SAY. AWESOME SO
BASICALLY TOOK THEIR GUIDELINES
AND APPLIED A LITTLE BIT OF
COMMON SENSE TO IT AND YOU WERE
ABLE TO KEEP- YOUR PATRONS AND
YOUR EMPLOYEES SAFE- IS AT THE
GENERAL GIST OF WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. I WOULD SAY THAT- IN IN
90% OR MORE OF THE CASES WE
WERE AREADY EXCEEDING. THE
GUIDELINES THAT THAT CAME DOWN
SO IT WASN'T THAT HARD FOR US.
TO MAKE THE ADJUSTMENT. I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME IN YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. WHEN THE
LAWSUIT WAS- YES. SEATTLE WHO
WORKED IN A FAST FOOD
RESTAURANT. I HAVE. I THINK
EVERYBODY GETS THEIR START IN
ONE OF- YOU KNOW MY CONCERN
ABOUT THIS AND MANY OTHER BILLS
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT JUST THIS
THIS PARTICULAR BILL IS I
REMEMBER GOING TO A- A SEMINAR
OR- CONFERENCE OR WHATEVER YOU
WANNA CALL IT. ON THE FUTURE OF
THE WORK FORCE AND IT REALLY
WAS TALKING ABOUT THE ROBOTICS
INDUSTRY. AND HOW WE ARE KIND
OF MARCHING TOWARDS THIS PATH
WHERE ROBOTICS ARE EXPENSIVE.
BUT AS WE MARCH FURTHER AND
FURTHER TOWARDS THE MIDDLE
WHERE ROBOTICS WILL EVENTUALLY
BECOME MORE ECONOMICAL THAN
HAVING PEOPLE WORK. AND I AM
AFRAID OF THAT BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT PEOPLE NOT WORKING. ONCE
ROBOTS ROBOTS REPLACE WORKERS-
GENERAL THEN I THINK WE'RE IN
BIG TROUBLE. AND AND SO YOU
KNOW THAT'S ONE OF MY FEARS
WITH A LOT OF THESE- THIS
INTRUSION INTO HOW PEOPLE RUN
THEIR BUSINESSES- AND IT IS
EVENTUALLY THEY WILL MAKE IT
TOO EXPENSIVE TO HAVE EMPLOYEES
THEY WON'T HAVE FIFTEEN OR
TWENTY THEY'LL HAVE TWO OR
THREE THAT ARE EXPERTS IN
ROBOTICS AND BELIEVE ME IF YOU
GO TO HIGH SCHOOL LOOK AT THE
ROBOTICS TEAMS AND SOME OF THE
THINGS THEY'RE DOING. YOU WILL
KNOW WHERE THAT FUTURE WORK
FORCE IS GOING TO COME FROM BUT
IT WILL ONLY BE TWO OR THREE OF
THEM. SO YOU KNOW THOSE AT YOU
THAT'S KIND OF MY CONCERN. IS I
THINK THAT WE ARE INTRUDING WAY
TOO MUCH. INTO PRIVATE
INDUSTRY. AND THE MORE WE DO
THAT THE MORE EXPENSIVE IT
GETS. AND THE MORE WE PUSH THEM
INTO ALTERNATIVE MEANS OF
RUNNING THEIR BUSINESSES AND
PROVIDING YOUR SERVICES. AND
YOU SEE THAT WITH THE AMAZON
AND THEIR- THEIR DRONES THAT
ARE DELIVERING INSTEAD OF THOSE
FOLKS. AND YEAH YOU KNOW WHAT I
DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT I REALLY
DON'T. SO ANYWAY. I HAVE A LOT
OF OBJECTIONS TO WHERE WE'RE
HEADED- I YOU KNOW I WANT
PEOPLE TO BE SAFE AND I WANT
THEM TO HAVE A GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT- BUT I DON'T THINK
THIS IS THE PATH IT'S GOING TO
PROVIDE THAT IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. APPREHENDED
EMOTION. THE MOTION SIR SECOND
AND THE SECOND TO THE MOTION
FROM SUMMER STONE SECONDED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD- WHAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I JUST I.
YOU KNOW. I DON'T WANT TO HARP
ON IT BUT- BEFORE I CAME TO
THIS GREAT INSTITUTION EIGHT
YEARS AGO I WORKED FOR THE
LABOR MOVEMENT AND EVERY SINGLE
TIME WE TRY TO ESPECIALLY FOR
LOW WAGE WORKERS TO IMPROVE THE
CONDITIONS EITHER THROUGH
PRIVATE NEGOTIATIONS OR PUBLIC
ACTION- THE ILLUSTRIOUS ROBOT
HAS ALWAYS BEEN USED AS THE
REASON TO NOT DO IT AND I THINK
BACK TO THE WORKERS WHO. I'VE
FOUGHT TO PROTECT. TWENTY YEARS
AGO. WHO SPENT THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS IN CONDITIONS BECAUSE
ROBOTS DIDN'T REPLACE THEM. SO
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO REALIZE YES TECHNOLOGY WILL
HAPPEN THERE WILL BE
ADVANCEMENT IN THE WORKPLACE
BUT THE MEANTIME WE DON'T THROW
AWAY WORKERS WE DON'T SAY. IT'S
OKAY THAT THEY'RE AN UNSAFE
WORKING CONDITIONS ARE IT'S
OKAY THEY DON'T HAVE A VOICE ON
THE JOB WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
INTO IT AND DIRECTION THAT IS
GOING TO BE BETTER FOR ALL
WORKERS. I'M WITH YOU I WANT
PEOPLE TO WORK I VALUE WORK AND
I THINK THE WORK WILL CHANGE
IT'LL CONTINUE TO CHANGE. BUT
ONE THING HASN'T CHANGED- LOW
WAGE SERVICE WORK IS STILL
DANGEROUS IT IT'S STILL HARMFUL
TO WORKERS. I YES ABSOLUTELY-
THE GENTLEMAN WHO SPOKE WAS
PROBABLY A GOOD EXAMPLE BUT IN
REALITY WE HAVE SO MANY
COMPLAINTS FROM WORKERS THROUGH
THIS PANDEMIC WE KNOW THAT'S
NOT THE NORM. AND SO WE JUST
WANT TO WITH THIS BILL TO LOOK
AT AN INDUSTRY THAT HAS BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
LOW WAGES- BYE BYE LACK OF
HEALTH CARE BY. AS SCHEDULING
MISHAPS THAT DON'T ALLOW THEM
TO EVEN HOLD A FULL TIME JOB
THEY'VE BEEN AFFECTED BY A
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND THEY'VE
BEEN AFFECTED BY- HEALTH AND
SAFETY VIOLATIONS THROUGHOUT
THIS PANDEMIC AND BEFORE. WE
WANT THEM TO HAVE A VOICE ON
THE JOB AND BECAUSE THE
FRANCHISE OR FRANCHISEE MODEL.
THAT HASN'T BEEN POSSIBLE AND
SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR OTHER WAYS
TO GIVE THEM A VOICE ON THE JOB
IN AS FAR AS A THIRD PARTY-
COMMISSION HAVING THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG HISTORY
IN FACT THE IWC. THE INDUSTRIAL
WELFARE COMMISSION STARTING
CALIFORNIA NINETEEN TIRTEEN
AND RAN UNTIL TWO THOUSAND FOUR
WHEN IT WAS DEFENDED BECAUSE-
IT BECAME AN EFFORT TO UNDER
CUTS. LABOR STANDARDS BUT WE
HAVE ALWAYS HAD ANOPPORTUNITY
ARE WE DID HISTORICALLY IN
CALIFORNIA FOR A COMMISSION TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR HERE. WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
WORKERS A VOICE IN THE
WORKPLACE A GROUP OF WORKERS
WHO DESPITE NOT HAVING POWER OR
LEVERAGE HAS LED THIS NATION
INTO A FIGHT FOR FIFTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR HAS WON IT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. IS LEADING THE
FIGHT NATIONALLY AND THEY
DESERVE AND THEY HAVE CHAU OWN
US THEY HAVE GOOD IDEAS AND
NECESSITIES IN THE WORKPLACE
AND THAT THEY SHOULD BE AT THE
TABLE TO THE TO THAT. THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES I
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. MA'AM SECTOR. TO
CALL THE ROLL ON AB. NINE NINE
FIVE. SORRY SEVEN OF. THE PAGE.
AB TWO FIVE SEVEN- WITH THE-
I'M NOT A MOTION BY SOME
IMMERSED ON SECOND BY SOME
AWARD THANK YOU. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
KALRA. AYE KALRA AYE FLORIDA.
FLOOR UNKNOWN GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER STONE
RIGHT STONE I ACR DO NOW YOU'RE
A KNOWN WARD. WARD I THINK SO
THAT THE NUMBER THAT- OUT AND
ON THE WAY THAT YOU DISTRICT
MANAGER- IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TAKE A WE WANT TO KEEP GOING
OKAY- ITEM FOURTEEN AB NINE
NINE FIVE. HERE YOU GO M. SO
THIS THIS. NOT TO I I'M JUST
GOING TO STRAIGHT OUT. BE CLEAR
NONE OF THIS WOULD THANK YOU
NOW THIS WOULD NOT AFFECT INTEL
AFTER THE CODED- SICK DAY
PROTECTIONS HAVE EXPIRED ANYWAY
SO WHEN WE'RE COMPARING APPLES
AND ORANGES LET'S MAKE SURE
THIS WOULD EXTEND FROM THREE
DAYS TO FIVE DAYS CALIFORNIA'S-
PAID SICK DAY LAW. WHICH WAS BY
THE WAY CALL THE JOB KILLER
BACK WHEN WE INTRODUCED IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN HAVE YET TO SEE
EVIDENCE THAT A SINGLE JOB WAS
KILLED BECAUSE WE PROVIDED
WORKERS WITH PAID SICK DAYS
SELF ALTHOUGH IT IS A BEGAN A
HIGHLIGHT OF THE CHAMBER SO
CALLED JOB KILLER. AT SOME
POINT WE HAVE LEGISLATORS
SHOULD PUSH BACK A LITTLE SAVE
WELL. WHEN DID IT KILL JOBS
BEFORE ALSO CURRENTLY
WASHINGTON ARIZONA OREGON NEW
YORK NEW JERSEY COLORADO
MICHIGAN MASSACHUSETTS MARYLAND
VERMONT MAINE AND CONNECTICUT
AND THE CITIES OF SAN DIEGO LOS
ANGELES SANTA MONICA SAN
FRANCISCO OAKLAND BERKELEY AND
EMERYVILLE HAVE GRANTED
WORKERS. THE RIGHT TO USE AT
LEAST FIVE DAYS OR MORE OF PAID
SICK DAYS A YEAR AND THEY SEEM
TO BE OPERATING QUITE WELL WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIVEAU. THANK YOU- AND WE CAN
GO OVER THERE ARE NO WITNESSES
AT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
WITNESS ENOUGH TO THIS. BILL
AND SO IF THERE'S ANY OTHER-
PEOPLE SUPPORT ON THE ROOMS
WILL GO. TO THE PHONES AB. NINE
NINE FIVE. NAME AFFILIATE A
POSITION THE BILL. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINE FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO PERRANCE
SUPPORTS. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF THREE SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND YOUR ON BEHALF OF NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
PROPER CHAPTER REPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ABOUT THE
LINE OF THREE THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND MY NAME IS
THEIR IDEAS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMPLICATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
STEP THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
TWO SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KATIE WATER SMITH WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO SIGN OF THREE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHEN I
PARTNER WITH AT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE OF THREE THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS IMAGE
CIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO EXPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANKS TO ALL OF
THE LINE OF THREE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JESUS HI MY
NAME IS MARIE IN IOWA DIRECTOR
OF THE RESTAURANT DIDN'T CENTER
LOS ANGELES. MISTER FAVOR OF
EIGHTY NINE NINETY FIVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TIME.
THREE FORTY. HI THIS IS
POLITICAL REALITIES ORANGE
COUNTY QUALITY COALITION
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
NINE NINE FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
THREE FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WELL THE WAY THAT OUR
HOME FROM SAN JOSE ON BEHALF OF
WORKING PARTNERSHIPS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FLEXIBLE
PLAN OF THREE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JOHN CONTENT FROM
PUBLIC COUNSEL IN STRONG
SUPPORT FIVE EIGHTY NINE NINE
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO TIMELINE OF THREE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON MY NAME TO CREATEA
LACK OF FROM THE CHILDCARE
LAWCENTER CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINE FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
THANK YOU MEXICO SIGN OF THREE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER SHANE
GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION THE INTERNATIONAL
SCIENCE CALIFORNIA THE
MACHINIST I APPEAL TO YOU LOCAL
TWENTY ONE IN THAT YEAR AND
UTILITY WORKERS UNION OF
AMERICA ALL SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO FIND OF
THREE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS REBECCA COUSINS AND
I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH CALIFORNIA
ART AND WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO SO LINE OF
THREE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS NOT A
HERSHFIELD WITH THE NORTH BAY
LABOR COUNCIL WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF DISCO. THANK YOU.
THANK IN MEXICO TO LINE OF
THREE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MR CHEN MEMBERS CAITLIN
VEGA FOR THE TRANSPORT WORKERS
UNION OF AMERICA AND ACCOUNT
LOTS OF BY SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION PARENTS STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF THREE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTER AN AMATEUR MEMBERS THAT
REALLY ON BEHALF HE W. AS TRUMP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE OF THREE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER KAREN MEMBERS MARICA
YOSHIHARU ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE- WINDS THREE FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIFTEEN
CAL THIRTY PARTNERS SEPTEMBER
MYSTIC FILING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO
ONE OF TWO SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS KATHY HALL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP WORKING
FAMILIES REPRESENTING OUR
AFFILIATES INCLUDING BECAUSE
CENTRAL COAST ALLIANCE UNITED
FOR A SUSTAINABL ECONOMIES
CENTER POLICY INITIATIVES IN
SAN DIEGO ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITIES ORGANIZED FOR
RESPONSIBLE DEVELOPMENT. SALINE
CRISTINA BILLY CONNOLLY WORKING
PARTNERSHIP UNTALLIED LAWCENTER
KELANTAN ECONOMY AND WAREHOUSE
WORKERS. RESOURCE CENTER IN
INLAND EMPIRE IN CHILD SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
OVER TO LINE OF THREE SEVENTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS KATIE RICHARD HORN LEGAL AID
AT WORK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
MORE SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU- WILL MOVE ON
THEN TO OPPOSITION AND WITH US
ON THE PHONE ASHLEY HOFFMAN YOU
MAY BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
ACTUALLY HAPPEN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE INTERSECT OPPOSITION
TO AB BANK HAS THE CHILD
KILLER. YOU KNOW WE RECOGNIZE
NAY KNOWLEDGE CODE PANDEMIC HAS
BEEN DEVASTATING BOTH WORKERS
AND BUSINESSES BUSINESSES HAVE
TRIED TO STAY OPEN AND KEEP AS
MANY WORKERS ON PAYROLLS
POSSIBLE. MANY HAVE TAKEN OUT
LOANS WE DO SO AND HAVE
INVESTED IN KEEPING OUR WORKERS
SAFE AND COMPENSATED AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE DURING THIS TIME.
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO KEEP OPERATIONS GOING
EMPLOYERS OBLIGATIONS TO
PROVIDE BELIEVE HAS INCREASED
OVER THE PAST YEAR INCLUDING A
SECOND ROUND OF THE NINETEEN
DEEPLY IF. EXCLUSION PAY UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA STANDARDS-
INDEED CREASY FOR AT LEAST A
SMALL BUSINESSES FMLA PREGNANCY
DISABILITY LEAVE AND MANY
OTHERS BUT DOES NOT EVEN
INCLUDE ALL OF THE OTHER LOCAL
ORDINANCES THAT HAVE MORE
BROADLY. FIREMEN ON TOP OF WHAT
THE STATE. AND EVEN THOUGH OF
THOSE MAKE. BY TIME THIS DOES
TAKE. THE COST OF THE LEAVES
AND ALL OF THEM. THAT HAVE HAD
TO WITH OVER THE PAST HAS. A
TOLL. WELL TO MORE DAYS AND
LEAVE FOR EMPLOYEES MAY NOT
SEEM LIKE A LOT AND EXPECTED
ABSENTEEISM FOR BUSINESSES
REALLY EXPENSIVE AND COST
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS PER
EMPLOYEE PER YEAR FOR BUSINESS.
AND FOR SMALL BUSINESS THAT
STILL STRUGGLING WITH 30% OR
MORE IN LOST REVENUE. EVERY
DOLLAR THEY HAVE IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL THE EMPLOYER HAS NO
DISCRETION TO DENY THE LEAVE
ABOUT THE INTEREST THE MULTIPLE
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE ON LEAVE SIR.
BONTA COMBINATIONS THE BUSINESS
MEDIA SPECIALIST FOR BUSINESSES
IS ASKING FOR TIME FUTURE THE
NEW MANDATE THAT WERE RECENTLY
PLACED ON THEM AND TO
RECUPERATE FINANCIALLY. ANOTHER
NEW MANDATE COULD COME AT THE
COST OF BRINGING ANOTHER
LEADER. WELL I MEAN I THINK
PLATE FROM CLOVE IT BACK TO
WORK. INDEED IN THE PAST WE'VE
ACTUALLY LABEL THIS BILL I
SUPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED OR CLOSE
BUT OUR MEMBERS ESPECIALLY
SMALL BUSINESSES CANNOT TAKE
ANOTHER MEETING RIGHT NOW AND
FOR THAT REASON THIS YEAR. WE
MUST OPPOSE EIGHTY NINE NINE
TIED TO JOB. KILLER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- LET'S GO TO THE-
PHONE LINES. FOR ANY. IN OP. TO
A- NINE NINE FIVE CAN I HAVE
THE FUNDS THEM PLEASE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB NINE
NINE FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE THREE
ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE ZERO
THREE YOUR MAYBE CAN YOU PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND ONE MOMENT FROM
THE OTHER NAMES TO BE GATHERED.
THREE THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MICHAEL
MILLER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FIND GREAT
POWERS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NINE THREE SEVENTY TWO. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO AGAIN ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WERE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE
OPPOSITION Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ALREADY SO THERE ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE- IF NOT UP%
WITH SOME RESULTS WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE GREAT SO WE ON THE
MOTION. HI SUMMER WARD SECONDED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON AB NINE NINE FIVE. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA HI ALL RIGHT I'D LARA
GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER STONE. HI STONE I DON'T
KNOW SARDONNO BOARD. BOARD HI.
PUTS THE BILL IS OUT. AND WE
WILL MOVE ON. TO A. B. TEN
SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU I'M AB
TEN SEVENTY FOUR STARTED OUT AS
A MUCH BROADER BILL WE HANDLED
A LOT OF THE ISSUES THANKS TO
BUDGET TRAILER BILL AND THANKS
TO OUR GOVERNOR AND THE
LEADERSHIP OF BOTH HOUSES- WHO
ENSURED THAT WE GOT A REHIRE
RIGHTS FOR OUR- HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY WORKERS IN AND LARGE
VENUES. ALL THIS BILL DOES NOW
IS LINE UP- HOTEL WORKERS WITH
A EXISTING ORDINANCE- THAT
COVERS JANITORIAL WORKERS UNDER
EXISTING LAW AFTER SERVICE
CONTRACT HAS BEEN TERMINATED A
SUCCESSOR JANITORIAL BUILDING
MAINTENANCE CONTRACTORS
REQUIRED. TO MAKE EMPLOYMENT
OFFERS TO RETAIN EXISTING
WORKERS BASED ON SENIORITY FOR
AT LEAST SIXTY DAYS. AB TEN
SEVENTY FOUR WOULD ADD
SIMILARLY SITUATED HOTEL
SERVICE WORKERS TO ITS
LONGSTANDING LAW. PATEL SERVICE
JOBS INCLUDING FOOD AND
BEVERAGE CLEANING GUEST
SERVICES ARE SIMILAR SIMILARLY
OUTSOURCED AND PERFORMED BY
CONTRACTED OR SUBCONTRACTED
EMPLOYEES THESE WORKERS
GENERALLY REPORT TO THE SAME
WORK SITE EACH DAY WEAR THE
UNIFORMS THE HOTEL THEY ARE
CLEANING. REPORT TO MANAGERS
AND SUPERVISORS ON SITE
REGARDLESS OF THE SPECIFIC
CONTRACTOR THAT THEY HAPPEN TO
BE WORKING FOR. THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PASSED SIMILAR LAWS IN
OTHER INDESTRUCTIBLE STREETS
PROVIDING RETENTION RIGHTS FOR
MINIMUM OF NINETY DAYS
INCLUDING FOR GROCERY WORKERS-
WHEN THE BUSINESSES THEY WORK
FOR GOES UNDER THAT GOES OUR
UNDERGOES A CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP. AS WELL AS FOR
PUBLIC TRANSIT AND WASTE
COLLECTION CONTRACTORS THIS IS
COMMONSENSE POLICY THAT WILL
ENSURE JOB SECURITY FOR
THOUSANDS OF OUR HARDEST HIT
WORKERS ARE MONEY PROBLEMS.
ALREADY I'M JUST TRYING TO GET
THROUGH AT THIS POINT I. DON'T
REMEMBER THE- HELLO. SO
SOMEBODY GOT THROUGH ON THE
PHONE LINE THAT WILL TAKE IT TO
I HAVE NO WAY- RIGHT HAPPY TO
GO TO SPEAK UP IN SUPPORT. OKAY
OF THANK YOUS ON THE MEMBER OF
IS THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
AB. TEN SEVENTY FOUR. ON THE
PHONE LINES. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN SEVENTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE THREE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SHOULD
INVESTMENT ON BEHALF OF UNITE
HERE AND THE TEAMSTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
TO EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JEFF IN ROWS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE THREE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE THREE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE LAST
PARTY. LIME THREE EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHEN A BORROWER WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIA ALSO SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q.
THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE ON TO A
POSITION OF TRUST FINAL
DECISION ON THE PHONE IS JOHN
PAUL WELL FOR THEIR JOURNEY MAY
BEGIN. MISTER CHAIRMAN JOHN
CALDWELL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION- AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF BOUTIQUE AND
BREAKFAST INNS- JUST LAST WEEK
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED SB NINETY
THREE A BUDGET BILL THAT IS
NEARLY IDENTICAL TO THE DELETED
PORTIONS OF AB TEN SEVENTY
FOUR. SB NINETY THREE WHICH IS
ALREADY THE LAW. CREATES A
BURDENSOME AND PAINFULLY SLOW
PROCESS TO BRING BACK LAID OFF
HOTEL EMPLOYEES. AB TEN SEVENTY
FOUR WHICH HAS BEEN AMENDED
DOWN TO THE ONE PROVISION THAT
DID NOT MAKE IT INTO. A SB
NINETY THREE ONLY ADDS TO THE
BURDENS TO AN INDUSTRY ALREADY
IN SERIOUS TROUBLE. UNDER THIS
BILL A HOTEL WILL FOREVER HAVE
TO KEEP THEIR EXISTING SERVICE
CONTRACTORS AND WOULD HAVE NO
DEFENSE AGAINST PRICE INCREASES
BY CONTRACTORS. IF THE
CONTRACTOR IS NOT MEETING THE
HOTEL STANDARDS A NEW
CONTRACTOR IS SIMPLY NOT GOING
TO ACCEPT THE EMPLOYEES OF THE
UNDERPERFORMING CONTRACTOR
HAVING NO INSIGHT TO THE
CURRENT EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
COMPENSATION. AS A RESULT
FINDING A REPLACEMENT. SIGN
REPLACEMENT FOR A BAD OR
SUBSTANDARD CONTRACTOR IS
UNATTAINABLE. EVEN ACQUIRING
COMPETITIVE BIDS AS A REGULAR
BUSINESS PRACTICE IS SEVERELY
THREATENED KEEP IN MIND THAT
THAT THE AVERAGE HOTEL YOU HAS
HUNDREDS OF CONTRACTED
PROVIDERS EVERYTHING FROM
FLORISTS TO PARKING TO PAYROLL
SERVICES. NOW IT'S PROBLEMATIC
AT S. B. NINETY THREE IS IT IS
LIMITED TO LAY OFF TO DO THE
CALL THE NINETEEN. THIS IS NOT
LIMITED TO COPE WITH SB NINETY
THREE AT THE SUNSET THIS DOES
NOT HAVE A SUNSET. M. S. B.
NINETY THREE WAS LIMITED TO
HOTELS WITH ROOMS WITH WITH
FIFTY RUNS OR MORE THIS BILL
APPLIES ALL HOTELS THIS. SMALL
BED AND BREAKFASTS THAT
TYPICALLY CONTRACT FOR MANY
SERVICES WILL BE COVERED BY
THIS BILL. OVER 20% OF ALL
HOTELS WERE CLOSED FOR AT LEAST
PART OF THE PANDEMIC AND THOSE
THAT REMAINED OPEN SAW
PRECIPITOUS DROP IN OCCUPANCY.
I HAD TO LAY OFF EMPLOYEES
ADDING TO THE BURDENS OF
RUNNING A HOTEL AS THIS BILL
DOES WILL MAKE IT THAT MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT FOR THIS
INDUSTRY. TO BRING BACK THOSE
LAID OFF WORKERS. THANK YOU I'M
IT THERE'S NO ONE IN IN THE
ROOMS OF ALL GO TO THE PHONES
OF FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TEN SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
YOU'LL GET THE MONEY CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU- WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR MOTIONS
ON- A. B. TEN SEVENTY FOUR.
OKAY THE MOTION AND A SECOND-
BY SURE. YES- THE OPPOSITION
CAN ACTUALLY COVERED A LOT OF
WHAT I WAS GONNA ASK BECAUSE I
DO THINK THIS IS VERY VERY
SIMILAR TO SB NINETY THREE THAT
WE JUST. WHETHER THE BUDGET. SO
I AM CURIOUS LIKE WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE. M. AND THEN QUITE
FRANKLY I KNOW THAT THE BILL'S
GONE AND IT'S MOVED ON. BUT-
WHY THAT BILL WAS IN THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL AND IT WASN'T
POLICY BILL AND THIS ONE IS A
WE'RE DEBATING IT NOW TODAY
BECAUSE- IT ESSENTIALLY IS
DOING AFFECT SAME THING. BUT
EXPANDING IT- TO SMALLER AND
TAKE OUT THE COVERT NINETEEN
PROVISIONS. SO IT'S IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE
AND I UNDERSTAND IT TO BE
HONEST IT DOES GET CONFUSING.
IF IT WERE- LIKE THE ORDINANCE
WE PASS FOR EXAMPLE FOR GROCERY
WORKERS NOT LONG AGO THAT THAT.
IS MORE SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
PASSED IN NINETY THREE- THAT
HAS THE PROTECTION UPON SALE
THAT THOSE WORKERS REMAIN PART
OF- GET THEY THEY GO WITH THE
SALE FOR NINETY DAYS THAT'S-
THAT'S WHAT WE HAD DO TO COPE
ED. IT IN NINETY THREE DOES
THAT MAKE SENSE. THIS HAS TO DO
WITH THE CONTRACTORS INSIDE THE
HOTEL SO WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
AND WORK SPACES MORE AND MORE
ESPECIALLY IN HOTELS IS. THEIR
HOUSEKEEPERS ARE DIRECT
EMPLOYEES OF THE HOTEL THEIR
DIRECT EMPLOYEES OF A
CONTRACTOR. AND OFF AND WE HAVE
THIS IN JANITORIAL WE'VE HAD
THIS PROTECTION FOR JANITORIAL
WORKERS FOR A LONG TIME OFTEN.
A NEW CONTRACTOR COME IN- AND
THEY SOMETIMES WILL JUST
REQUIRE THE SAME EMPLOYEES IT'S
A CHANGE OF CONTRACTOR THESE
THESE EMPLOYEES- THEY THEY
DON'T SIT THERE THERE LIKE
EMPLOYEES BUT THEY'RE OF THE
CONTRACTOR BUT THE WORKING
STRAIGHT THERE AT THE HOTEL SO
THIS WOULD JUST SAY WHEN YOU
CHANGE. A CONTRACTOR- YOU HAVE
TO GIVE THESE EMPLOYEES AN
OPPORTUNITY SHOW THIS NEW
CONTRACTOR THAT THEY'RE GOOD.
THEY ONLY GET SIXTY DAYS TO DO
THAT AND THEN AT THAT TIME THEY
CAN IN FACT- REPLACE BAD
EMPLOYEES IF YOU'RE WHAT IF
THEY'RE NOT PRODUCTIVE. BUT
THIS GIVES THEM THAT
OPPORTUNITY RATHER THAN HOST
WHOLESALE BUYERS- JUST BECAUSE
THE CONTRACTORS REMOTE. DURING
KOBE AT POST COVER THIS MAY BE
IMPORTANT ARE SOME CONTRACTORS
THAT MIGHT HAVE GONE OUT OF
BUSINESS YOU KNOW AND YET YOU
STILL HAVE THESE EMPLOYEES. WHO
ONCE WORKED AT THIS HOTEL- WHO
AREN'T COVERED BY BY A NINETY
THREE WHICH WAS IF THEIR DIRECT
EMPLOYEES OF THE HOTEL THIS IS
THAT THE CONTRACTORS. THAT MAKE
SENSE. IT DOES OKAY BUT IF WE
HAVE LIKE ROUGHLY ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND OF THESE
HOTEL EMPLOYEES. HAVE BEEN LAID
OFF BECAUSE OF COVERED RIGHT. I
THINK THAT'S THE NUMBER THAT'S
BEEN THROWN AROUND. SOMEWHERE
IN THAT BALLPARK SB NINETY
THREE AFFECTED SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND WORKERS SO I ACTUALLY
THINK IT'S BUT THAT. WAS LARGE
VENUES AND AIRPORTS CHAU SO
YEAH BUT ON THIS PARTICULAR
SECTOR OR DELIVER ON THIS BILL
IT'S I THINK IN THAT NUMBERS
DOESN'T THAT. WE DON'T GET A
LOT A LOT DON'T GET HUNG UP ON
THAT. BUT IF YOU. ARE A NEW
CONTRACTOR COMING IN. AND YOU.
TO BASICALLY GIVE THOSE
EMPLOYEES WITH EXISTING
EMPLOYEES SIXTY DAYS AND RIGHT
NOW WE'RE FIGHTING. DESPERATELY
THREE OPEN OUR ECONOMY. AND WE
HAVE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO COME
TO WORK. BUT WE HAVE SIXTY DAYS
THAT WE HAVE TO HOLD ONTO A
POSITION. FOR THIS OTHER
EMPLOYED AMERICANS WANT TO COME
BACK TO WORK OH NO NO NO NO NO
THAT'S NOT HOW THIS WORKS I'M
SORRY IT'S NOT NOW IN IN YOU
REALLY SHOULDN'T THINK OF THIS
IN A CO BID LET LET'S. IT IT
MAY BE EASIER TO THINK OF A WAY
AND WERE NOT IN COBIT RIGHT SO
IT WOULDN'T APPLY IN FACT UNTIL
IN JANUARY WHEN HOPEFULLY IF.
YOU'RE FOR LONG OUT A CODE RED
AND- BE HAPPY TO WORK ON SOME
LANGUAGE TO SUGGEST THAT IN
HERE AS WELL. SO NO IT IS A
SITUATION WHERE THE CONTRACT IS
AN ON GOING THE WORKERS HAVE
BEEN THERE ALREADY THEY WERE
ALREADY CAME BACK THERE WORKING
FOR A CONTRACTOR THERE'S A NEW
CONTRACTOR THAT COMES IN- THE
NEXT DAY THEY'RE NOT FIRED YOU
KNOW UNDER THE LAW RIGHT NOW
THEY COULD BE REPLACED. IT'S
OFTEN USED TO BE REALLY HONEST
IT AT CHANGE OF CONTRACT.
TOWARD IS OFTEN USED TO BUST AN
ORGANIZING DRIVE- QUITE
HONESTLY YOU KNOW IT IF THE
HOTELS LIKE WELL WE DON'T
REALLY WANT THOSE WORKERS TO BE
UNIONIZED EVEN THOUGH THEY'D BE
WORKING FOR THE SUB CONTRACTOR.
CONTRACTOR SAYS OH MY BROTHER
HAS A SIMILAR- CONTRACTOR. FIRM
YOU YOU WAIT WE CAN GET HOTEL
WORKERS AT. HOPE TELL
HOUSEKEEPERS FROM HIM. YEAH
WE'LL JUST END UP THE WAY TO
REPLACE WORKERS WHO ARE
ORGANIZING SO THIS JUST SAYS.
WELL YOU CAN REPLACE THE
CONTRACT. AND I KNOW FOR FOLKS
WHO AREN'T IN THE INDUSTRY- AND
WHEN WE DID JANITORIAL I THINK
IT FELT THE SAME WAY YOU DON'T
REALIZE THAT THESE CONTRACTORS.
ARE IN FACT USING THE SAME
LABOR PULL OVER AND OVER AND IN
DIFFERENT PLACES RIGHT IT'S
NOT. AS IF THEY THEY'RE COMING
IN ITH THEIR OWN LABOR- PULL
BECAUSE THEY'RE COMING INTO A
SITUATION WHERE THESE WORKERS
ARE WORKING FULL TIME AT THE
HOTEL. SO IT'S JUST. SAYING YOU
GOT TO GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
YOU'RE GOING TO GIVE THEM SIX
DAYS. C. YOU KNOW BY SENIORITY
IF YOU NEED FEWER PEOPLE THAT
MEANS A- SENIOR. GET THE ARE.
FIRST AGAIN WE'RE WORKING WITH
A FOR AT CLASS. AT OF WORK WHO
ARE- WOMEN OF. WOMEN WHO ARE
AGING AND WHO. SOMETIMES
REPLACED YOUNG CHEAPER. JUST
BECAUSE THAT'S THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT EXISTS IN THIS PARTICULAR
INDUSTRY NOT L. FINALISTS AND
WE'VE BEEN HERE FOR AWHILE- DO
YOU THINK. COMPETITION BETWEEN
CONTRACTORS LIKE POACHING OTHER
EMPLOYEES. HAVE YOU GONNA PUT
THAT IN THE FACILITY FOR A
WHILE AND A NEW CONTRACTOR
COMES IN THEY'LL SAY ALL MAFIA
DOLLAR FIFTY CENTS AN HOUR
MORE. COME WORK WITH ME. DO YOU
SEE THAT A LOT I I'VE NOT I'VE
NOT SEEN THAT A LOT LOW WAGE
WORK UNFORTUNATELY WITH WITH
WITH. YOU RANK AND FILE WORKERS
WITH SUPERVISORS OR MIGHT BE
THAT ISSUE BUT THIS PROVIDES-
INDIVIDUALS. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVE THEMSELVES WHO ARE
ALREADY BEEN WORKING AT THE
FACILITY. JANUARY THE EIGHTH
THAT'S BECAUSE LIKE IN THE
ATTIC. SACRAMENTO CA. ATONG ANG
SPECIALLY ON THE FRESH FRUIT-
HAND PICK STUFF. WHERE THE BASE
RATE WORKERS AND- AND FARMING
THAT THAT HAVE IT DOWN OUR
INCREDIBLE RIGHT SO YES I COULD
SEE WHERE THAT'S A PROBLEM THIS
IS- THIS WORK IS A DONE BY
PIECE WHERE. THAT THAT JUST
PROVIDE THE DIFFERENT INCENTIVE
I THINK ANYONE IS THAT THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT. YOU COULD BECAUSE- THE
FAST REALLY PRODUCTIVE AS-
OFTEN YOUNG- IT. HOOKING GET
THEIR STRAWBERRY VERY QUICKLY
YES THEY'RE VERY PRIZED-
EMPLOYEES FOR EVEN THE HOUSE
UNIT WITH. THE HOTEL CLEANERS I
MEAN THERE'S PROBABLY YOUNG
YOUNGER VIEW LOOKING CLEAN A
LOT QUICKER GET MORE ROOMS DONE
FASTER THAT IS RIGHT BUT THERE
ARE GUIDEINES TO AYE AYE IN
MOST HOTELS ON HOW MANY ROOMS
THEY EXPECTED TO SHIFTED. IN
AND THIS IS JUST AGAIN-
PROVIDING AN OLDER. WOMEN OF
COLOR WORKFORCE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO COMPETE BECAUSE AFTER SIXTY
DAYS THEY DON'T HAVE TO COMPETE
THAT KEEP THEM IF THEY HAVE
WORKPLACE OR PERFORMANCE ISSUES
THEY DON'T HAVE TO KEEP THEM.
THIS GIVES THEM THAT
OPPORTUNITY THOUGH. WHAT THANK
YOU ARMENIANS HAVE A MOTION- SO
WE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE RESULTS
FASTER AND I VOTE. THANK YOU.
SO ON A. B. A TWENTY SEVENTY
FOUR OF THEM CENTURY POSSIBLE
PLEASE. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA FIVE KALRA
I FLOOR NO FLOOR NO GONZALEZ.
HI GONZALEZ SIDE JONES SAWYER
STONE. ALL RIGHT STONE I SEE I
DON'T KNOW. IF YOU ARE DON'T
KNOW WORDS. FIVE WARD HI. BUT
IS OUT THERE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIR PRESENTING AB
SEVENTY TWO. WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY. THE BILL THAT THANK YOU
I THINK IT WAS SURE. THE PAST
YEAR HAS BEEN A TIME OF. A
DIFFICULT AND GREAT AWAKENING-
PLAYERS AND WORKERS IN THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY WERE HIT
PARTICULARLY HARD AS COVER
NINETEEN RESTRICTIONS MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO STAY OPEN-
MILLIONS OF JOBS LOST MANY
OWNERS HAD TO PERMANENTLY
SHUTTER THEIR BUSINESSES AND
WORKERS A BILL LEFT FOR MONTHS
WITHOUT. WORK OR A SAFETY NET.
OF THE MORE THAN THIRTEEN
MILLION RESTAURANT WORKERS THE
UNITED STATES MAJORITY OF WOMEN
JUST PORTION JUST FORTUNE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE OF COLOR.
ACTUALLY THE NATIONAL WAGE GAP
OF NEARLY FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR
BETWEEN BLACK WOMEN AND WHITE
MEN WHO HOLD TIPPED IN
MANAGEMENT POSITIONS IN THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY. IS OFTEN
THE RESULT OF HIRING
DISCRIMINATION IMPLICIT BIAS
AND OCCUPATIONAL SEGREGATION
AND THE INDUSTRY. I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY TWO
WHICH WILL DIRECT THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO ESTABLISH
A PROGRAM TO TRAIN RESTAURANT
EMPLOYEES MANAGERS. EMPLOYERS
TO IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS
DISPARITIES IN THE WORK FORCE.
AND IMPLEMENT A HIGH ROAD
EMPLOYMENT POLICIES. UNDER THIS
BILL THE BOARD WILL TAKE BIDS
FROM COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT SERVICES
THAT PROMOTE WORKPLACE
DIVERSITY. THE BILL RECOGNIZES
THE IMPORTANCE OF CREATING
PATHWAYS WITHIN THE INDUSTRY
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS
WOMEN AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRANSGENDER NON BINARY AND
INTERSEX. RESTAURANTS HAVE
COMPLETED THE TRAINING OF
IMPLEMENTED THE HIGH ROAD
EMPLOYMENT POLICIES. WILL BE
CERTIFIED AS A HIGH ROAD
RESTAURANT. AND BE ABLE TO
ADVERTISE THEMSELVES AS SUCH.
THIS BILL OF AFFECTED TO CREATE
ANOTHER HYDRO TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP AND BE PART OF A
LARGER INITIATIVE TO ADVANCE A
FIELD OF PROFITS THAT ADDRESSES
INCOME INEQUALITY AND ECONOMIC
COMPETITIVENESS. HIERO TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS DEVELOP SOLUTIONS
TO IMPROVE WORKER RETENTION
UPSKILLING AND RESKILLING AND
UTILIZE WORKER TO HELP SHAPE
TRAINING PROGRAMS. WITH THESE
HIGH ROAD TRAINING POLICIES IN
PLACE WE CAN START TO REPLICATE
RACIAL AND GENDER DISPARITIES
IN THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY.
THAT PROMOTE EQUITY AMONG
WORKERS I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE.
THAT THERE WAS A LADY THAT WAS
LAID OPPOSITION. OF INCUMBENT
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WANTED
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE HAD A
CHANCE TO ENGAGE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT ENGAGE AND I'M
SURE THEY'LL BE. OTHER THING A
FEW WORDS ALLOW AS WELL. OF
ESPECIALLY AFTER I BOUGHT AND-
BY TELEPHONE OF THE WE HAVE A
PRIMARY WITNESS OF MIKEY NAB.
WHO'S THE NATIONAL STRATEGY
DIRECTOR FOR REYES HI ROAD
RESTAURANTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MODERATOR.
CAN WE OPEN PHONE LINES FOR
MAKING UP. YOU NEVER KNOW WHEN
YOU NEED. YES WELL AS WE GOT
TO. OKAY OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THIS INCREDIBLE BILL- I
DIDN'T MAKE IT OUT I STARTED
THE DISHWASHER WHEN I WAS
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD AND NOW I RUN
THE MET THE FAMILY RESTAURANT
GROUP WITH THE RESTAURANT IN
SAN DIEGO BOOK CALLED PUMP THAT
MEXICAN RESTAURANT AND ANOTHER
IN PORTLAND OREGON KALRA. YOU
SOME OF THE NATIONAL STRATEGY.
FOR A PRIVATE RESTAURANT WHICH
IS A NATIONAL NETWORK OF OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED OWNERS YOU'VE
MADE THE COMMITMENT TO RACE AND
GENDER EQUITY IN OUR INDUSTRY.
WE CONCEIVED OF AND LAUNCHED
THE HIGHER EDUCATION PROGRAM IN
RESPONSE TO COPE IN A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR AND
WORKFORCE BOARDS- THE PRORAM
PROVIDED RELIEF FUND TO ALMOST
FIFTY RESTAURANTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THE COMMITTED TO
INCREASE WAGES. WRITTEN GENDER
EQUITY AND PROVIDING FIVE
HUNDRED FEMALE TO COMMUNITY. TO
THE COMMUNITY. ONE OF THE TOP
THIS YEAR THE INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANTS ABOUT PERHAPS. THE
PROGRAM OF BOTH THE PASSPORT
ADVANTAGE IN YORK BOSTON
CHICAGO NORRLAND. IN TEXAS THAN
IT CURRENTLY BEING THE TOP OF
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. ONE OF THE
COMMITMENTS MADE BY
PARTICIPATING RESTAURANTS WITH
TO GO THROUGH THE BREAKING
GENDER EQUITY TRAINING OFFERED
TO OUR MEMBERS. AND THE RESULT
OF AN ASTOUNDING. IT MEANT
HIRING CHANGE AND CLOSE
PRACTICE THAT ARE IN THE- HAVE
LONG ADOPTED. THAT THE- RACIAL
AND GENDER AND- LEAVING WOMEN
pWITHIN FACT THE PROFESSOR
LETTER. BY LEARNING HOW TO VIEW
THE FACT THAT THE THROUGH THE
LENS OF EQUITY. OPERATIVE THE
CONTACT DATA BEEN ABLE TO
ATTRACT AND RETAIN GREAT
TALENT. AT A TIME WHEN THERE'S
A SEVERE LABOR SHORTAGE IN OUR
INDUSTRY. WHILE ALSO INCREASING
DIVERSITY AMONG NINETEEN SO THE
DESKTOP LOOK MORE LIKE THE
COMMUNITY. THE THREE BALTIC. A
PART OF THE TRAINING INCLUDED
IT UP IN A CURRENT PRACTICE OF
INTRACTABLE CONVICTED
INTERJECTED. WHAT BEEN
HAPPENING HERE TO PARTICIPATE.
I HAVE COMPLETED THE TRAINING
THE RESULTS THE PARTY SHOWN.
PRODUCED TURNOVER INCREASED
LOYALTY AMONG STAFF. AND
INCREASE QUALITY OF. SERVICE IT
ALL OUTLINED IN THE REPORT
pSUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE
ENTITLED INCREASING RACIAL
EQUITY IN CALIFORNIA RESTROOM
STRING. IMPORTANT RECORD OF
RESTAURANT HONORED THAT I
BELIEVE DESERVE TO BE SHARED.
UNDER CONTROL FROM BACK HOME
AND FLAWS IN PETALUMA AND
FAVORITE AT THE RESPECTIVELY
SAID. WE ALWAYS TRY TO BE
DEEPENING THEM BUT I THINK THAT
WHAT TWENTY TWENTY REALLY
TAUGHT ME A LOT OF MY BLIND
SPOT. I THINK HAVING A LEFT IN
THE TRADING FROM HIGHROAD.
FURTHER SHOWED ME HOW THE BLIND
SPOT. GET EVEN FURTHER AHEAD.
THAT BALANCE IN CLOAK AND PETAL
INTENDED THAT HIGH KITCHEN A
LOT ATTENTION THE- TO THE VALUE
IN CULTURE OF ALL THE
PROVISIONS. REST TO ALLOW
NEPALI DON'T. THE THAT YOU
COMPANY WILL. TO IT HIRING
RESTAURANT A- IN PARTICULAR
CURRENTLY DEVELOPING A
BLUEPRINT FOR MORE EQUITABLE
HIRING PRACTICES. AND HIRING
KITCHEN PROGRAM ACTIVATION
EQUITY TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
DIFFICULT PROGRAM. HELPED HER
DEVELOP IDEA TO THE BLUEPRINT.
CORRECT BONTA. REP OWNER AND
THEN TO GO THROUGH. CHAIN WE
ARE CREATING A WIN WIN WIN
SITUATION WHERE RESTAURANT
OWNERS. ARE ABLE TO ATTRACT AND
RETAIN A DIVERSE WORKFORCE.
REDUCING TURNOVER INCREASING
QUALITY. WOMEN WORKERS
TRANSGENDER WORKERS AND WORKERS
OF COLOR GAIN BETTER ACCESS TO
HIGHER IN POSITION. AND A
PROFESSIONAL ATTITUDE. AND
CONSUMERS CAN ENJOY FOOD AND
EMPLOYMENT IN THE PAPER MORE
EQUITABLE STATE. PREPARED IN
THIRD BY TEAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
EMPLOYERS IN BATON EQUITABLE
AND DIGNIFIED FUTURE. STRONGLY
ARGUED. FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL
GO NOW TO ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM AND SUPPORT.
SEEN NOBODY WAS MODERATOR WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE SEVENTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. LINE TWO EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU JEFF IN ROWS ON
BEHALF OF. NINE THREE EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BERNAY BAYARDO WITH SEIU%
CALIFORNIA COURT. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS AND- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MOVE OPPOSITE. TO
TESTIFIED OPPOSITION WE HAVE
MATT SUTTON BY PHONE NOW TO
YOUR ONLINE SYSTEM. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
WITHOUT A CHECK WE'VE GOT TO.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- IN
THINKING MEMBERS AND I HAVE
BEEN A LONG DAY- MAYBE FIVE
SEVENTY TWO I'LL BE VERY FOR
THE FOR DAYS AGO AND FRANK IT'S
BASED A FALSE. I THINK THE
NORTHERN DIVERSITY NETWORK NO
IN THE RESTAURANT COMMUNITY
IT'S ACTUALLY NOTHING SHORT OF
A THAT THE COLLATERAL FACTION
AND FORTUNATE ISSUED ON THIS
BILL BY THE AUTHOR'S OFFICES
IT'S GOT INFLAMMATORY. AND SAYS
THIS. OF RACISM AND THE
RESTAURANT. NOTHING FURTHER
FROM THE TRUTH THE OVERALL
STORY THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
WORK FORCES ONE OF DIVERSITY
WE'VE SHARED THAT WITH MANY A
FEW 64% OF WAIT STAFF ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR 80% OF CHEFS
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR LIKE NEARLY
70% OF MANAGERS ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR. NEARLY 70% OF
SUPERVISORS ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR
60% OF CALIFORNIA RESTAURANTS.
ARE OWNED BY PEOPLE OF COLOR.
SO RESTAURANTS PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL UP. TO BID AT TALKED
THE IN. THE ALL BACK. AGES AND
STAGES OF THEIR- PRESS MAKE IT
THEM DIVERSE WORK FOR IN THE
NAME. I'M MORE PROUD OF THAT.
AND MORE FOR TO BE THE
DIFFERENCE VOICE THE K. REST.
FOOD SERVICE CAN. BUT WE
WELCOME ENOUGH. TO SPEAK TO
WITH THE OFFICE AND OTHERS.
ABOUT THE GREAT TO THE TO
SERVICE. BUT WE ARE. AND WE'RE
PROUD OF IT AND WE OPPOSE THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE OF
OPPOSITE IN THE ROOM. C. NINE
TO MODERN DO WE HAVE NOT TO
LINE. MYSTERY DO WE HAVE ANY UP
IN OPPOSITION PHONE LINE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE
SEVENTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE
SEVENTY TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE I DO HAVE A QUESTION
FOR- THE FIRST SUPPORTER WHO
SPOKE FROM- MIKEY I'D LIKE HIM
TO RESPOND TO. AS THE
RESTAURANTS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION AND KIND OF
ASSERTION THAT THAT MAYBE THERE
ARE RACIAL INEQUITIES IN THIS-
ELECTED MAKING THAT I CAN USED
ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
WELCOME THE OPPOSITION THANK
PERCENTAGE OF THE PUTTING FORTH
FOR THAT INFORMATION TO WEIGH
IN ON A NUMBERS I CAN'T SAY
THAT. THERE IF YOU'RE NOT
MENTIONED THERE OUT AND MY
THOUGHT YOU THAT WOULD FROM THE-
VERSION BETTER CALLED ENDING
JIM CROW AMERICA'S RESTAURANTS.
AND SEGREGATION AND READ. AND
BASICALLY THE REST ON SHE COULD
BE. AND THREE BIRTH HI AND FINE
DINING RESTAURANT WITH HIGHER
MY PRICES IN THERE FOR HI CHIPS
RIGHT THERE. I WILL REST ON
WOULD LOWER MY PRICES ON BOTH.
EVERYONE OF THE CLIP THE HIGHER
EARNING JOBS THE MORE I BILL BY
WHITE. AND THE LOWER POSITION
THE MOP TELL BUT YOU OF COLOR.
THE IMPLICIT CLAIM MADE.
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANTS.
POPULOUS TO FILL IN THE
DEMONSTRATION GENDER DOES NOT
ACCEPT THEM CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANTS AND I TO GET ALL- I
FIND IT STRANGE THAT ORDER TO
DO. CLAIMS ARE FOR. WILL BE TO
THE POINT OF THIS TO A BILL
THAT WOULD SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
TRAINING FOR RESTAURANT MANAGE.
AND THE BIRTH. OF THE WAY FORCE
TO KEEP TALKING BY. LOOKING FOR
A PLACE TO IMPOSE ITSELF. EARLY
ON YOU SAID THAT THERE'S THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT IS SWEEPING
THROUGH THESE DIFFERENT STATES
IN THE RESTAURANTS THAT ARE
DOING IT ARE. FINDING IT SUCH A
HUGE BENEFIT TO THEM. IF THAT
SO BECAUSE I CAN I CAN
GUARANTEE YOU. EVERY SINGLE
RESTAURANT OWNER WANTS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. AND IF THIS IS THE
PROGRAM IT'S MAKING THEM
SUCCESSFUL. WHY AREN'T THEY
JUST DOING IT RIGHT THEY JUST
SIGNING UP AND- BEING PART OF A
PROGRAM- I'M I'M CURIOUS WHY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
TAXPAYERS OF CLIFORNIA. HAVE
TO. HAVE TO PROVIDE THAT
PROGRAM FOR THEM WELL THIS IS
WELL THAT SHOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT THEY PROVIDE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THERE'S THE PERSONAL
THERE'S NOT A MANDATED PROGRAM
AND AS INDICATED THERE'S BEEN
THE HIGH ROAD KIDS PROGRAM IS
A- NEW. PROGRAM THAT THAT THAT
THAT WE'RE JUST GETTING SOME
RESULTS FROM SO- INTRACTBLE
IT'S SO NEW THAT THE REPORT.
THE FIRST APARTMENT MARKET
REGION R. ONE FAIR WAGE AND
FOOD LABOR RESEARCH CENTER THAT
WE- PUT ON THE ON YOUR DESK
HERE. IS LITERALLY DATED
TODAY'S DATE SO- THIS IS A NEW.
ENDEAVOR BUT AGAIN- IT THAT THE
IDEA IS THAT WE- ARE OFFERING
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RESTAURANTS TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR POLICIES ARE CONSISTENT.
WITH THE HIGH ROAD EMPLOYMENT
AND IF. OF THE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION SAY THEY'RE ALREADY
DOING A GREAT JOB THAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A WHOLE BUNCH OF
RESTAURANTS. THEY'RE GONNA
QUITE EASILY QUALIFY AS I RODE
PLAYERS. IN THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY. THANK YOU- I JUST
HAVE ONE COMMENT IT WILL ALSO
MAKE COMMENTS- JUST HAVE ONE
COMMENT BECAUSE- ON- IS BECAUSE
THIS BILL AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN.
ONE OF OUR CHIEF WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THAT WAS MAKAYLA
WHO IS A TRANSGENDER FRANCHISEE
OWNER ONE OF THE LARGEST IN EL
POLLO LOCO OWNERS. I THINK YOU
HAVE A GREAT PERSPECTIVE OF
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RIGHT
HERE ON. HOW TO MAKE THIS MORE
EQUITABLE FOR A LOT OF
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES. SO I DO
THINK THAT THE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION IS MOVING FORWARD I
DID NOT A 100% SURE THAT THIS
IS NECESSARY BUT I. I DO CAN I
WISH TO MAKE A LIST ON THE
PHONE LINE BECAUSE I WOULD
ACTUALLY LOVE HER PERSPECTIVE
ON THIS I THINK SHE WOULD BRING
A VERY VERY FASCINATING
PERSPECTIVE SO WITH THAT BEING
SAID- ANYBODY ELSE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU AND TO THE
POINT ACTUALLY AFFORD REACHING
UP REACHING OUT TO MAKAYLA THAT
OCCUR RIGHT AND IN FACT YOU
KNOW MIKE UNITED WITH HIMSELF
AS A RESTAURATEUR SO. WE HAVE A
LOT TO LEARN. FROM THOSE THAT
ARE RUNNING THE RESTAURANTS
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT THAT'S
PART OF THE PROCESS AND- ONE
THING I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE- HONDA.
PROCLUS IN ON ON THE LANGUAGE
IN THE- IN THE FACT SHEET
REGARDING SYSTEMIC RACISM. BY
THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN THE
FACTION IS THAT- STRUCTURAL
RACISM STRANGLEHOLD THROUGHOUT
ALL OF YOUR SOCIETY. THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY IS NO
EXCEPTION I WOULD CLAIM THAT-
YOU KNOW THAT THAT THE RACISM
IS. SOMETHING WE'RE ALL TRYING
TO MOVE FORWARD FROM AND
IMPROVE AND DO BETTER. AND I
THINK THAT WE DO HAVE A LOT TO
BE PROUD OF IN THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA. AND THE
IDEA BEHIND THIS IS A TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD AND I
THINK THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THIS PROGRAM. TO DO THAT-
AND TO USE THE GREAT DIVERSITY
THAT'S ALREADY IN ARE IN THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY. AND MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVANCE AND. AND
TO HAVE A JOB THEIR PRODUCTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A- WAS
CALLED. BUSH IS DUE PASSED TO
PER CALL FIVE KALRA AYE FLORIDA
I PROMISE ALSO YES AGAINST
POINT MEL. LORD KNOWS GONZALEZ
I GET SALAS AYE JONES SAWYER
STONE. STONE I DON'T. NO SEE I
DON'T KNOW LORD LORD HI ABILITY
THE FIGURE BILLS OUT ALL RIGHT
MISTER CHAIR WE'RE GOING TO
PRESENT THE FINAL BILL THE DAY.
FIFTEEN OH SIX. THIS BILL BIG
SUPPORT THAT MOMENT THE
DEFINITIONAL CALIPERS CAPTION
OR PUBLIC WORKS ARE PERFORMED
THE FOURTEENTH FOR TO BY THE
COUNTY WHICH PUBLIC WORKS FOR
THE COUNTY WHICH FOCUSED ON ALL
CASES. ON HIS CHAIR THE NUMBERS
BUCKLEY ASTRO VOTE. AND I SEE
THAT THERE IS NO. WITNESS OF
AMAZING- MISTER MODERATE ANYWAY
IN SOME ON THE PHONE. FOR A. B.
FIFTEEN OH SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER TURNER IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
OH SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SEEING NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM. IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
ON THE PHONE LINES. AB. FIFTEEN
OH SIX. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN ON
FIXING A PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CA NO WITNESSES IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. CNN MISTER WOULD
LIKE CLOSE YES MY VOTE. ADAM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
HELLO I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND. YEAH I WAS GONZALEZ AND
MR STONE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR KALRA
FIVE KALRA I FLOOR NO FLOOR
UNKNOWN GONZALEZ GONZALEZ DIED
JONES SAWYER STONE. STONE HI
ZERO NOT VOTING SCIARRETTO NOT
VOTING WARD. ACTUALLY WARD HI
THAT BILL IS THAT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND- MADAM SECRETARY IF
YOU CAN I THINK WE HAVE- A BILL
THAT'S ON CALL. IF YOU CAN CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS WITHOUT BILL
PLEASE. BILL ON CALL IS A B.
ELEVEN OH FIVE RODRIGUEZ
FLORIDA. NUMBER FLORIDA NOT
VOTING GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES SAWYER STONE STONE I.
THAT THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
AND LET'S GET TOGETHER ALL THE-
I THINK THAT WAS ONLY WHEN I
WAS ON PAUSE LET'S GET THE ADD
ONS IN THE MEANTIME OR WAITING
FOR THAT AND WAITING FOR SUMMER
JONES SAWYER AND FOR FOLKS OUT
ON I JUST WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE THAT I THINK THIS IS
ARE. A LOT OF WORK WAS DONE ON
A GOOD REPLY TO BILLS I JUST
WANT TO GIVE A THANK YOU TO OUR
SECRETARY LAURIE OVER AS A
CONSULTANT MARTIN IN YELLOW
WHO'S BEEN WORKING AND FROM
INVESTORS NOT A POINT TO MAKE
SURE EVERYTHING WENT SMOOTHLY
AND TO MY CHIEF CONSULTANT
LEADERSHIP CONSULTANT AND MY
CHIEF OF STAFF MAKE ELAINE SO
LAST MONTH THANK THEM. FOR ALL
THE WORK THEY PUT IN- IN THE
WEEKS AND- LEADING UP TO THE
HEARINGS. THAT WE'VE HAD- SO OF.
MADAM SAID. TO GO THROUGH. THE
WILL BE. AFRAID H. NINETY.
THREE ABSENT MEMBERS STONE-
STONE HI. AB SEVEN EIGHTY THREE
GRAY STONE FIVE STONE I. EIGHTY
SIX FIFTY STONE FIVE STONE I.
CONSENT CALENDAR. SB SIX FORTY
THREE AND TWELVE SEVENTY THREE
FLORA FLORA HI. EIGHTY SEVEN
YES. EIGHTY SEVEN- I'VE GOT UP
TO MEMBERS FLOOR BOB OF FLORIDA
NOT VOTING GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
STONE STONE I. A. B. ELEVEN OH
FIVE JONES SAWYER. AB. SIX ONE
SIX NUMBER JONES SAWYER. SURE.
A. B. SEVEN OH ONE AT THE
MOMENT. EIGHTY NINE NINE FIVE
ABSENT MEMBER FLORIDA. NUMBER
REALLY. LARA NOT VOTING JONES
SAWYER ON AB NINE NINE FIVE AND
SALAS THAT'S THE ACT. A. B. TEN
SEVENTY FOUR- ABSENT MEMBERS
JONES SAWYER. HI JONES SAWYER I.
AB FIVE SEVENTY TWO KALRA JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER HI. AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX JONES SAWYER-
RIGHT WELL THAT'S HERE FINE.
JONES SAWYER I AB ELEVEN TWO
JONES. THAT'S THE HI. JONES
APPEARED ON HIS I SEE YOU GOT
YOUR OTHER. LIKE THIS. THE
PROPOSAL. ONCE. NINE NINE. BUT
YOU'RE CHANGING YOUR BOTH.
THANK YOU READY THANK YOU THANK
THANK YOU. GEO OF STUFF THE-
OKAY LET'S SEE HERE AB A OF JOE
SAWYER. THAT- FOR THREE
RODRIGUEZ HI. JONES SAWYER I.
LET'S SEE. A. B. C. ONE SIX
STONE YEAH JONES SAWYER ALL THE
JUST GAP SO THAT'S WHAT I. IN
SCHOOL I. AB TWO FIFTY. AND SO
ABSENT MEMBERS JOHN SAWYER.
WHAT WAS THE PHONE OUT THAT. IT
IS THE BILLS ARE HAVE FLOOR TO
ITS OF OUR- JONES HI. AB SEVEN
NO AND GONZALEZ BILL JOAN
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER HI. AB
NINE NINE FIVE VOTE FLOOR FROM
NOT TO KNOW. I'M ENOUGH. YOU
ARE ALREADY ON THE SIR. WE ARE
CLEAR. EVERYTHING EVERYTHING
OUT SURVIVOR EVERYBODY ARE
TRYING.